hey guys and welcome to react beach
resort project where we'll display hotel
rooms and set up functionality so the
user can filter them as well
during this project we'll use react
router for our routing react context api
for our state management content full
headless cms for our data management and
netlify to host our application so
what in the world we will build well
first and foremost i do want to let you
know that project will be responsive and
since i don't want to jump back and
forth for every section that i'm showing
you i might as well tell you that right
away and for the navbar on a smaller
screen size we're going to have a toggle
button so this is how the nav bar will
be displayed in smaller screen size but
then once we go to the bigger one we
will gonna have our traditional navbar
right after the navbar on the home page
there will going to be a hero component
that we're gonna have a background image
and in the middle of the hero component
we're going to have a banner that has a
link to route to our rooms page since
we're not done with the homepage we will
then head over back and then we're going
to have services where we're going to
use react icons to display the services
that the hotel provides after that we're
going to have future rooms so imagine
you're going to have data for all the
rooms in the hotel but some rooms hotel
would want a display as featured so
these were going to be a featured rooms
now in both pages whether that will
going to be featured rooms or all rooms
together
we will going to use the room component
to display that one specific room and as
you notice in the room component there
will be price for the room as well as
the name for the room and as i'm
hovering over the card we're gonna have
an option of clicking and then we're
gonna navigate to a single room page
where we're gonna have information just
about that specific room page whether
that will be let's say our family deluxe
room or it will be single deluxe again
i'm heading over there this will be a
unique picture about that specific room
as well as rest of the information that
would tell us more about this specific
room since we are using the react router
i also want to let you know that if
let's say we're going to be
trying to navigate to a page that
doesn't exist we are going to create a
custom 404 page where it says okay so
page not found and obviously we have
either option of clicking return home or
we can navigate through a navbar now
once we're done with the homepage notice
these are the sections we're creating
now let's head over here to a rooms page
where we're going to have all the rooms
that currently hotel provides as well as
since we have multiple rooms the user
will also going to have an option of
filtering them out so let's say i'm not
interested in all the rooms i would just
be interested in the family rooms this
displays me all the family rooms that
hotel provides and like i already
previously said we still have an access
to a single room page where we're
navigating to that specific room then
once we look at the family rooms this is
what we're interested we also have an
option of filtering even more let's say
judging by the price and if i'm going to
go below
the price that i'm looking for notice it
says unfortunately no rooms match your
search parameters now what does that
mean if we're gonna have no rooms to
display that would match the search
parameter this is gonna be our error
message we can filter our rooms even
more let's say i could look for family
rooms that only providing the breakfast
as well as the pets are allowed
now in this case this particular room
allows
pets as well as provides free breakfast
however i can check maybe for the rooms
that only allow pets all right now this
is just going to give me the rooms allow
pets but if i would want breakfast then
obviously i'm going to be heading over
back to that one room within the family
room tab then i can also say you know
what i would be interested in let's say
staying four people so let's see which
rooms allow to have four people and then
this one obviously doesn't allow four
people that's the reason why it's not
showing you now hopefully this gives you
an idea what we're going to be building
and why don't we talk about where we're
going to store our data now first and
foremost
initially we were going to have all
local data that i'm going to provide so
even if you don't want to work with
contentful or netfly which by the way
we're going to use both of them free
tier so you'll not have to pay anything
but let's in say that you just don't
want to work with content folder or
netlify
you'll be able to finish your whole
project just with the local data that
i'm going to provide in the setup files
now later on once we're done with the
project we were going to take a look at
how we can set up the contentful which
is a headless cms or also something
called boyf which means bring your own
front end and what's really cool about
contentful that regardless of the
application that you're building whether
that would be with vanilla js whether
with the gatsby project with our react
project which would be our case we can
set up our data and then using the cdn
we're going to be able to consume our
data what's really cool about connectful
that once we're done with our
application once we're going to set up
all our data within the contentful
it will be possible for us
just to add changes within the control
and we'll not have to store our project
locally our machine just to change
something delete data edit the data and
so on and so forth last but not least
like i said we're going to use free tier
netify to host our amazing application
so the whole world can see it as far as
setup files go they will be located on
my github account so you can search for
setup files react beach resort or just
follow the link that i will leave in
description i also want to let you know
that if you like project-based courses
be sure to check out my udemy courses
where we cover topics like react
javascript gatsby and styled components
just to name a few in the description of
the video you'll find 10 dollar course
coupons before we tackle the project i
do want to mention two things
first as far as styling is concerned we
will use one main css file available in
the setup files and since it is react
project we will cover css very briefly
only when i find it useful or for
understanding our whole setup
second while developing application only
one react hook will be used use context
hook and only because we will look at
multiple options of consuming context
api
all right assuming that you installed
these setup files i think we can kick it
off and start working on our application
and the first thing that i would like to
do is bootstrap the react application
using the create react app now i'm gonna
go with npx route but obviously you can
install this globally or assuming that
you already have this globally you can
just run create react app and then
whatever the name of your project will
be now i'm going to call my resort so
what i'm going to do right now i'm going
to navigate to desktop
once in the desktop like i said i'm
going to run npx
then we're gonna go with create react
app so
now i would need to just come up with a
name and i'm gonna go with resort
while i'm right now bootstrapping the
react application i would wanna show you
what you're going to have within the
setup files so here you're going to have
three files as well as the images folder
and this is going to be used for
redirect so i'm going to show you what's
happening in the next video then app.css
will be the main css file for the whole
application
data will be the local data that we're
going to be using while we're developing
the application prior to when we are
hooking up actually everything with the
contentful so this is very important
otherwise it's going to be very hard for
you to code along and then last but not
least we have the images again which we
will use while we're developing this
locally as well as later on once you're
setting up the contentful this might be
useful where basically as you're
creating more and more items you can
just grab here the images that we're all
going to be using okay now also you'll
notice there's a gif one for the loading
so there's going to be a case where we
would want to set up the component as
let's say some kind of page part loads
so this is we're all going to be using
the gifs all right now once you have all
this installed then obviously what's
next is happening is that the
application currently is being
bootstrapped so we can see that we have
a bunch of dependencies that are being
installed with create react app and once
that will be finished
in fact before we run npm start and we
actually start the development server i
would want to install these two
dependencies because we're going to use
them right away so i didn't see the
point of starting the dev server and
then in fact stopping it install these
two dependencies now one of them will be
react icons and the second one will be
react router dom which we'll use for our
routing so in this case i would want to
navigate to my resort folder so since
the name is quite simple i can just say
cd resort and then let's run npm install
i'm gonna go with the react icons first
and then once they will be installed now
we're gonna go with react router down
and then after that i would want to open
up right away my text editor as always i
have a few options i can do it directly
here from the terminal where i can just
type code dot or i can just go with drag
and drop now this would be my first
application or i'm sorry not application
the dependency and then i'm going to go
with npm
install again or we can just write i
react
router
dom
and we can just go with dash dash save
as well just in case okay now once we
install both of these dependencies like
i said i would want to open up my text
editor
and in this case this will be visual
studio code
we'll drag and drop and we're going to
get our folder i can might as well
minimize this we will not gonna need
that
and let's open side by side
window so that way we can have two
browser windows one is gonna be the
small one
where we're gonna see everything that
we're doing as we're developing the
application and the second one will
going to be the bigger browser window
where we let's say want to say how the
grid works okay now in this case i will
going to open up the terminal the
integrated terminal in the visual studio
code by the way if you don't know where
it is this would be the new terminal and
i am using the shortcut here of course
and then why don't we run the dev server
so npm
start we all going to start the local
dev server which will serve our project
on localhost 3000. now like i said this
would be the finished project that we're
going to be striving to achieve and then
i would want to set by side by side with
localhost 3000 where this will be the
project that we're currently working on
okay now this will be the setup and
assuming that you followed all the steps
and everything was successful i think we
can move on to our next phase of our
application first things first i would
want to do a bit of a spring cleaning
because obviously this comes with a
bunch of things that we don't want and
we can start simply by app.css now you
have two choices either you can import
right away my file that you have in
setup files meaning you can just replace
it by drag and dropping or you can clean
out here and just copy and paste the
content of the setup file css file this
is really up to you in my case i'm just
going to delete this
and we're going to create a new one
later on when we're going to grab my app
css from the setup files
then i'm going to head over obviously to
the app.js and for the time being we're
just going to comment this out because
otherwise our application obviously
we're gonna break
then we can head over maybe to index.js
and i would want to comment out
index.css
because like i already said three times
probably our main css file will be just
one so we don't need the second one with
the index css
then we don't need the logo svg
so we can just delete this sucker as
well
so let's say logo svg you go
bye-bye
then what we have well again we have app
js breaking so why don't we do very
simply by deleting everything that we
have currently in the div
and we can just have i don't know maybe
a react fragment in this case
and we can just say okay within the rack
fragment we're going to place a hello
from app just for the time being
hello from app now let's save that and
there should be no errors i'm apart from
the fact that i'm trying to import the
logo of course
so i can delete that and yes everything
is working correctly we do have our
hello from map
then uh we will gonna head over to the
public one and within the index html i
would just want to create a new title
because at the moment i have react app
and i'm going to call my one resort
resort recording recording all right now
let's say that this is going to show me
two things where i have beach resort
that will be my finished one and then i
have a resort recording now
as far as the setup files are concerned
why don't we go over to the setup folder
and we're gonna go one by one so here we
have the redirects and like i said i
will gonna talk about redirects in this
video and in fact i'm gonna do that
right now so what happens is since we're
using the react router dom
they don't play very nicely right out of
the box with a netlify where we will
going to be hosting our application
eventually and what happens is that the
fix is very simple
you need to actually get this redirect
file so if you want more information
again you can head over to the google
you just type react router down and
pretty much this is going to be the
first blog that comes up and like i said
we just need to grab that file and that
file needs to be in the public folder
and that way whenever we're going to be
redirected or any kind of routing that
we're going to do in metal file will in
fact work exactly the same like it would
work locally with just a react rotor
dump so i'm going to grab this redirects
i would want to copy this guy and then
we're gonna head over to the public and
just copy and paste it right here like i
said if you want more information if
you're gonna head over to the blog
you can just read what is actually
happening and what would be the case
scenario why we wouldn't want to use
that and notice we have the redirects
now that is obviously the file name and
then we have our index html now
technically this would come up only
later once we deploy it on nutify but i
think that we can just get it out of the
way because maybe eventually i might
forget
now next one up we do have our app css
like i said this is going to be our main
css file so i will gonna right now copy
this
and we're gonna head over back to folder
of the source
and just copy and paste it somewhere in
the source now it is important that you
actually use the same structure as i am
where the files are at because i do have
already some paths here so let's say
when i'm setting up the hero backgrounds
or something like that i am already
having some kind of paths so it's
important if you change the path notice
i'm actually looking for the images
folder layer now and then if you're
going to place this file somewhere else
obviously it's not going to make sense
so
that's why i'm suggesting either you
follow the folder structure exactly
by the letter or if you are actually
creating your own folder structure then
obviously just keep in mind that
whatever we're going to be having some
kind of path you'll need to fix it all
right now this will be my app css now i
can head over back to app.js
and in fact comment this out so now
we're not going to break or we shouldn't
break at least and the moment i do that
i do have a beautiful error and the
reason for that is like i was just
talking about that i cannot find the
path because i'm looking for the image
and i cannot get the image now i will
gonna return back to app.css we will
talk about a little bit more
but right now what i would want is get
these images so i would want to get this
images folder and again somewhere within
the source so make sure that this is
still within the source we're just going
to copy and paste that and this is going
to be our images folder then images are
quite self-explanatory these are going
to be the images that we're going to be
using locally and later on you can use
the same images if you're setting up the
data on contentful
and then why don't we also grab this
data one
and why don't we talk about the data and
what's happening here now i'm gonna
discuss this data file later on
in more detail once it's going to make a
little bit more sense but as you notice
right now there's our bunch of imports
here on top where again we are just
getting the images so it is crucial that
again your data is sitting within source
because if you're placing it somewhere
else this path will not going to make
sense but like i said we're going to
talk about this data.js later on when
it's going to make sense because at the
moment we are not working with the data
so we might as well just skip that so
this will be our setup files and last
but not least i would want to talk about
a little bit about css so the way i was
setting up css first and foremost you
notice that i have a bunch of variables
here so i'm using the css variables i
did set them up in a root and then all
throughout the document you're going to
notice that i'm just actually accessing
these variables because i find it easier
now there's also one more thing that i
would want to let you know that my main
goal was as i'm working to create as
little class names as possible
so even though normally i would work
with style components or even if i just
work with css i prefer
naming everything with the classes in my
case i didn't want to over populate the
jsx that's the reason why we're going to
see a bunch of these nav links and then
you have let's say whatever the element
that i'm choosing this is not my
preferred way but since again i'm doing
the recording and i didn't want to over
populate the gsx that is the reason why
my css was structured this way you're
also going to notice that here on the
top
we have a bunch of globals whether this
is going to be the body where whatever
heading wants then a few classes that
we're going to use all throughout the
document
and then everything will be in a
following string where basically you're
going to have a comment so this would be
the section that we're going to be
working on let's say navbar and all the
css
that has to do anything with the navbar
will be here then we have end of navbar
then obviously we're going to cover hero
and so on and so forth so if you ever
need to find something remember that
you're just going to have to look for
the name of the section that we're
working on or if let's say you want to
find a specific class you can also use
always find and let's say we're going to
be working on a hero i can type here
okay so these are going to be the
classes that we're going to be working
with a hero now last i also would want
to mention that i am purposely repeating
myself now what do i mean by that you
will notice that for each and every
section i will gonna set up the media
queries and bunch of them i could set up
in one place and just use the grouping
now again i did this purposely so
whenever you're working on this
particular section you can see all the
css that was done now again this
wouldn't make sense normally you just
group everything together especially as
far as the media
queries are concerned because let's say
if you're repeating the same rule it
doesn't make sense but in my case again
i wanted you to show
rule by rule that is applied for each
and every section that we're working so
this would be the setup this is the
folder structure that we're going to be
using well obviously we're going to
create more folders and more components
but this is how we connect right now our
application with the setup files that
were provided our next tags will be
creating pages that we will use all
throughout the project so as i'm looking
at my finished project i have few pages
i have the home page
then we're gonna have the room page
where all the rooms will be displayed as
well as single room page where there
will be information about single room
and also we would want to set up the 404
page so let's say we're going to a page
that doesn't exist we were going to be
brought to a 404 where we have an option
of returning home okay
now what do we need is we we're going to
head over to the source within source
there will be new folder
and quite self-explanatory we're just
going to call this pages within the
pages there will be four components
most of them will be actually functional
components only one the single room page
should be class-based component you can
obviously do it later on however you'd
like but you might as well do it right
now so let's start with the first one uh
this will be home js
and like i said the home js will be
functional component and in this case i
am using right away the extension that i
have which will be the es6 7 react
snippets and this allows me to not to
type the whole spiel where i'm importing
a react and all that i can just say
r a
c
and or fc sorry and this creates a
functional component
in this case though this will be an
arrow function now you can also do it
rfc this is just going to be creating as
a function this is really up to you
however you'd like
all right now in here let's just write
hello from
home page because this way we're going
to know which component we have actually
rendered in the app.js because starting
from next video
we all gonna set up the react router dom
for the routing
then the next one will be rooms so again
new file
let's call this rooms.js
again let's create a functional
component
rfc or rf ac
and then let's just say that hello
hello from and we're going to say rooms
page okay
then we do have another one which is
going to be single room page so we can
just call this single
room js again same old deal
however in this case like i said let's
create a class-based component
so in that case i'm going to type rcc
and we can just say hello from
single room page now last but not least
there will be an error page
let's call this error
js
and again this is going to be the
functional component
and why don't we say hello from
error page
error page
and when we save them i might as well
can close all the tabs
and then what we would want is within
the app.js i would want to import them
one by one we're just going to import
them so i'm going to say first and
foremost import and why don't we
actually close the sidebar so import now
i'm just going to be looking for the
home and that will going to be in the
pages folder so since this is the same
folder of course that's the only thing i
need to do and then i'm not looking for
the images in fact i'm looking for the
pages
and then we're gonna go with home i will
gonna save that we can just copy and
paste that four times since we know that
we have four of them and let's just
change the naming the second one was
rooms
then we had what was the naming here i
think the second one wasn't the rooms
obviously that was single room
and we also need to change the name of
the import
single room and last but not least we
have the error
so let's write error page
as well as import from the error
all right
and when we do that
why don't we render everything out just
so we can see how everything would look
like if we wouldn't use the react order
dump so in that case we're just gonna go
with home
and then again like i said copy and
paste it like we did already previously
and let's just change the naming in this
case we're gonna say rooms
then we have a single room
single room and the last one
will be no
other than the error page
and once we say that we have four pages
now it's a far cry from our final
application
but at least we have started doing
something so why don't we take a look at
how we can work nicely with react router
dom
setting up all our pages was nice and
easy however we would probably want to
give our user an option to navigate to a
different pages because at the moment if
we're just going to keep on filling in
all the components that we created we're
just going to have one giant page that
will not make sense in the long run
now there's many ways how we can do that
however probably the most popular would
be reactor or dump and as always if you
want more information we can just go to
react
router
and we're going to be looking for the
package name of dom and then since this
is created by react training all the
documentation will be in fact in this
website where we have reacttraining.com
and then step by step first we would
need to install it which we already did
and then we would want to import few
things and we would want to start with
the browser router which will serve as
the router
then route we are going to point to a
specific route where each component will
be rendered and last one will be link
which will be pointing to that specific
url okay now we also gonna use the
switch and we're gonna talk about it
once we get there but these would be the
basics that we would need to get from
react router down as far as the browser
router we would want to use the browser
router to wrap our whole react
element tree or react componentry so we
have few options we can do this in the
app.js however just so we don't clog up
the app.js we can also do it in the
index.js so this is exactly what i'm
going to do is i'm going to import
i'm going to say import then i'm going
to say browser
router and usually what happens you use
the alias like you notice here they use
browser router and then you just call
this as router so you give it an alias
and we're gonna go from react router
down since we already have installed the
package and what you would want to do
right now is just wrap your app
component that you have that's being
rendered in the browser or i'm sorry in
a router so this is going to serve as a
parent container right now or parent
component and then we're just going to
lift this guy up the app and we're going
to save it and now we're going to have
access to a browser router now i did
mess up here because obviously this is
not how you write this so let's write it
correctly and then we have the import
and we have successfully set up our
router once we have the router we might
as well can start using it and like i
said we would need two more things
now the first one will be a
route
so notice we have a route component and
then later on we're also going to use
the switch
and i'm going to talk about the switch
once we start using it but i will gonna
import this right away so we're gonna be
looking for route
then we have the switch
and then again this will be from react
router dom and the syntax is very simple
so let's imagine we have these
components that we already created as
pages
and then notice we have the link
component which will be pointing to that
route whether this is going to be
forward slash or this is going to be
forward slash about
and what happens with a route component
it has this path prop
that just shows where we're going to be
actually navigating
and then what component will be rendered
so if the path is forward slash this
component will be rendered then if we
have the about then the other component
will be rendered
and in our case this is very simple in
fact we again need to set up the route
and i'm going to say okay so if there is
a prop and the name is passed in fact
not to let me go back path and i'm going
to say if the route is the home page
which would be the forward slash what
component i would like to actually show
well this is quite simple component
and then we're going to go with our home
one
i'm going to say okay so home component
will be displayed
then i would need to get rid of rest of
them and we're just going to copy and
paste them and set up four paths now the
last one we're not going to use the path
but we're not going to talk about it
right now so why don't we get rid of the
fourth one all together and we're going
to talk about a little bit more once we
actually are covering the error page so
if the path is forward slash if the home
page we would want to render then
obviously we're going to be looking for
the home component
then we would want to set up the rooms
path so if we're navigating to the rooms
then we would want to show rooms and
last but not least we also would want to
show the single room so for the time
being i'm gonna write like this
single room but we will gonna change
this a little bit later
so let's write this a single
room and now let's notice what happens i
do have my home page awesome because
currently we are sitting on the homepage
however the problem will be if i want to
navigate to a rooms because i'm going to
write forward slash
then we have the rooms
and check this out i still have my home
even though i'm also rendering the rooms
and the reason for that is because
with react router dom
it will match the first one
now in our case what we would want is
match the exact one and for that we do
need to add
this prop and the name here is exact and
that way only
if the path matches exactly which would
be the forward slash then we're going to
be rendering the homepage because what
you need to understand is if you're
looking at the rooms the way it's
written right now we have forward slash
and then rooms it also matches the
forward slash
the one that we have just for the home
one so what i'm gonna do is right now is
i'm just gonna grab these guys
and i'm just going to copy and paste
them so we're going to add this exact
one to all our writes so one two and
three
we're all going to have this exact route
once i do that and by the way i didn't
set up for the last one
then if i'm going to be on a home page
only the home page will be rendered if
i'm going to be on room page only the
rooms page will be rendered we also have
an option of single page
or single room right so we can write
single room and this will be our single
room however
there is an issue currently because
what's going to happen is that
the single room we're going to use for
each and every room however we will
going to be displaying different
information so if we have single economy
room this will have information about
that single economy room if i would want
let's say some kind of presidential room
i would want information about that
presidential room and at the moment the
way our setup is currently
we are not doing that we're just
rendering this one single room
and in order to fix that we would need
to use the route parameters so how we
can do that well we need to come up with
a path so in my case i will going to say
this this is rooms even though remember
you could just say leave the forward
slash and then do the route parameters
but in order to set up the route
parameters you need to set up the colon
and then
need to come up with whatever variable
name you would want now in my case i'm
going to call this slug
but you can call this uncle bobby it
doesn't really matter now the key here
is going to be
later on when we're going to be working
within this single room component
we're going to check it out how we can
access
this slug here how we can access that
variable and then pull the information
about that one specific page so that's
the reason when i'm going to be clicking
on a single room page i'm going to be
getting a unique information about that
single room page all right now let's
test it out
let's test it out our slug so in this
case i can say localhost this will be my
homepage
then if we're going to do let's say
rooms
let's type rooms this will be the room
page and then if i'm going to do the
forward slash and this is going to be my
path where i'm going to be accessing the
single room and we were going to set
this up with the naming where if you're
looking at the final project notice that
this would be double basic this is going
to be our slug but just to show you that
doesn't matter how we name the variable
this is just the accessing i could type
let's say one here now what this is
going to do is this is going to say okay
so i cannot find this particular rooms
now the reason for that because i didn't
save it now let's save that and notice
now i have rooms
then i have one which will be that one
specific room and obviously this will be
hello from single room now instead of
one i could just write slug and again
this will gonna lead to a single room
page now last but not least i do want to
set up some kind of error page because
at the moment if i delete everything
that i have in the url and let's just
say forward slash hello check this out i
have this blank page because none of
these ones matched here so i had a bunch
of routes but none of them in fact match
and what we can do here is we can set up
the switch component so we can place
everything within the switch that is
giving
with a react router
now let's place this all the way in the
bottom
and then once within the switch
statement we can set up again route
component in this case we don't need to
show the path we can just say okay so
we're going to be rendering the
component the name of the component will
be in our case error
error
and now let's check it out
when there will be no match for whatever
url we currently have
we will be rendering this error page all
right now this will be our setup from
the reactor or dom and then next we can
start working on our navbar once we have
successfully set up our react router
with the url parameters as well as the
error page just as a side note i want to
let you know that if you want to get
more information about what is happening
with react router dom just explore their
documentation where in this case they do
talk about the url parameters basically
what they are and how to work with them
as well as we have our no match and the
reason for that why we're placing in the
switch because the switch will render
the first child route that matches and
the route with no path will always match
now just to show you how this is going
to work so let's say i will going to get
rid of the switch so i'm going to select
them both and in fact delete them now i
can leave them as a fragment notice
right now my error one will be showing
up on each and every route so even if
i'm going to go to a let's say rooms
then i'm still going to have this arrow
so one of the things that we can do
is we can use the switch statement here
like so and then what happens is that if
the route will obviously not gonna match
we will gonna be rendering this error
component all right now the nav bar as
i'm looking at our finished project
notice that navbar will be on each and
every room
even the error one so even if i'm gonna
say hello and i'm gonna have a trouble
finding this page i will gonna still
have my navbar so one of the most
important things that we need to
remember that navbar will be placed
around the switch statement because we
are going to use the nav bar for the
navigation in order to do that i will
going to create a new folder
now i'm going to call my folder
components
and then within the components we're
going to be placing a bunch of
components and then the first one will
be navbar
js and why don't we do it very simply
where i will gonna place a class-based
component because i do want to set up
here the toggling and why don't we write
just hello from
bar let's save that and then within the
app.js i would want to import so
somewhere here maybe in the bottom
last import import then we're looking
for navbar this will be in our
components so
not there but
dot forward slash
components and then we're looking for
the navbar and on top of the switch
we will gonna render our navbar let's
save that and we do have our hello from
network which is really really good
because then for each and every page we
will gonna have the navbar once i go to
homepage i'm still gonna have navbar and
so on and so forth our done in or sorry
i work in the app.js is pretty much done
and next we'll just going to be working
whether the pages or whether this is
going to be components first and
foremost i would want to show you how we
can work with react icons because if
you're noticing on a smaller screen
we all gonna have a very very nice icon
and let me make this smaller notice this
guy so this is gonna be the react icons
now in fact that is a phantasm icon but
what i really liked about react icons
the package is the fact that they are
rendering this as an svg and it just
gives you more nice features all right
now first and foremost let me make this
bigger
then i will gonna keep this open just
again to show you where we're going to
be working with the links because this
is what we're going to be setting up but
i will going to open a new one i'm going
to say react
uh react and let's call this icons and
then this is going to lead you to react
icons netlify.com
and then notice how we should work with
them so first and foremost we would need
to install them which we did then we
have few
libraries that we can choose from
whether you want to do font awesome
ionic material design
and then the way you would import this
would be the name of the icon which you
would like to import and then the
library where you want to import from so
in our case we're going to use fantasm
so we just need to add this forward
slash fa and then if you want to render
that icon the only thing you need to do
is just name it okay now if you want to
check it out what kind of icons they
have here you go
knock yourself out again icon name and
then from the font item obviously you
can just follow along what would gonna
be my naming for the icon so you don't
need to actually go ahead and search for
that because you'll see in a second
which icon i actually picked now first
and foremost uh what kind of other
imports i would want
well i would want to set up some kind of
uh logo as well because if you're
looking at it in again the final project
we're noticing here the logo so why
don't we start with a logo
and we're going to do this from the
images import
then i'm going to name this logo and now
we just need to navigate to a images
folder and we do need to add from
and let's see so we have right now
images
and then within the images the name of
the logo will give me logo
svg now this is going to be the logo
that we're going to be using second i
would want to get my icon so i'm going
to say fa
then the name is align
and right and then like i said this will
be from react
icons and then forward slash and fa now
last i would want to get and this is not
what i would want these are the setup
files but what i would want is to head
over to a not react icons but react
router and then remember we talked about
the link component now link component is
going to be the thing that we're going
to use in the navbar because we're going
to use the link component then to prop
this will be actually directing our user
to a specific url okay now
let's import it
import and let's name this link
from react router down and get used to
this import we will do this all
throughout our application because we'll
have a bunch of buttons that we're going
to be
directing the user to some other route
all right now we do have the link
everything is awesome and like i said i
would first want to set up right away
the state because i will do a bit of a
toggling
if i'm just going to make this smaller
just to show you how this is going to
look like if we're going to go to the
smaller screen
notice this is going to be our navbar
and then we click it again and now
navbar disappears i'm doing this with a
state and with handle toggle as well as
there is a little bit of css but
obviously i'm going to show you what
kind of css is involved however i do
want to let you know that in order to
see everything that we're going to be
doing within the navbar you will gonna
have to head over to app css
now let's find where is the nav bar
let's look for the nav bar and then
within the nav bar links
you have here the height 0 and overflow
hidden so if you're not going to comment
this out unfortunately you're not going
to be able to see what is happening so
you do need to make sure that you
comment this out and that way everything
that we're going to be writing within
our js you will be able to see okay
enough of me apping why don't we set up
the state like i said we're going to set
up the state
then we're going to use this or is open
then we're going to set this equal to
false so by default navbar will not
going to be open and we already know
that we can create a handle toggle which
will be our method obviously we can name
this however we would like
and what this is going to do is use this
dot
set state and we're just going to make
sure that if the is open is let's say
false we would want to set it equal to
true if it's true then it's false and so
on and so forth and the way we do that
is we use this that's the state
then we have this property there by the
name of is open and we're all going to
set it up to opposite so i'm going to
say exclamation mark this dot stat state
and is open so this way as we're going
to be clicking on it this is going to be
toggling in between the false and true
then within the render this is where the
real fun starts so first and foremost
let me delete div
and i'm going to say that this instead
will be nav
i do want to add right away the class of
navbar
class name bar and if you did everything
correctly obviously there's going to be
already some css that's being applied
within the nav bar we're going to set up
the nav center
this will be the div
then after that we would want to go with
nav
header div
and then last but not least i would want
to start setting up my logo but i will
gonna wrap this in a link so the way we
use this link component that we got from
react router down we just need to write
link
then to prop so we're all going to be
directing the user in our case if i
click on my logo i would want to go back
to the homepage so let's close it out
and then within the link why don't we
place that logo so for that i'm going to
use source i did already import the logo
from images and i can just place it
within the source so i can say logo
and we can also add maybe alternative
and for alternative we can write i don't
know beach
beach resort something like this
resort and we also obviously need to
close out the image
so forward slash and this will going to
be our logo
like i said there's going to be multiple
things happening first and foremost you
notice that there's the background here
there's also a logo and everything is
working nicely all right
then i would want to work on my button
which like i said will be our toggling
button on the smaller screens and in
order to do that we will gonna set up
the button component or button element
first and foremost
then we might as well add type
will be button
button and then why don't we add a class
name
of our nav btn
so nav btn and then within the button i
would want to render
my icon here the fa align right now like
i already previously showed you from
their docs the only thing i would want
is to access obviously this icon so i
would just need to add a name of this
icon and then i will gonna add right
away class name because i did add a bit
of styling here
so nav icon
let's close that out let's say that and
sure enough we have our icon but we
still haven't set up the handle toggle
when i'm clicking on this button so the
way we're going to do that
is we're going to set up on click then
this will be equal to a obviously
function
and the name of the function will be
this dot handle toggle since we have
access to it in this class
last but not least i would want to set
up the ul or unordered list
which will render in fact all our links
now i need to be careful here that i
would still want to place this within
nav center but i don't want to place it
within the nav header so make sure that
you are outside the nav header and we're
going to set up the on our list
then for on our list this is going to be
the kicker where the class name will not
going to be a simple class name in fact
we were going to use the value
from the state where we have this dot
open i would want to write it first and
then once we're going to set up
everything here within the navbar i'll
head over back to css and show you what
is actually happening but the way we're
going to do that is this dot
state is open since obviously that is
the property we're looking for and i'm
just going to check if the property is
true so if this is open
then this class name should be two of
them then there's going to be links for
my
unordered list
as well as we're going to be looking for
the show nav class however if it is
going to be false then we're only going
to be rendering one class or adding one
class to this on order links which will
be nav links and then within the onward
list i'm just gonna go with list item
and for that particular list item we're
gonna place a link
and then there's gonna be two prop again
this will be again directing the user
back home
so we're gonna write that the name in
this link will be home let's copy and
paste that one more time
and then the second one will be rooms
and that's it that's the only thing we
need to do as far as the navigation is
concerned
because we don't have a bunch of links
here so let's write rooms and check this
out and currently what i have here i can
click on it all day long and not much is
happening only this small move but we're
gonna fix this a little bit later on the
reason for that is of course because we
commented it out
but i do have my links now as a side
note normally if you're setting the
links
it's probably wiser to set it up in a
different place and then just rendering
it as a list well what do i mean by that
well let's imagine again i keep going
back to my github where i don't want to
go but let's imagine you're going to
have a bunch of links
and those links will be displayed all
over the page let's say you have the
sidebar you also have maybe links
displayed in the footer and what you
don't want to do is just hard coding all
over the place because let's say you
want to change something so probably a
better way would be setting up some kind
of constants folder or data folder where
you have access to these links so set
them up as some kind of array and render
them now in my case there wasn't bunch
of links and i was just rendering them
in one place so i thought this might be
a bit of an overkill but normally if
you're rendering in multiple places and
you have way more links it makes more
sense to set up this as some kind of
array array of let's say objects and
then you're just rendering this and that
way you have the information one place
so if you change this information then
all the changes are being affected all
throughout your project again in my case
it just didn't make sense now the second
one will be this app css because what
you notice in the nav links we have by
default height of zero and overflow
hidden so if i'm gonna comment this out
you'll see how actually this is going to
work i will going to set this up so at
the moment by default they should be
hidden but probably because i already
clicked on them this is the reason why
it's not happening so let me refresh
notice now my links are gone because by
default height is zero and overflow is
hidden and then there is the show now of
class that adds this height of 100
or i'm sorry 100 pixels that's the
reason why we click on it now this class
of show nav is being added to my on our
list and now my links are being shown
that's the whole magic here behind this
navbar js and as you notice here we are
just checking the value in a state is
this open
then add these two classes here the nav
links as well as shown up and if it's
false which by default this is false
then we just want to work with a nav
links okay
this is the only thing that we should be
interested within our navbar.js
and now we are ready to move on to our
next component which in fact will be a
hero component as you're looking at a
final project you probably noticed that
for each and every page that we have
there's going to be this massive hero
background image and that is going to be
the component that we were going to
create and the way we're going to create
that is that we are going to be able to
reuse it
now there's still going to be a problem
just doing it with a regular css route
so when we're going to get to a single
page in fact we're going to do it two
ways first we're going to set it up
normally like we're going to do it right
now with the css but we're also going to
explore the styled components way where
we can make it even more dynamic okay
now what i would like to do right now is
head over back to the components we're
going to create a new file and i'm going
to call this hero js
this will be a functional component so
rfc and let's close the sidebar and now
let's decide what we would want to do so
this is going to be my component
then there's going to be two props
children because i would still want to
render this banner with a button and all
that within inside that's the reason why
i want to access the children and the
second one will be a hero now this is
the prop that i'm creating myself which
i'm going to add to this header that i'm
going to be rendering the reason for
this hero class is because i want to add
it as a class name so i'm going to set
up the class name
and i'm going to say hero so each and
every time i'm going to be rendering
this hero component i'll have an option
of changing the class name and then i'm
going to show you obviously in the css
how we're going to be doing that but in
general i'm going to say okay so this
will be equal to my prop so instead of
passing this as a string i need to say
hero and then we also would need to
render the children so i'm going to say
header
and then we're going to say i don't know
children
so let's write children that is the prop
obviously that we're accessing
so let's go with children and this is
our component we're almost done we're
still going to have a look at how we can
set up default prompts and why would
that make sense but why don't we test
this out so i'm going to say okay there
will be a hero component and first and
foremost i would want to try this out in
my home page so we're going to head over
to the homepage we will going to import
this i'm going to say hero from
and let's say components of course
then within the components we do have
the hero
and why don't we render it first and
foremost let's get rid of this div
and then let's just say that this will
be my hero
uh hero component
like so
and i do need to add the class name here
because this is what i'm expecting in my
hero
because i have my hero prop and then
this hero prep will be passed down into
attribute of the class name and then
this is what's going to make the whole
change so in this case i'm going to say
hero and i already did set up within the
app css
hero class
now let me show you how we can find that
instead of looking for the nav bar
we're going to look for the hero and
then check this out i have two classes i
have one for default hero and the second
one would be for room zero so this is
what i'm talking about when i say that
we're gonna reuse it so we're gonna have
this hero prop
but in this case i would want to pass
default hero and since this will be
accessing the class that i had the
default hero class since that is the
whole setup in the hero check this out
now i do have this massive image in my
homepage however i would want to set up
some kind of default props for this hero
component because the issue right now is
that yes i am expecting this hero prop
but what about let's say i forgot to add
the prop now it would be annoying if the
only thing would be rendering is pretty
much nothing here because this is just
going to be empty component so what we
can do here is we can use the hero now
that obviously is the name of our
component
then we go with default props and i'm
just going to set up right away that the
hero prop
will by default be default hero which
is in fact the class name that i had
within the css now what's going to
happen is if on a different page let's
say the rooms page i would want to
render different image obviously i'm
going to be passing the class name that
i'm going to create for the rooms
however if i'm not going to pass
anything altogether
like let's say for
the error page if you're going to go to
the error page notice this again we're
going to be rendering the same thing
like we had before is because i have the
default props so let's test it out i do
have my hero prop i already have the
default prop so that way within home i
actually don't need to add any kind of
class name here this is happening by
default and why don't we head over back
to the rooms again we're going to do the
same thing
we're going to import hero
from and then we're going to be looking
for the components
as well as we're going to be looking for
the hero and why don't we get rid of all
this
and for the time being let's just say
hero however in this case i would want
to pass the information and if you
remember within the css what was the
other class name that i created
and that was room zero and again just to
repeat the reason why i didn't create a
separate class for the single room is
because we're going to do a little bit
differently because there is a bit of
issue here if you want to customize this
even more so there's limitations to
doing this with acss but in this case
i'm going to call this a rooms
hero which in fact will overwrite the
default ones that we did set up so in
this case if we're going to head over to
the rooms page i will going to have a
different image now all the magic is
obviously happening here within the css
because i do have these two classes what
i'm saying here is the min height will
be 100 view heights then i'm just
getting rid of the height of the navbar
i'm also setting up the background now
for the default one i'm just looking for
a default image from the images then i'm
making sure that it's in the center and
here i'm just adding the flexbox so the
banner that we're going to be adding
later on will always always be placed in
the center and for the room zero i'm
using all the properties with the values
but i'm just overriding them i'm saying
you know what i don't want 100 view
heights so i don't 100
of the viewport in fact i want only 60
and then i also would want to change a
image now last but not least like i said
we still would want to set it up the
error page so why don't we head over
back to the error and in this case again
this will be very simply we're going to
say that we're not going to be getting
any kind of specific class for that
particular hero component
where we're going to write hero from
and then let's say what from well we can
go to components again hero and why
don't we render this dude
why don't we say hero without any kind
of classes or anything like that now
let's save that and in this case if i'm
gonna navigate in my browser to let's
say again hello
how we're going to be brought to my
error page and which i'll going to be
able to set up later on in next video
the banner component which will have
this button so then we're going to be
able to navigate back to a homepage
we have our hero component good good and
next one up we have the banner and i can
tell you right away that we could set up
everything within hero
so where i do have the background then
within the banner obviously we're going
to be placing all this information
whether that would be title subtitle
this underline and then as a child we
will be able to place something else now
in my case i'm going to be placing each
and every page we're going to have some
kind of link and like i said you could
set this up everything in one component
now the reason why i split this up
because my idea was like this to show
you that you can always reuse them
however you would like
let's say in your case you wouldn't want
to use
all of it together you wouldn't have
some kind of place in your project where
you only want the background or you
would only want the banner or you would
want to place different children than
just let's say button so that way if you
make them smaller the only annoying part
is the fact that if you want to use all
three of them together for each and
every page we're obviously going to have
to do the import within home we're going
to have to not only import the hero but
also the banner and also the link and so
on and so forth so you could technically
set this up as one big component the
reason why i splitting this up because i
find it a little bit more customizable
where if i want just to grab a hero
component i can just add it as an image
that's it i don't have to actually get
rid of the banner or anything like that
all right that is just a side note then
after the hero
i would want to create a component
and the component will be banner.js
within the banner js again this will be
functional component
then let's close the sidebar and we will
gonna pass three props so
there's gonna be option four title and
subtitle and title would be this guy
then subtitle would be here and then
also we're gonna be rendering the
children and just as a side note for
anybody who is interested what is the
children that is basically within the
component so if i'm saying here that i
would want to render children whatever
i'm going to place within this component
we're also going to be rendered
otherwise if you're not going to use
these children then whatever you're
going to place within that component in
fact will not be rendered so we have
hero then we have banner
like i said we have three props again
we're going to use the children because
i would want optionally to add this
button now you don't have to there's
going to be cases we're not going to be
adding the button but in most cases we
will going to add this link and for that
we're going to say children so we're
going to render children then title
and then subtitle and what we would want
to render well there's going to be a div
i already did set up the class name the
class name will be banner and then we
will have a heading 1. now heading 1
will be rendering the title then we will
have a div
so simple div
as well as after that there's going to
be a paragraph and paragraph we'll be
using to actually render the subtitle
that we have and last but not least i
will going to place the children and
what you need to remember that depending
of where you're going to place these
children this is where they're all going
to be rendered so the reason why this
button is all the way in the bottom
because i just set it up i said whatever
i'm going to be passing as children will
be placed in the bottom so if you're
going to place them here let's say above
the title they will be rendered above
the title we did set up the banner now
just to show you the classes that i'm
using for the banner this will be right
after hero like i said so if you're
following along next section up we have
the banner here are the comments again
display online some backgrounds some
colors some paddings text alignments and
so on and so forth
then within the banner we are pretty
much done we don't need anything and now
again this would be the part if some of
you are annoyed by the imports where we
would want to import this of course i
will gonna right away import link just
so we can set it up everything together
with the children so i'm going to say
import then i'm looking for the banner
from
and i would need to say from where well
this is obviously from the components
and the name will be banner and like i
said if i want to render the children i
would need to place this within the hero
and the kicker here that within the hero
we already set up our flexbox remember
when we were saying that if there's
going to be child it basically will be
placed in the center display flex align
item center and justify content center
so this is exactly what we're going to
do right now we're going to say
that we would want to render
banner
the props are optional as far as the
title and the subtitle is concerned so
for the title i have luxurious rooms
so let's write title and i'm going to
try to not
misspell it and this is why i'm not
going to repeat that because usually
when i talk and type my
spelling is even more terrible so
hopefully this is luxurious written
correctly and then for the subtitle
let's write deluxe
deluxe
rooms
starting
i don't know
at 299.
so dollar sign 299.
let's
actually not close the manner but let's
just close the opening tag and now i
would want to get my link so what i'm
going to say here import
then we're going to be importing link
from what well we can use it react
router down
let's import that and then like i said
within the banner this is where we're
rendering the children we're going to
say a link now this will link back to a
rooms when i say back obviously in the
case of the homepage this will be
rendering or this we're going to be
navigating to the rooms
and then we can also add right away
class name class name will be button
primary now where's the button primary
in app css again the fastest way
probably will be btn and this is going
to set up the class that i'm adding so
notice this is the css we're adding and
by the way this is going to be something
we're going to reuse all throughout the
project
then within the link what we would want
to render well let's write
our rooms
let's set this up
and bummer i don't see it here and the
reason for that is obviously because i'm
looking at a hello which is our error
page but if i'm going to head over back
to the home and this is going to be my
banner and if we're going to click on a
link notice now we're going to be
navigating to the rooms i also would
want to set up the same way like we did
in home i also want to do a banner or
i'm sorry not banner the error page so
let's close the home i think we can
close the css i don't think we need it
anymore and for the error what we're
gonna do
well i think it's gonna be a bunch of
the same things where again we have
already hero imported
i do need to have my banner so import
banner from and that components
banner and i also would want the same
thing with a link so import
and then i need to have it as a name
import link
then where well this is coming
from the reactor dom
and then again within the hero
there's going to be a banner within a
banner there are going to be a link
so let's write
banner
then let's write title
title will be 404
subtitle let's write page not found page
not found let's close this banner for
now and then within the banner again
let's actually
uh set up the link now in this case this
will be directing us back to the home
page so link component that we just got
from react router 2
then home page
class name in this case again we're
using btn primary
primary and by the way i can close it
here
and then within the link we would want
to render return home
so let's go up a little bit to return
return
home let's save that
and now if i'm gonna navigate
on my current recording to some kind of
hello page
this is what's going to be rendered and
check this out so i have 404 page not
found and then now we can navigate back
home let me double check with a finished
project what's happening with the rooms
and within the rooms i do have this
banner still with just a title so not
subtitle as well as the link so this is
exactly what we need to do within the
rooms
let's check out the rooms let's copy and
paste it in this case we will can
obviously rename that we are not looking
for the banner we're i'm sorry for the
hero we're looking for the banner
and let's close that and again we'll
need to do the same thing import link
from and react router down
from react router dom react
router down and same old spiel here
we're going to be looking for the banner
hero within the banner and then banner
and again i already said it once but i'm
going to repeat it twice if you don't
like
to be this way where you have bunch of
small components you can obviously
combine it into one
if this is really what you want now in
my case i just thought that i'm going to
show you how we would do it if we have a
bunch of small components the same way
you can just set up one component for
the banner the title will be just our
rooms
title our rooms and we'll have no
subtitle so since we have no default or
no nothing then nothing will be rendered
and then in this case where we're
navigating back home so again link to
and why don't we set up again forward
slash
and two and obviously we need to write
something within that link
and in that case we're gonna write our
return
home and we also would want to add that
class name with a button
so class name btn
primary
let's save that
and this is going to be my rooms also so
once we navigate to the rooms i will
gonna have this massive banner and i can
navigate back home
then next one up we don't have search
rooms that in fact will be the last
component that we're going to be working
on
but we do have our home
and within the home we have these
services so that will be our next
component we're gonna create excellent
we did set up everything that we wanted
with a hero as well as the banner
next one up we have services that will
be rendered only in the home page and
within the services we're also going to
create one component that we will reuse
later on which will be titled for the
sections so notice how we have services
titled and featured rooms so on and so
forth that way we're gonna create both
of these components right now okay now
let me open up the sidebar i would want
to close everything that i have
currently open
i don't need it and then within the
components let's create two of them so
first one will be services js
which will be a class-based component
so let's type rcc this is our gonna be
our component let's write uh hello from
hello from services
and then we can right away import the
component that we currently don't have
which will be title so from and then
that title component will be in the same
folder so within the components so let's
just write title and we obviously don't
need to have the extension
then
once we have the services why don't we
create the actual title component
so title.js this will be a functional
component and we will gonna be
expecting one prop
the name will be title
that will be rendered once we're
actually working with this component the
class name for this particular component
that i have set up in css is section
title within the div the title will be
displayed within the heading 4
like so so let's say that we're going to
be rendering this title prop and right
after that there will going to be a div
which will be the underline
let's save this title first and foremost
we can also save the services but what i
would like to do right now is get rid of
everything that i had currently so hello
from services
and let's just say that i was going to
be rendering my title component
and the name i guess will be what well i
think it just went with services so i
can say title prop you'll be equal to
services
let's close out this particular
component
and then like i said we would want to
render this only in home page
so what we're going to do right now is
we're going to head over to the home
and then right after the link by the way
we can close the sidebar import and then
not the title but actually
services that we were going to render in
a second so from and then we're heading
over to components
and then within the components there
will going to be a services component
and right after the hero we would want
to render services now the issue right
now is going to be that we will try to
render to adjacent component so
the issue would be fixed by adding a
react fragment so either i can write
react fragment or not create factory
i could just type react fragment or the
shortcut shortcut would be
just angle brackets as well as the
closing angle brackets
let's close out the
fragment and now let's render our
services now we don't need to pass
anything here the services will be a
component on its own so i'm going to
write services
and services should be rendered now at
the moment we only we're going to have a
title and by the way we do need to
navigate back to the home page and yep
this is going to be my title again if
you're interested in the css
just head over to the app css
i believe it was actually globally let
me check
title
and then sectional tile is right after
the banner so align it in the center
added some font size letter spacings the
color the main color that i'm using
as well as this underline okay that is
as far as the app css is concerned
and why don't we head over back to
services and obviously there's a bunch
of other things that we would need to
add here in the services first and
foremost we would want to display a
bunch of these icons so i have four
icons and we already have the react
icons working
so it will be very simply where we're
going to say import
now there is four icons that we're
looking at
so [ __ ]
tail
then fa hiking
hiking and then fa
shuttle man
shuttle van and last one will be beer
now all of them will be from and then
again react
icons forward slash fantastic icons
and once we have these imports i would
want to set up the state again so
technically we could set this up
globally in a context api which we're
going to take a look at later but i just
thought that since these are kind of
dumb components anyway meaning we're
just rendering the icons we might as
well can do it locally here within the
services
component so let's set up state state
will be object within the object we're
going to set up one array
services that will be my array and each
and every item within this array will be
an object now we're going to have few
properties here the first one will be
the icon so i'm going to go with a
cocktail one first
then title let's write that this would
be free
free cocktails
cocktails and then i would want some
info
and for that i'm just going to get some
laura mipsum and let's say i'm going to
go with 10 words so let's say lorem 10
and i'm just going to grab this text
so within the icon i'm going to write
info
and that property will be equal to this
text now like i said i would want four
of them so what we would need is copy
and paste it four times or three times
so we would have four
i'm just gonna add some commas so we
don't have any issues
and then we obviously need to change
these values where this is not going to
be hiking anymore
where i could just select them three
right now and let's just write hiking
that will going to be my second one
then let's select next to
and let's write fa shuttle van
and last one will be very simply beer
if a beer
okay we also need to change some texts
here this obviously is not going to be
um
three cocktails we can write endless
hiking
like so
then we don't need a
free cocktails
we would probably need free shuttle
and that last one will be strongest beer
strongest
strongest beer
let's save that and
after that we would want to obviously
render that so what i'm gonna do right
now is get rid of this div we're going
to go with the section section we're
going to have some class name now the
class name is important when i say sum
of course
services that is the class that i'm
using for the styling
then within the services the first one
will be title
that will be rendered first and after
that we're going to have one more div
with the class of services
services center now within this div i
would want to render this list there's a
few options i can obviously do this
above the return get my array or i can
just do it straight in the jsx which is
going to be this case so i'm going to
say this dot state
map and no you know what first of all i
need to access that array so i'm going
to say services since services is an
array i can use the map method and then
each and every item within this array
i'm going to pass it as an argument in
my callback function so i'm going to say
you particular item i would want to do
something with you and as far as
uh the mapping is concerned we might as
well you know what do the index because
we're going to have to add key
so why don't we say item which will
refer to each and every item in the list
as well as the index and now we would
want to set up some kind of return where
we had a simple array and now we would
want to wrap this in the jsx now the way
this is going to work i'm going to say
all right so there will going to be
article for each and every item in array
now the key prop we need to use every
time we're rendering the list and since
the key prop needs to be unique i will
going to use the index
and in this case it doesn't matter
because it's not going to be changing
normally if it's something like a list
that's changing let's say within the
rooms you should never never do that but
since again this is just a dumb
uh components list where we just have
the icons i think we can just cheat a
little bit and i had index for the key
as well as i would want to add a class
name and the class name is service so
this is what i added in the css now what
will be within the article
well first there's going to be a span
and we're going to be accessing actually
i item icon
so each and every item in a list we're
going to have the icon
that is obviously the property that i
have like so
then let's copy and paste the span
two more times but you know what i
actually didn't want span my apologies
we're gonna have in fact heading six uh
this will be item title item
title
and then last one will be info now info
will be in a paragraph
so we might as well go to paragraph tags
and then let's add
item info idem
info and let's save that
and voila we're gonna have
all the
icons here as well as the text
now it looks like i did mess up a little
bit
because at the moment for the free first
one i don't have three cocktails
so i have everything written here
with a camel case but then rest of them
i didn't so probably
i would want to add here a little bit of
css now let's head over back to app css
first and foremost i'm going to show you
where we're obviously getting it so we
have services then services center this
is for styling where all throughout the
project i'm using grid and i'm using
this grid template columns where
basically you can set up the repeat
function then with the repeat function
we can have either autofit or autofill
so with autofill this is going to make
sure that the columns fill out the whole
screen with autofill if there would be
extra space it would add a empty column
which by the way we're going to use
later on within the
rooms section where we are actually
doing the filtering and then we're using
the min max where the first value is the
minimum of the
actual column so minimum would be 255
pixels and then second one is one
fraction now this says what would be the
max and within the grid this just means
one
value from the screen size so let's say
one fraction
would be one part of the screen okay now
when in reality means that this is going
to span as much as it can until it is
actually able to fit two columns in one
line so that would be the shortcut and
then for letter spacing i'm obviously
working with heading six
so here i can just add text transform
uppercase
like so
and we can save that and notice now i'm
having everything uppercase but probably
capitalize would be better
capitalize and now all my texts are
capitalized and if you want to do a
little bit more info on one fraction
let's say that would be one unit of the
screen so if you have
let's say
the screen size so one fraction would be
one unit so if you have one fraction one
fraction that will be a two column
layout so what we're saying here is that
as i'm going to be increasing the screen
size check this out it's going to get
bigger bigger bigger bigger now the
moment it will be able to place
both of these with the minimum size of
255 then we'll have a two column layout
okay since this is a react project house
level i'm not going to focus too much on
css but i just wanted to tell you that
all throughout the project this is
probably going to be
most used and
useful
property as well as the value okay we
have our services set up let's check it
out in our recording
i'll head over home and yep we have the
services so next one up what do we have
in the final project we already have the
featured rooms so first why don't we
talk about what we have in our data why
the data is structured in a particular
way and then we're going to start
working on setting up the context
because in fact i want to
access the rooms data using the context
api
before we start working on our next
section and even before we start working
on setting up the context api
let's look at the data that we got from
the setup files and let me explain
why i was setting up this data this way
well first and foremost let me tell you
why we in fact are including this data
so my ideas was very simple later on at
the very end we will check it out how we
can set up everything externally within
the contentful now
i apologize if some of you actually
pronounce this contentful
i already have used to i guess saying
contentful so if some of you are annoyed
by that again my apologies but either
contentful or contentful and in order to
do that i did want to set up the data
where we can finish the whole project
just by using the local data because
what i've noticed from the courses and
from tutorials a lot of times people
have actually issue of connecting now
that is not the reason why because the
service is bad because usually there's
some kind of bug or something like that
somebody misspells the name or something
like that and what happens is that let's
say if that would happen in the very
very beginning person gets frustrated
and just moves on to a different project
so my idea was very simple where i did
want to create a local data
that we can
use all throughout the project build the
whole project so you shouldn't have no
issues of accessing it using it
i don't know modifying it and so on and
so forth and at the very very end i'm
going to show you how we can actually
set up this data in the contentful and
then get this data to our application
and obviously we're just going to flip
it there's going to be one place within
the context api where we're getting our
local data and then what we're going to
do is we're just going to change few
lines of code and our whole application
is still going to work so that's the
main idea now that leads me to a second
point of as you're looking here like i
said first and foremost these are just
the images that we're using so each and
every room obviously has bunch of
information about it you can think of it
as a big object that has images it has
all kinds of information about it and
these are all the local images so what i
did here
is just reference them and then i added
to
all those objects now each of them has
obviously a separate image but you
understand the idea so there's a room
object and that roon object has
particular image let's say image number
one image number two and so on and so
forth then
as you're looking at it you might be
a little bit questioning my sanity you
would be like okay first of all okay i
see that this is an array this is an
export default that's all good
but what is this all about
why this dude couldn't just do id
equals to one and then rest of it be
name slug
why is there a system
then this is an object then we have an
id then we also have the same thing with
the fields
and don't make me even get started on
the images where i have the images array
then each and every item is an object
and then the actual image is within the
fields within the file and within the
url
all right now let me explain what's
happening first and foremost each and
every item we're going to have these
keys when we have the id
or you have the name slog type
price size and you can obviously see all
them as you're looking at the final
project as well as as you're looking to
a single page where we go and look at
information about each and every single
page we have price size and yada yada
now the reason why we're adding so much
information because i would want to have
a nicer filtering where we have more
options to filter it trust me i could
just set this up with one type and that
would be fine but i just find it a
little bit more interesting where we
have multiple things that we can
actually sort it through
now let me tell you the most important
thing
why
there is a specific structure to this
well it's very simple like i said at the
very end i would want to flip it
where we are using all the time the
local data and at the very end we're
going to connect to the content full and
we're going to use the external data now
what i don't want to do is set up the
whole application and then be like okay
so now we're going to rebuild everything
just because the data is coming back
like this so the short answer is that
when we're all going to be accessing our
data from contentful
this is going to be their structure now
obviously they were going to have more
information
so
the structure will going to be the same
but as you're going to be looking at a
systems property there's going to be a
bunch of things so the only thing that
we're looking for is the id but there's
going to be other things if you want you
can obviously access them
but that way when we are actually
accessing the information from the
content pool nothing will gonna break
now understand in the beginning you
would be like okay so we could have set
this up much more easier
but i just find it more
better if we do it this way
where we have our original setup already
like we were going to be getting the
information eventually
from the external source and yes of
course we are going to have to do some
kind of formatting where as we're
working
with our application as we're accessing
this data obviously this is not going to
make sense so within the context api
we're all going to set up the function
that we're going to format where
basically we're going to get one object
just with these properties id name slug
breakfast blah blah blah and then as
well as extras and images will going to
be just a simple array with a images
property here and we're going to be able
to access them because it would be the
pain each and every time as you're
working with an application if let's say
you want to access this image this is
not going to make sense but you would
have to do this regardless
so even though you would be getting this
externally you would still have to do
some kind of formatting so i think it's
much more better if my original data is
going to be exact same structure as the
data we're going to be letting on and
right from the scratch we were going to
set up a function that we're going to
format
our code are basically our data and then
we're just going to get back the data
that we would normally work with once we
talked about the data why it was
structured why it was created in the
first place now let's talk about how we
were going to be distributing our data
as we're looking at our application it
would be very easy to set this up
locally for each and every component so
let's imagine we have these featured
rooms and by the way i can tell you
right away that the way i'm accessing
the feature rooms is that on each and
every object
we will going to add the featured
property where for most of them this is
going to be false and the rooms that i
would like to show will be equal to true
and we could set this up like i said
where we're always going to have this
featured rooms component
then we just access the array data that
we had separately filter it out and show
it however what i wanted to do is create
one place
where we're going to be storing all the
information our data that we will
eventually we're going to get from
contentful and currently we're going to
get from our data file and then we'll
just going to take a look at how we can
distribute it around our application and
you could definitely do it with the
redux but what we're going to do is
we're going to check it out the react
context api and again there's many
resources you can find but i just find
this one to be most straightforward
obviously we're going to do the coding
but just to give you an idea
we will first going to create a
context object
now once we create a context object then
we have an option of passing some kind
of default value or in our case we're
just going to say that we don't want
anything
then we have access to two components
one of them will going to be provider
notice provider react component
that allows
consuming
to subscribe to the context changes
meaning this component will gonna allow
the access to our context
all throughout our application
our react component three and then we
have a consumer where the consumer will
be in fact subscribing for that now
obviously we're going to get to that
one thing i would want to point out that
this value property or prop is very
important because this is where we're
going to be placing pretty much all our
application we are going to do this in a
few steps where first of all we're just
going to set up the context
then we're going to start accessing the
data from our array and last we're going
to do that formatting like i was talking
to you okay now first and foremost let's
do a simple access and by the way i will
gonna be returning here because we will
look at few ways how we can access it
because as we're working with the other
component with a consumer component that
also comes with a context object we have
multiple options we can use the
actual context where we're using context
type we also can use the render tabs
that is also an option notice this would
also want to be one of the syntaxes we
also have an option of actually using
higher order components
also something we're going to look at as
well as using one of the use hooks or
name of the hook would be used context
but
that basically be one of the hooks okay
all right now let's start working on our
setup first and foremost i would want to
create a context however in this case i
will not to place it within the pages or
the images or components in fact i'll do
it directly in the source so i'm going
to say new file
and we're going to call this context js
now you can obviously name it with
capital letter doesn't really matter
next one up we would want to create a
class-based component now at the moment
it will not get a matter but i'm going
to show you in a second why
actually i'm doing this the name
currently is context and that's not what
i would want so instead i'm just going
to say that this will be called the room
provider and now i would want to set up
my context api and the way i would do
that i would need to come up with some
kind of name so const and i'm going to
call this a room
context and this will be equal to
react and then we have that method
available where the method would be
create context and i'm not going to pass
any kind of default value so now i do
have my context and if you remember
now i had access to two components so
the first one was a provider
and the second one was a consumer
so the provider was
in fact responsible
for allowing all the components in the
component tree to access it now
obviously we do need to wrap that
component tree with that room context
provider and then the consumer was used
to access that information
now i could technically do something
like this where i say room
context i do need to add obviously my
value so context and by the way let me
spell this correctly context i'm going
to call this provider and then i need to
use the value however
the reason why i created the class
because what we were going to do is we
were going to set up the state here and
then we're going to place all our
information in state create methods
that actually operate with these state
values and then we're going to pass it
down to the value because this will give
us way more flexibility now the kicker
here is that not only we can pass like
let's say a simple string of hello in
fact we can pass the whole object so
that is the case where we're going to be
working with a state so how this is
going to look like i do have my room
provider
so instead of wrapping my whole
component tree with the room context
provider and then value i was going to
set it up here within
this room provider so within that
specific class so
let's slide that we're going to be
looking for the context
then the name is provider and at the
moment i'm just going to set this equal
to a simple hello okay now nothing fancy
here now let me make sure that i do
close it so i have room context then i
need to go with a provider but i
definitely
100 sure need to make sure that children
are being rendered and this actually
made me
mess a bit so let me close it properly
and then once i have this room context
provider that i actually accessing from
my room contest but since i'm going to
be wrapping
my whole component tree i do need to
make sure that i'm accessing the
children now the children in the
class-based component are this dot
perhaps and the name
is self-explanatory children so this
would be the provider
then we also do need to create a
consumer because we would want to access
the data now the most simplest way would
be const room
consumer again name however you would
like
consumer and then we need to use the
room
obviously context since that is the
context we created and then set this
equal to a consumer now last but not
least i would want to export them and at
the moment by default this is exporting
room provider and that's not what i
would want so what i'm going to say is
that they're just going to be a simple
class and nanowires is going to export
it like so where we have the export
then i'm going to say that i would want
to export room
provider now that is obviously the class
that we just created
second i'm going to export room
consumer
and last but not least
there's going to be a case where we
would want to use the whole context so
that's why we're going to actually
export as well room context and
obviously we're going to go one by one
where some cases we would want to access
room context in some cases we would want
to access room consumer now once we have
exported all this
then what we can do
well i could technically go back to
app.js and just wrap my whole component
tree but since i already have the react
router done
it would make more sense if we're gonna
head over back to the index and in fact
wrap everything the router the app
in my provider okay now in this case i
do need to say import then i'm going to
be looking for the name export since
obviously we named them and the name was
the room provider
and then this will be from the context
which is in the same
actually directory so let's access the
context and now let's wrap it let's say
room provider
will going to wrap around the router as
well as the app so i can select these
suckers here
get them out and copy and paste it and
now i do have my provider at the moment
nothing magical happened i understand
this might be a bit of a bummer where
you're like okay this i mean what is
happening here we did all this work and
nothing magically happened yes that is
true but just to give you an idea what
would you normally do so let's say that
you have multiple
components that would want to use some
kind of data well eventually you would
want to lift your state now what do i
mean by that well let's say that we have
a route with the rooms then i also have
the home and then as you're noticing my
services are featured rooms that we're
going to create later on
will be within the home so what you
normally do you would set up the state
somewhere here and then you start
passing down you would be like okay so
i'm going to pass these functions as
well as the
properties that i have on the state down
to rooms component or the home component
and what's happening that as you're
doing that
you're passing you're doing basically a
prop drilling where you're passing those
props down unnecessarily because the
component that's going to be using is
just sitting pretty much wrapped in
three other components but you do need
to pass it through so if i start with an
app i'm going to have to pass the home
home is going to pass down to featured
rooms and then so on and so forth so
what context allows us to do
is avoid that step
where even though
the section
that i'm going to be using
my data
will be in fact within home
i don't need to pass anything within a
home
so we will gonna avoid that step now
what do i mean by that so let's say we
have the home and like i said we will
have to create a featured rooms section
we're all going to be looking for at a
featured rooms then normally what would
you well you would pass it to a home
then from the home you're going to find
wherever yours component and then pass
it down but i'm going to show you in a
second how we can actually omit that
step so within the components let's
create featured
rooms and at the moment we're just going
to be rendering obviously that one silly
thing that we had
remember when we passed basically what
within the context we had a simple hello
so first we're going to access that and
then of course later on we're going to
set up everything properly where we will
going to access
whatever we have currently in the state
okay
now let's head over to the featured
rooms this will be a functional
component or i'm sorry no class based
component so let's say and first of all
i do need to name this properly
so
let's rename
js
that's the first thing that i would want
then class-based component
voila here you come
and then hello from
featured
rooms
right let's save that then what i would
like to do is head over to the home
imported so right after services
import
featured
rooms and let's say that this is housely
in the same or no it's not in the same
folder it's actually in components
folder then within the components folder
we had featured rooms folder
let's save this and then right after
services let's check it out what do we
have so we'll have a featured rooms
and we're rendering them now at the
moment again i just have one silly hello
from featured rooms again nothing
magical happened yet but let me show you
where the real magic comes in where
again we have multiple ways how we can
access it whether that's going to be
render props whether that's going to be
hooks
but the first one we're going to look at
is where we set up the static
name here is important where we have
context type and we set this equal to
the context that we just created
now how this is going to work well this
is going to work where we do have the
name of course for the context that we
created and we're going to set the
sequel to now there is one
easy mess up that i did
where i would probably want to actually
create this like this where this is
going to be my value and now i'm going
to have my hello
then within the featured rooms like i
said first and foremost we would want to
import this we would want to import my
whole context not just the consumer but
the room context
the way we're going to do that import
then we're going to be looking for room
context from
and now we're going to go up the tree
we're not the tree actually directory
then we're going to be looking for
components or no not components sorry
context is actually in the same one or
where it is let's figure out so we have
context right here i don't know i'm
staring at it but for some reason i
cannot see it and then like i said we
would need to follow these steps
where first and foremost we're going to
set up the static context type and this
will be equal to our context
all right now
let's write that let's say static
then proper naming was what context type
context type is equal and now we're
setting this equal to a room context so
that's the first step
now the next step is i would want to
access this value so in this case i'm
just going to say const
and we're going to set this equal to a
simple value now if i want to access
this i need to use this dot context
so this dot context and why don't we
right away do a console log so i'm just
going to say first of all
value
and why don't we do also here
where we're
showing what we have so i can just add a
curly braces where i want to access the
javascript and the moment i save it
check this out now i know that it's hard
to see but here in the bottom i do have
my hello and in fact if i'm going to
head over to my project my recording and
if we're going to do inspect you're also
going to notice in the console where i
have the hello
now this is magic because we
actually went around
the home page we went around whatever
other component would be there so we
didn't have to set up anything in the
app.js pass it down and then in fact
access it we directly access it using
the context api
now if i'm going to change that
and if i'm going to say i don't know
hello world
now check this out
now what i'm going to have here is hello
world so whatever values we're going to
be placing there we're going to be
accessing of course of course the string
is the most basic one that we can use
like i said why don't we check it out
would we have an object because let's
say that i'm going to have like some i
don't know
greeting
then within the greeting i'm going to
say hello
and let's also use name
and then we're going to set up john now
in this case i don't want to pass here
the string instead i want to pass the
object and then we have a few options we
could access properties one by one
so i could set up in my new object let's
say a property by the name of greeting
and the value is going to be coming from
my state object so let's write this dot
state and whatever property name so
again since i'm looking for a greeting i
could just type here greeting or i could
use a javascript object spread operator
where instead what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select
object whose properties i would like to
copy so in my case that is going to be
state
and then i'm just going to type here dot
this dot and state so in this case we
are going to copy and paste all the
properties that we have within the state
object now currently we have two of them
but of course i could add 10 000 of them
and all of them are going to be copied
now at the moment obviously there's
going to be big fat error now the reason
for that error is because within the
featured rooms i'm right away saying
okay so get me the whole value now that
is not what i want since right now i
have the object there
so let me delete that
let me re-render
and check this out so what we have here
is
greeting hello and name of john that way
instead of just working with the whole
value i could say that instead of
creating some kind of variable we can
right away do a destructuring from the
object that we're getting back again we
got our own context
it's important that you pass here not
the consumer but
your whole context
set the equal to the context type and
then you're going to have access to that
context using this dot context and then
like i said we would want to destructure
what i'm going to say name
and greeting
and we can use maybe here name name john
from
uh hello and by the way we can probably
change this hello as well
let's say greeting
now let's check it out and what do you
see here well i have hello john
from featured rooms so hopefully you
understand the basics of the context api
where most of the work that we're going
to do be in fact within this context.js
we're starting from next video we will
going to get our rooms and we're gonna
set up them in a state and then we're
gonna pass them exactly the same way
down
and our whole work is gonna start where
we're gonna create a bunch of functions
here that we're gonna work with state
and so on and so forth but these would
be the bare bones of how we can start
working with a context api that creates
provider and consumer we wrap the
provider
within our component tree or component
tree gets wrapped
with a provider and then we have
multiple ways how we can access it so we
looked at the way
how we do it within the class-based
component now this is important you're
not going to be able to do it in a
functional component this is the reason
why we're gonna check it out other
options as well but this probably would
be the most simplest one in class based
because the render props is a little bit
i mean just takes a little bit of
wrapping your mind around it but static
context type get the context that you
have and then you have access to
whatever you have currently in your
context
once we understand the general idea
behind the context api why don't we
tailor it to our application
so we're gonna do our setup i will gonna
get rid of this greeting
as well as name because at the moment
we're gonna do a later setup anyway and
i'm just gonna get rid of it just
remember that we were gonna have to use
this that context in order to access it
then we're gonna head over back to a
context.js and as a side note if you are
really just passing one string you could
do something like this however it
doesn't really make sense that if you're
going with all this setup just to pass
down one string okay so in most cases
this is exactly what you're going to see
but then remember that if you're passing
here the object you do need to have a
two sets of curly braces otherwise this
is not going to work
that's the reason why it's probably more
useful to place that string within the
curly braces so then at least you
understand
how would be the general setup all right
now i also want to add different values
in state
but before i do that why don't we import
all the items that we have in the data
and like i said i do have it as a
default export so if we're going to
check out the data
all the way on top you'll notice that
export default and that means that we
could name this however we would like
but i will gonna name these items again
the reason why i'm naming these items
when we're gonna be accessing the
contentful it will going to be
placed on the property by the name of
items that's the only reason so let's do
from
now this will be exactly in the same
folder so we're just accessing the data
and then before we do anything i would
want to change some values within the
state so there's going to be rooms
property which will stall all our
information about our rooms then we're
going to have sorted rooms now the
reason for that is
when we're going to be filtering our
rooms
this is the array that will going to be
rendered but then if we would want to
get let's say information about all the
rooms that's when we're going to be
rendering our original rooms array okay
now after that we have featured rooms
featured rooms will be in home these
three rooms and at the moment again this
will be set to featured
rooms and then we're going to set up
here a empty array now last one here
we're going to be loading and by the way
when we start setting up the filtering
there are going to be more properties in
a state but i just don't want to
overwhelm you so why don't we start with
the first four which allow us to
complete a big part of our application
and then once we get to filtering and
sorting that's we're going to set up
more properties here so let's set
uploading to true
now as we're getting locally data as
we're getting this data locally of
course this is an overkill because we'll
have instant access to our data but like
i said our general goal is to set up
everything where we were going to be
getting this using
the external data so eventually at the
very end we're going to have the
function let's call this get data and
we're going to run that function when
the component will get amount and what
we are going to do right now is
obviously we're just going to access the
these items directly from our data but
there's a reason why i'm not setting up
directly in a state so again i want to
show you how we would do it later on
anyway when we're accessing the external
data and currently we're going to do it
with our local data however what i would
like to do is once the component mounts
then we're going to make sure that
loading is in fact now at the moment
you're not able to see that but once you
refresh the page again because this is
getting instant access
once actually you would have let's say
some kind of slower internet connection
you would be able to see the gif that
we're going to be placing later on okay
now we do have this get data that we for
sure are not going to do anything right
now
but i would want to set up the lifecycle
method so when this component mounts so
component didn't mount
then i would want to update these values
in a state and that's when we're going
to update this whether this is going to
be true or false so first and foremost
why don't we set up component did mount
then within the component and mount
there is going to be a let
rooms so that will be my variable and
i'm going to set this equal to this dot
and function that we haven't created now
this function is again format data and
then we're going to set this equal to a
items and again
once we're going to get external data i
know i keep on repeating this book but
this will going to make much more sense
later on as we're getting this external
data
currently this
function
will just gonna work as a formatter so
we're gonna be getting all the items
here so we're passing them down into
this function and what i would like to
do is eventually just to get a normal
object where my data structure is not
like this okay because this is going to
be much more easier for us to work with
so
obviously you understand that next thing
we would need to set up this function so
i'm going to say format data now this
format data as a parameter is just going
to get some kind of i mean you can write
array but i'm just going to call this
items but
of course understand that this is the
argument where we're actually passing
our data that we got from the items and
this is just the parameter that i'm
writing here okay
now what i'm saying here is let
and first and foremost i would want to
loop through my items that i have loop
through the data that i got here so
first and foremost i'm going to say temp
items
temp items this will be equal to
items map so i'm iterating over my array
and each and every item here i'm going
to call this that this will going to be
my item now there's going to be a quite
a bit of destructuring so for sure i'm
going to create a curly braces and the
return is going to be here at the very
bottom now first and foremost i would
want to access this id
so each and every item we're going to
have the system property and then this
id property on it okay now the way i can
do that i can just say okay let id
is equal to item so each and every
object we're gonna have systems property
will gonna have the id property in there
now that's first one
then i would want to get those images
because like i said accessing these
images this way we have images array and
then one object second object third
object
doesn't really make sense so you can say
let images is equal
now item will gonna have what
well the image is in fact sitting within
these fields so we have the fields then
within the fields we have the images so
this is the reason why we type fields
then we type also images and then i need
to map over those images because again
each and every item there was in fact an
object so
what i can say is each and every item
you will gonna have what well i could
just return what i had in there right so
each and every item has fields file url
but what i'm interested is only this url
so what i can say as i'm
mapping or looping
over this images array just return me
image
fields
file
and url and that's it now our array in
fact which is going to be simple array
with all these values
then i would want to create a new room
object so i'm going to say room this is
just going to be simple object however
to access all the properties that are
within each and every item fields
property i'm going to use
dot dot and item fields and again if you
remember this is javascript object
spread operator where within each and
every item we do have the fields
property now the fields property is
already object itself with more
properties so what i'm doing here is i
am creating a new object and i'm just
going to copy the
properties from the fields object and
then after that once we have copied all
the properties we have two options if
that actual property is already within
the object if we're going to come up
with the new value we're going to
override that property now if that
property is not within that object well
we're just going to add that property to
our new object so in our case we would
like to add two properties one by the
name of the id and the other one by the
name of images now what happens though
images is already there within the
fields remember images was already there
now the problem was that images had this
nested structure however in our case we
already have flattened out that
structure so what i could do here is i'm
going to say there's going to be an
images property now since that property
is already there essentially we are
overriding this and i could just say
images like so where i set this equal to
my variable but please remember that of
course we're using es6
so i could just write here images that's
it that would be exactly the same like
we just wrote previously and then after
that like i said i would like to add the
id property now since the id property is
not within the fields as you notice
scroll up and down you're not going to
notice this id property because it is
sitting within the systems
that's when we are creating a new
property in our room object so this is
our room and what i would like to do
right now
is just return
now room and what happens well i'm
getting back this temp items correct so
i'm looping over my array i did all this
destructuring and reformatting now the
last thing from this function i would
want to return
temp
items and then next one up since we are
obviously calling this function so i'm
saying this dot format data then i'm
passing the array that we got from the
local data and i would want first of all
console.log just to show you what is
happening with a rooms okay and then
after that i'm gonna kind of give you a
brief idea of what actually happens okay
later on when we're gonna get this data
so i'm all gonna head over to a
recording and now check this out i have
an object which i'm constantly logging
with 13 items and now notice what we're
actually rendering now this
makes much more sense right so this is
more cleaner where each and every item
is just an object now it has the
breakfast capacity
all these values and check it out the
images again this is not a nested object
anymore we access everything here
that we wanted which in fact is just
that url and just to give you again i'm
going to repeat this probably already
for the fifth time but
we were going to have this get data
now once we're going to get
get data or once we're going to run get
data we're going to get our data
then we're going to run this this format
data
in the actual first function of by the
name of git data and then we're just
going to run this this dot
get data again this will be at the very
very end but i'm just explaining why
we're going through these actually steps
because what i would want to do is run
this one where in fact it mounts again
it would be much more easier to for me
to say okay items pass in the rooms but
we would have to do all this extra work
at the end of the day now the only
difference is where we're calling this
format data and the way this is going to
work we're going to say okay so we got
the rooms awesome
and now i want to work a little bit more
with the information that i have because
notice not only i'm looking for the
rooms i would want featured rooms as
well as i would want to probably set
this loading to false
because what i'm going to do is later on
we're going to pass this value down and
the component is going to check
are we still loading the information if
we are loading then i'm going to show
the spinner
if the information is there then i'm
going to display the items okay
now the way this is going to work first
and foremost let's get to featured rooms
and now we're already working with our
normal object and when i say normal of
course what i'm saying is this is just
going to be simply to access so that way
i can say featured
rooms is equal to rooms since obviously
we have access to it and then filter it
out whatever you have for the featured
rooms so like i said there's going to be
property with the value featured and
we're just checking whether it's true or
false so i'm going to say each and every
room
if you have
room featured if your property is in
fact
equal to true
you'll be added to this featured rooms
array
and then we also might as well just do
the this dot set state so let's write
this dot
set state
and now we would want to change the
values and the values we want to change
is for the rooms
is also for the sorter rooms feature
rooms and loading
now
at the moment at the very beginning
sorted rooms
will have all the information the same
like you would normally get the data so
since we would want to display initially
all the rooms they were going to be
exactly the same as we start filtering
you'll see why we're using the rooms
but what i would like to do right now is
this that's the state again we can use
the s6 where i don't need to say rooms
is equal to rooms since i obviously
named it exactly the same
then i'm looking for featured rooms
which also is named the same
then the sorted ones is not exactly the
same name so i do need to write
that sorted rooms will be equal to my
rooms that i just got and last but not
least we'll be loading
off a false again
not going to make much sense currently
this loading falls because we're getting
our data locally but once we're going to
be setting up
getting the external data it does matter
that we in fact use this loading flag
where if the data is still loading we're
not trying to render something okay that
would be our initial setup and now check
this out we do have all this access in
the state so just to show you and we're
going to do it in the next video the
actual
proper
rendering but at the moment just to show
you that we in fact have the featured
rooms i can just say that i would want
to access this so i can just call this
as a variable const and i'm going to
call this featured room so i'm accessing
that value from the featured rooms but
i'm right away going to give it an alias
or i'm just going to rename it i'm going
to say that this will be equal to rooms
and i'm getting this from where where
i'm getting this from
context and now let's check it out
where if i'm going to do console log
let's cancel log and whether we all
gonna get rooms and let's see what we're
gonna have and whoa i have an empty
array okay
let's go back to context and figure out
what went wrong
let's scroll up and i can see that
notice here i didn't use featured
should be featured not feature
now let's save that again and voila we
have our array with three featured rooms
so now we can use this information in
fact to display them before we start
working on a logic how we're gonna be
rendering all the featured rooms we will
gonna use two components one by the name
of loading and the second one by the
name of room and as a side note like i
said both of these components we will
gonna reuse in different parts of the
application as well let's say for
example room
is gonna be rendered also when we are
rendering all the rooms not just for the
featured one so what's going to happen
right now is we're just going to set up
the bare bones for rooms application
where there's just going to be one text
then i'm going to render the
rooms that are in the feature rooms and
then we're going to work in the actual
rooms component
all together okay now for the moment i
just want to create the bare bones for
uh rooms component and set up the
loading component first and foremost
let's call this loading
js
and for that this will be a just a basic
functional component
rfc
than what we would want to pass nothing
as a prop but we would want to have a
div
by the name and we're going to give this
a loading that is something that i
already set up within my css
we might as well have a heading 4.
let's write rooms data
loading dot dot dot and then i would
want to import one of my
gifs
you can go with uh
gears if you want because i have two of
them basically i have gears and i have
the other one was the arrow i think i'm
going to go with the arrow so if we're
going to head over to the source if
you'll notice the images within the gif
i don't know whether you can see that
but basically i have one of them which
is an arrow
and the second one which is a gear so
this is really up to you which one you
would like i think i'm going to go with
the narrow
so
i would want to import that so i'm going
to say import i'm going to name this
loading
gif
like so and then from and now we're
obviously looking for my images
so i'm going to say not data
we're going to go for the components no
not components images
then gif and then we're working with the
name is
loading
and arrow arrow and then the extension
is gif
and then right after the heading 4 we're
going to have the image then for the
image we're going to use loading
loading
and we're going to call this gif
then full alternative i don't know we
can just skip this i don't think this is
going to be
doing a bunch of bad things if we're
just going to skip alt altogether
then i would want to import that in my
featured rooms so import
um let's call this loading of course
loading
from and that
and we have obviously the loading
component and instead of just looking
for the rooms right after the
ending text
and just say loading and let's check it
out whether our gif is going to be
working let's save that and all the way
in the bottom notice this is going to be
my loading gif if you're interested
again in the css
same old spiel the difference would be
that this class will be in my globals
because like i said i will going to
reuse it one more time so
only thing i did is text capitalize line
center and margin top ones three that's
all what happened here
close the app css and like i said i
would want to create a room which at the
moment we're just gonna have some dumb
text like hello from room
but then
starting from not next video next video
we're going to set up the functionality
in future rooms but then one after that
we're going to actually work on the
rooms component and at the moment this
will be a simple functional component
rfc
we're going to call this room and let's
just go hello from
room
let's save that as well we can close at
the moment
then we can close loading we don't need
it anymore as well as for the time being
context is also not needed
let's close the sidebar right after the
loading
why don't we get the rooms
let's call this room or not room say
room
from and we're gonna go with uh
obviously my component by the name of
room just so i can see that everything
is being rendered properly and let's say
right before loading i would go with a
room component
that i currently have
let's save that and i do see my little
hello from room
right after the feature room so i know
that i successfully created both of
these components well one of them
completely and the other one just has
the bare bones and now i can start
working with displaying
all the featured rooms that i have in my
application we're all going to start
working on our logic just in a second
but i did i
forgot that i do need the featured rooms
title meaning i do need to import the
title component so let's do that we'll
say import
and we're looking for title component
from and then where it is it should be
in the same directory so let's just
write title and let's save that okay
that would be the first step then after
that remember when we were working with
a context i was telling you that we were
going to use the loading again at the
moment local data doesn't make much
sense later on we're going to be getting
our data externally we're all going to
make a whole lot of sense so not only i
would want to get featured rooms that i
would want to rename it as rooms but
also i would want to get loading i'm
going to say get this property from the
context okay now once i have that i
don't care about console logging anymore
i would want to loop through my rooms
and in fact set up right away the jsx so
i'm going to say rooms and again we can
do it multiple ways we can do it right
in the jsx or we can just do it
separately outside and as always with
all my projects
i'm striving to kind of show you
multiple ways this is what i was talking
about where we're going to have a
multiple options of how we can work with
context now you can pick and choose
which one you like of course i would
rather probably with class based
components stick to this one instead of
using render props but i want to show
you multiple options just in case you're
like hey you know what maybe the other
one makes sense so previously we did our
rendering within the jsx just remember
we can do it outside as well so we can
say rooms map so i'm gonna be again
looping over my featured rooms array
each and every room will going to be an
object of course there which i'm passing
here as an argument in my callback
function and what i would like to return
is not
just a simple room but i'm going to wrap
that room in a room component that we
just created i do need to have the key
since there is going to be list and each
and every room remember had the id
that's something that we didn't change
the only difference is we don't need to
use the system anymore to access it and
then we were going to say that we're
also going to pass a room prop with
all information about that specific room
okay so we're passing it down
then i'm gonna close this out i would
want right away to get rid of this room
because usually what happens i render
the list and then there's an error
because there's just one simple one and
we also would want to restructure this a
little bit so what i'm going to say here
is this will be
section instead of div
first and foremost and let's type here
section as well
then the section we're gonna have a
class now the class name is again
important because it adds all the
styling
featured
rooms like so
then we're gonna have our title like i
said title
and the title is expecting a title prop
title prop will be featured
rooms
that is the text that i would like to
display here
then after the title
i'm going to set up another div which
we're going to have class name of
featured room center again this is
for the whole layout with the grid so
this is important so div
so class name
or i can just go with
featured
featured
rooms and we're gonna go with the center
like so
featured room center and then within
this div
i would like to get my ternary operator
where i'm gonna check if the loading is
in fact in my context true
then i wanna show this spinner
and the moment i'm gonna get my data
obviously loading will be false and then
we're gonna be displaying all the rooms
okay so that way again we're not
rendering an empty array which would be
the case if the loading is true because
only featured rooms will gonna have some
kind of information once we're done with
loading once we're done with getting
that data
and in this case what i would like to
say is that loading so i'm going to
check the property that i'm getting from
the context
if you are true if the data is still
loading then we're going to be
displaying this loading component that
we created in the last video and if the
data is there
then just do everything that we did here
where
get me this rooms and just render it
here all right now let's save that of
course at the moment we should have
already some kind of rooms and at this
point saying all constant oh yeah so
that is the issue i should use let here
because the moment i use const i wasn't
able to do it and what i have here well
at the moment i do have two loadings
because i didn't delete this guy
so let me get rid of that one but i do
have my three rooms because obviously
once i run the component did mount
then loading is set to false but let's
imagine that we're waiting a long time
and i'll do that by just passing through
then if we're just loading then the user
is going to know at least that okay so
we are getting that information
sometimes again
probably you could say well i don't need
this flag i really don't care this is
really up to you but if you are doing
some kind of data fetching i think it
makes a little bit more sense if you
have some kind of flag where you are
rendering only when you get that data
awesome we have ourselves featured rooms
the only problem is that this is
currently a far cry of how our
application would look eventually so i
think we can start working on a room
component because this is where we're
going to be displaying all the
information about that particular room
whether that would be the price whether
that's going to be image and naming as
well as we're going to set up this link
where once we click on a link we will be
directed to a specific single room page
where there's just going to be
information about this room obviously
we're going to work on this component
after this after we finish with the room
but in general this is the idea we're
all going to have our featured rooms and
then each and every room will be
displayed as a component and by the way
like i said before
this component the room component we
will also going to reuse in our rooms
page so we're not gonna have to do
double the work
but in fact we're gonna do just once
we're gonna build our own component and
then we can display it all over the page
okay
now after i have rambled on and on about
the actual room component why don't we
start building it we already have the
file room js
and here i would want to start firstly
by importing the link now link will be
imported obviously from the react
rotterdam and the reason is very simple
because i showed you that i would want
to link it to a specific single room
page so link from and then we go from
react router dom of course
that is our import and why don't we
start working on what we're going to
display within the room now i know that
within the featured rooms what am i
doing well i'm passing the prop by the
name of room and then i'm assigning
everything that i'm getting for each and
every room so
in the room component
i'm going to destructure first of all
the prop that i'm getting first and
foremost
and then i would destructure a little
bit more where if you want to check it
out what kind of rooms are we going to
be getting or what kind of information
we as always can do a simple console log
or you can use the reactos this is
really up to you i'm going to use the
console.log this time where i should
have three objects printed out on screen
because obviously i have three featured
rooms so let's head over to our
recording
let's see what we're gonna have and i
should have in the console three objects
so console and sure enough this is gonna
be three object and what i'm interested
is a few properties so first of all i
would want the images more specifically
the first one because that's going to be
the one that's displayed now again this
is really up to you this is an array
with four images and the reason why we
have multiple images because later on
we're going to have a single room page
we're going to be displaying a couple of
those images and that was the reasoning
there and then what i would like to
display as the main image would be the
first one
then i also would want to get the name
the slug that will be displayed in my
url
and then what else what else uh i think
i will gonna go with uh price
so price is right here so these are the
things we're looking for each and every
object and again the same thing we're
going to work within the room page so
what we can do here is const we already
know how we can destructure
using the s6 so i'm looking for name
properties slug property
images property which will bring me an
array
and price property here and in this case
i can just say that i'm going to be
looking for the room
to be destructured so room prop and now
we're destructuring and now let's start
working on our return
first and foremost this will not gonna
be a div
but instead we're gonna go with an
article and i will gonna add a class
name now the class name will be room
again and this is something that we did
already in the css
so
i will gonna get rid of this random text
hello from room
and first and foremost i would want the
image container
where i will gonna have my image as well
as the
actual link that will gonna link to a
page to a different page so let's start
with the div image container that will
be the class and then let's start by
placing an image so for the source i
will use this images array and i'm going
to get the first one i'm going to say
images
and then we're just going to say 0 since
this is an array and we'll have access
to that particular image now after that
we have an
alternative one so let's write single
room
and then let's save that and let's see
what's going to happen and what you
should see is these three images for
each of the featured rooms now there's
one thing that i definitely want to do
right away which would be setting up
some kind of default image because
here's the case
well let's imagine
that i'm going to head over back to the
data and i know that i should have this
presidential room which by the way was
going to be all the way in the bottom
and the reason for that because i know
that this is definitely featured so i
don't want to look for feature that way
and let's say that we comment this out
let's say there's some kind of error
where you're not getting this image from
your data so let's do that and what
you'll notice is that the single room in
this case is missing
so i cannot see it that way and this is
not what i'm looking for and by the way
i was actually very very lucky because
this was also featured i didn't get the
presidential so let me again
show this room and then scroll a little
bit more down where i'm gonna have my
presidential so now i'm gonna comment
this out and check this out i don't see
the room right now i don't see the image
because obviously i'm not getting it and
what we can always do is set up some
kind of default
where if i'm going to head over back to
the room js
let me close the sidebar here i will
going to import some kind of image any
kind of image from the images and again
this is really up to you you can
obviously check what kind of image
you're importing i'm just showing you
how we can set up the default image so
i'm going to call this default image and
then we're looking for the images folder
then within images folder we're not
going to be looking for gif
again random image that i'm just picking
normally you would obviously research
what kind of image you would want and
here we can use the or operator so i can
say get me the zero images or one images
or whatever images you would want from
that array however if it's not there if
it's not
at all in the array what we can do is we
can just say just show me default image
so that way you don't have these
surprises where
let's say you have your application and
it doesn't make sense
where you should have some kind of image
but you don't so i think this is a
better
better look where we have at least some
kind of image now i will gonna head over
back to that and of course show the
presidential there's no reason for us
not to show it but this is going to be
nice fallback where just in case we
don't have that particular image let's
close the data
now next one up after the image i would
want to show the price
so still within this image of container
this is important we will gonna go with
div by the class name of price
top and again this is important to keep
these class names that's the reason why
everything is going to be displayed this
way
and i would want to access the price so
i'm going to say first of all dollar
sign
then we're going to be looking for the
price
like so and we're going to also display
a paragraph by the name of per
knight let's save that and check this
out we have nicely priced displayed for
each and every room and then last but
not least
still within this image container again
this is important but not within this
div of course
let's work on our link so the link that
will gonna guide us to that single page
so how this is gonna work well first of
all i'm gonna say link two
and now here's the question so where are
we linking well if we're gonna head over
back to app.js notice what we had for
the single room and i do need to close
the sidebar right now just so you can
see it a little bit better
where the path for the single room was
what
well we had the path of course
then we were heading over to rooms and
then we had our url parameter
where i'm just passing the name by the
slug but of course again we can name
this however we would like what's more
important is what kind of information
we're going to be setting up here so
what i'm going to do right now i'm going
to say okay so first of all i'm gonna
have to create a curly braces because i
will gonna have to use the variable and
the variable by the way will be slug and
then we're gonna set up obviously the
template literal and we're gonna write
rooms so first of all we would want to
navigate to rooms
and then within the rooms we're going to
access
each and every room that we have
selected so this slug will going to
allow us to do that now currently of
course it will not do it it will just
gonna show the url that's it we will
gonna have to set up the single page in
the next video so in the next video
we'll see how we're accessing this
information because what's really cool
about react router dom
or react router as a short one
then we can access this so there's a
reason why i'm setting up this slug
because each and every room will gonna
have a unique slug we could do the id
but then we're gonna have to have some
kind of number here and what i would
want is to have a text that's the reason
why i'm adding here the slug now this
will gonna navigate to that single page
but again nothing has been set up yet
and then let's add a few class names
here that will going to add the styling
so first of all i'm gonna use again
button primary
and we're also gonna call this a room
link that was just used to actually
place it correctly and then let's add
some kind of name of course features
like so and then as i'm hovering i
should see this link and if you're gonna
check it out notice right now i'm
heading over to rooms and double deluxe
now what's happening of course like i
said already probably three times we
haven't done anything here within a
single room page because we haven't set
up any kind of logic where we're going
to fetch this information from our
context api and we're going to get that
information about each and every room
specific room and that will be displayed
meaning if i'm going to head over to
finished project you'll notice that of
course if i'm clicking this is not just
going to be single room but actually
specific information about each and
every room all right so this is going to
be dynamic eventually currently at the
moment this is just going to show this
dumb text if i'm going to navigate back
of course this is going to be the same
however you will notice that the url is
changing so we are going to a different
url
however at the moment we're just showing
our single room page that we didn't do
anything with it okay
then
still
within the actual article but outside
this div i would want to set up here the
paragraph and i'm gonna add some class
names here i'm gonna add class name of
room
info
and then let's use the name here
let's use the name and again we're gonna
have to obviously navigate back and what
you're gonna see is double deluxe
family deluxe and pretty much each and
every name of the room now last thing
that i would want to do with the room is
set up the prop types because we are
passing the name the slug the images and
it would be nice to have some kind of
mechanism where we're at least checking
whether the prop has been passed and the
way we can do that in react or one of
the ways how we can do that we can use
obviously prop types
so let's write prop types from and then
we're importing this obviously from the
prop types
so name is prop types like so now once
this is imported all the way in the
bottom we are going to set up our prop
types and the way i'm going to write
that this is going to be the name of the
component
then we're going for the prop
types
like so but we do need to use the camel
case here in this case
prop types and this will be equal to an
object now the kicker here is that a
room itself is an object remember these
are not just single properties so what
happens yes the room has specific props
but the room component has only one prop
and that one prop in fact is an object
so what we would need to do here is use
uh
shape from the prop tips so how this is
going to work i'm going to say okay so
there is one prop
within my room component by the name of
room
then we're going to say that we would
want to check
whether this object has particular
properties there and in order to do that
we're going to have to use shape
then within the shape we're going to set
up the object and now we're going to go
one by one and basically check our
properties now first one was the name
then here we're going to write prop
types and we need to make sure that this
is a string and we also need to add is
required so that way if the string by
the name
of name will not be there then obviously
we're going to have a warning in a
console and i'm just going to copy and
paste that i have four of them
now next dude will be slug here which
also will be string and also will be
required of course
then images is an array so in this case
we're going to do a little bit
differently i'm going to say okay images
array then prop types will not be string
of course because it is an array and we
need to use array off and then we need
to specifically say well array of what
well and what we would want is to be
array of strings so that way i can write
prop types
and we just say string so just make sure
that this is an array of strings in fact
and then last one is a price which
obviously should be number
so we can just write price
and then instead of string we can just
write number
now let's save that and now we're
setting up the prop types so this should
be good
as well as everything else is being
rendered now our next challenge
obviously is going to be working with
the single room page but before we do
that why don't we head over back to our
recording
just so we can see what we have done so
far i will gonna close the console i
don't think we need it and yes we do
have our awesome featured rooms
so
now let's head over to the single room
page and work on the single room page
before we set up this single room page i
would want to set up the function within
the context that we will use within a
single room page now the reason for that
is because single room page will be
quite big component so in fact i think
we're going to do multiple videos on
that particular component so why don't
we split up even more where we're going
to set up the functionality in the very
beginning and that way it's going to be
easier later on so first and foremost
we're going to head over back to
context.js we do have our component
mount we have formatting the data and
right after that why don't we set up a
function that we're going to call get
room now this get room function we all
going to accept one argument by the name
of the slug and here the only thing that
we're going to do
is in fact we're going to filter it and
you can probably already see what is
happening
so there will going to be a way for us
within the single room
let me open this component
where we will have access to the slug
that we're passing from the room
component remember we were using the
link and we were passing the slug so
there's going to be a way for us to
access that slug and there's also going
to be a way for us obviously to access
the context and we already looked at one
way and by the way we're going to repeat
the same way using the context however
later on like i still promised i
remember that we're all going to have to
look at multiple ways how we can do that
but again since single room will be
quite big the way we're going to access
the context will be the same way like we
did before where we use the context type
because i just don't want to put too
much information in the single room
because this is already quite big
then like i said we get the slug okay
that's first and foremost and now i
would like to filter it and get that
specific room that has that slug that
will be passed using the link so the way
we're going to do that we're going to
say let and i'm going to call it stamp
rooms and temp rooms is going to be
equal to our rooms property in the state
however i wouldn't want to assign it in
fact i would just like to copy the
values that i have in my rooms array and
the way we do that is by using the
spread operator so again i'm saying
there's going to be an array and now
just like to spread out the values that
i have already within this dot
state
rooms all right now once we have these
particular values once we have array now
i would like to use the find method to
get the room that matches the slack that
we're going to pass into our function
and the way we do that is by setting up
another variable
then we're going to say temp rooms that
is of course already our array we're
going to use a find method and then
within the find method we're passing in
the callback function and within the
parameter of our callback function we
can access each and every item in our
array now since it is a parameter we can
call this however we would like so i'm
going to call my room and in fact i'm
going to use the arrow function and then
what i would like to say is you know
what get me the room that slug matches
whatever we're passing into a get room
function so let's write rooms log
is equal to a slog let's save that now
we have our function and lastly what i
would like to do is return the rule okay
now if you're wondering what would be
the difference let's say between the
filter and the find so define is going
to find the first match and also find is
going to be an object where within a
filter you would need to essentially
actually get it out from the array
because filter is going to return the
array so in my case since i'm just
looking for one item i'm fine with just
being an object and then once we get to
the object then we're just returning
back from our function
now lastly i would want to make this
available in my context so once we have
spread out our this that state correct
within the value what i could also do is
add more properties now in this case the
way we add the properties is by coming
up with a name of the property so i'm
going to say get room and i'm going to
set this equal to a this dot
get room function and this is how we can
make this get room function available
within the context and this particular
function is going to help us to get
specific room once we open up a single
room page
that was nice and easy we do have our
functionality awesome now we're gonna
head over to a single room and first and
foremost we're gonna do quite a few
imports now i'm obviously going to
explain to them uh to you once we get to
that particular import once we start
using it while we're doing it most of
them will be uh straightforward but
let's say some of them i'm not going to
spend too much time right now you'll see
it as we're creating this component
while we're using it and of course i'm
going to return and then show you how we
did that so first and foremost i would
want to get some image so i'm going to
say default bcg
and then from and then we're looking for
images again you can pick whatever image
you like i'm gonna go with room one jpeg
that would be number one then i do want
the hero because we will gonna be
displaying a massive hero and at the
moment this will be a very basic one but
like i said later on we're going to
check it out how we can do that using
the style component
now this will be my hero so let's call
this hero and then this will be from
components of course
components and the name i believe was
euro
then we do have the binary
banner will be used display name so
banner from and again same thing
banner from the components
then we will have a link which will link
away from a different page let's say
rooms because notice again we have the
banner and we're going to have this link
back to all the rooms page
so again we're going to look for the
room or link
from and react router dom
react router down
and last but not least we will gonna
have to get a context because within the
context there's gonna be a few things
first and foremost we will gonna have
access to all the rooms that we had
because we would want specific one and
second one we want the function that we
just created in the last video so let's
go with room
context and like i said we will use
again context type that we already
covered since this is a class-based
component we already know that probably
the simplest way would be using the
context type now for the context type i
do need to have my whole context the
room context and that's the reason why
we're importing here from the context
later on we're going to have a
functional components where we're going
to check it out the other way is how we
can access the context like i've already
previously mentioned the reason why i'm
not doing it here is because this will
be quite a big component and i don't
want to confuse you more than i already
have
all right now first and foremost i do
want to show you how we can access
the parameter the url parameter that we
passed here by the name of this log and
in fact this is very simple
now we have a few options how we can do
that in the class-based component and by
the way we can also do this in a
functional of course i'm just going to
show it with the class-based one where
remember when we were working with the
classes or class-based components we had
an option of creating a constructor
where we had the props
and we also had super
by the name of the props and now we can
do something here whether it bind
functions or set up the state as well as
we had a life cycle method
when the lifecycle method was well one
of them at least was component
did mount and now let's notice something
interesting
so what's going to happen is that i can
in fact access here something that react
router
is giving me and how we can do that well
first of all let's look at console
console
log
and let's type this dot props and by the
way i can tell you right away that this
is going to happen exactly the same in
the component in month i will gonna tell
you in a second why i'm showing you the
component didn't mount but for this time
being let's just save this and once
we're going to head over again to our
recording
we'll notice something interesting but
by the way before we do that let me just
uh elaborate that
nowhere in our application we're passing
this directly to a single room because
notice this obviously is just a link so
it's really interesting it's not like i
went back to app.js and passed somehow
here the prop
the prop is being passed by react router
just remember that that is kind of
important
now if i'm going to do again inspect
check this out
what's going to be in the console now
currently there's nothing there right so
currently our console is just a bunch of
complaints that we're not using some
kind of
variable that we set up but check this
out i'm going to click on features
and i'm seeing this prop and i
definitely didn't pass this prop myself
now what's really cool that this is a
react router and it gives us what well
it gives us access to bunch of things
now what we are interested is notice we
have an object and we have history
location match
what we would want in this case is get
this particular slug because remember
this is what we set up the function for
where we will gonna pass that slot and
by the way this slug
will be specific
for each and every item that we're
passing so we're gonna have a match
then within the match we're gonna have a
params and what do you see within this
params object i see the name the name is
double deluxe so just to show you that
this obviously would be unique remember
this was double deluxe
let's head over back and let's go with
let's say prudential just so we know for
sure that this would be different now
again there's going to be another object
again we're going to look in the same
place we're going to look for the match
and then what do you see within the
match params i see the slug by the name
of presidential room
so react router gives us a very very
nifty way how we can access in fact this
parameter so this is exactly what i'm
going to do
and the reason why i'm showing you a
component did not
because in our case i'm accessing this
specific room here from obviously my
function from the context
now there's going to be cases where
you're going to be setting up a
different kind of api call where
remember eventually we're going to set
up everything using contentful so in our
case we could say that we were going to
get all our information from the
contentful and we're going to store it
here in context but then there's going
to be cases let's say you want to make a
single call because obviously what you
need to understand is that this would be
a single call so what do you do well you
would set up some kind of api call where
you're just getting the specific room
about that specific one page now in our
case we are already doing this just by
accessing the contacts but this is not
always going to be the case there's
going to be a case where you
specifically need to make the api call
now the reason why i'm showing you this
that you most likely were going to do it
with component mount and that again is
where you can access this console.log
this problem now i'm not going to
console.log this right now i'm just
showing you that this obviously works
and i'm just going to comment this out
for now just for your understanding and
yes you could technically just pass it
here grab the information from the state
you can do it let's say you're going to
access that slug and then you're going
to make your api call but i'm just
letting you know that you still have
access to this component that mount to
the props
to any props but more specifically in
our case what we want is access to the
props that react router dom is providing
now after we have rambled on about the
props so we're going to comment out just
so you can have it for your reference
and what i would like to do right now is
set up this dot and state now within the
state i will have a few properties that
we will going to reuse all throughout
the project so first of all i'm going to
set up the property by the name of this
log now this will be equal to this dot
props like i said bunch of objects match
params that was the path and then last
one will be slug and again remember this
is unique for each and every time we're
going to be opening up the single room
page this will be unique because we're
getting this for each and every room
this is obviously different and then i
also would want to set up the default
bcg which will be
exactly the same name that i had here
default bcg again this will make sense a
little bit later this is just to be a
image so we're going to get there all
right now
last
i would want to access my context
so we can do outside the constructor we
can say static
static context type will be equal to
room
context now we already knew that
so what we can do is we can save that
and now let's notice something
interesting
once we successfully get our context
from the room context why don't we eat
this structure and more specifically why
don't we destructure the function that
we had by the name of guestroom so in
order to do that i'm going to say get
room that obviously will going to be
coming from this dot
context that's number one and then i
would want to run that function and i
would want to run that function and
remember we had to pass in this log so
the way we're going to do that we're
going to say const and we're going to
assign it by the name of room
i'm going to say room and then we're
going to go with this dot and then we're
going to say of course
first we need get room
let's go with get room and then this dot
state and slug and now i would want to
console log the room to show you the
issues that we're going to be having and
then we're going to decide how we're
going to fix them so first and foremost
we have
console
log
so we're looking for the room
and now let's check it out when we go to
the console notice we have undefined
first and then we are only getting the
room
now what's even worse is let's say that
not only we are navigating to single
room from when we click on the room
component we can also obviously navigate
here in the url
so not only if i'm going to be going for
presidential but let's say i'm just
going to type one check this out now i'm
going to have two undefined so we would
need to figure out a way how we would
catch this undefined
then render
something first if the room is undefined
and then only when the room is defined
eventually then we would want to render
information about that single room
knowing the issue is the first step
next we would want to fix it of course
but before we do that let's just see how
our application will perform
if we try to access this room when it's
undefined now we know that we cannot
access object in general but we can
access the property and i already know
that there will be the property by the
name of or name yeah by the name of name
and of course at the moment there will
be a big fat error because it says well
i cannot read that properly now we could
technically just again refresh and let's
see how this is going to work if we go
directly from our featured rooms page so
once we click it over here everything is
awesome we are accessing this double
deluxe all this is fine however the
issue will be once we refresh then of
course we're gonna get there the same
way if we're gonna try to access some
kind of room that doesn't exist again
we're gonna have a same error because
the room will be undefined so how we can
fix that well we could set up the if
statement where we check whether room is
undefined that means that either it's
still loading or there was an error and
then we render something so one part of
our application and then once the room
is actually defined
then we're gonna destructure it and show
the information about that specific room
very simple so why don't we do the if
statement and we're just going to say if
room
is undefined then we would want to
render something now that something will
be a narrative
so i'm going to say return
then we're going to go with error
and not console.log error but in fact
we're going to go with error div
error div
and then obviously this is the class
that we're just accessing from the css
as well as we would want to maybe place
some heading three
no such room
could be found now please understand
that if you're doing some kind of apa
call api call from the component didn't
mount then you're probably going to
write like loading or something like
that now the reason why i'm mentioning
that because people sometimes do a
different setup by using the code that i
have and then they write in the comments
that well you know what it didn't work
well yeah it didn't work because you're
doing a different thing in my case i
don't have an option of loading i have
only option of if that room is not in my
context then there's no way i'm going to
be able to find that room now if you're
just waiting for your component to mount
then probably if it's even better set up
the flag within the state where once you
actually get that specific room get
fetch that information then in fact you
render in my case again there is only an
option of either that room is in my
context or not and that's it so in that
case i'm going to write no such room
could be found
then we have three dots
and then why don't we set up the link
right away so the user can navigate away
from the page so link two
then we're gonna do i don't know rooms
and then let's write class name
will be
btn primary
like so and within the link why don't we
write uh i don't know
back to rooms and let's see what we're
gonna happen
then in our application we notice that
there is no such room
all right then if i'm just gonna type
and write deluxe i will gonna get this
deluxe because initially yes it will be
undefined but then we're gonna get that
information about that specific page so
not only are we gonna have an error if
that room is not in my context so once
we're gonna type that no such room could
be found and then we have an option of
actually navigating back to the rooms
that will be the first thing now we
would want to set up here our actual div
that will be rendered if everything is
successful so if the room is uh defined
first and foremost we would want to
destructure it so first of all i'm going
to be looking for that name property
then we're going to write for
description
so comma description
then we also have capacity
as well as size and again these are just
properties that i have on my room so
price
extras uh what else we have breakfast
breakfast
as well as we're gonna have pets and
images and all that
will be in the room so images
and that will be in my specific room
object
and why don't we actually change also
what we're going to be returning so this
will not just be a simple div we're also
going to use a hero
and for the time being we will going to
use our hero class
however in next video we were going to
look at styled components and how they
improve our application so we're going
to set up the basic setup and i'll show
you the
pitfall of this kind of setup so rooms
hero that is the class that i already
used before
for my rooms now within the hero we are
going to go with the banner and for the
banner title in this case
we are going to set up the name that is
for the room so that way i can say that
i'm sorry not two but title
and then why don't we set up right away
the template strings
and we're just gonna go with a dollar
sign i will gonna be looking for the
name of the room and i'm going to say
that this will be the name of my room
then within the banner i also want to
place a link
now the navigation will offer user to
let's say navigate rooms
why don't we also add right away class
name
i don't know um button primary of course
button
primary like so
and then within the link we're gonna
write i don't know back to rooms again
back to
rooms
let's save that and we'll see what will
happen and again in this case since the
slug
doesn't match any rooms that we have we
have no rooms can be found if i'm going
to change this one to deluxe of course i
will gonna get this nice hero component
with our banner and then this will be
the name of my room however
there is another issue
now this issue is very simple where each
and every time we're going to be
rendering that specific page the image
will not going to change
now why it's not going to change because
we're just using a simple class
where i have the room's hero class and
remember we had the case for the app css
and then within the app css we did have
somewhere hero
and i think it will be easier to find it
using find
so why don't we type hero and sure
enough we have our two classes and you
might be tempted to say okay of course i
understand yes at the moment because
we're rendering room zero we're just
accessing that one image so maybe we
could set up a bunch of classes here and
each and every class will be targeting
that specific image and then each and
every time we're going to be going to
that page we of course will going to
render a different image but again
please remember we will going to be
getting this data from where we're all
going to be getting from contentful
and that way it's going to be impossible
because those images will not be stored
locally in our application or on machine
in fact they're all going to be stored
in contentful and we're just going to
access them dynamically so even though
you would want maybe manually to add
whatever classes you have you're not
going to be able to access the images
that's number one
number two
you probably are going to be wasting a
lot of your time because every time what
you're going to change something about
your data
you're going to run back over to your
css and add the class so there has to be
a better solution
and that better solution will be styled
components
which allow us to insert this data
dynamically so this is what we're going
to do in the next video and this is what
i'm saying where this component is going
to be quite big as you noticed first we
dealt with an issue of actually
accessing the slug
now we fix the error and now we're going
to fix this hero we're all going to have
the styled components hero that we'll
access for each and every page
dynamically the image we would want so
the image will be changer that big
background image and then we're gonna
run the rest of the
information regarding that single room
okay we know our next task is to create
the hero component to be dynamic now the
first things first why don't we take a
look at what are styled components
because this is exactly what we're gonna
do now i'll tell you right away that i'm
gonna be skipping over them a lot
because i already have a separate course
on styled components so i'm not going to
go through each and every detail what is
happening with style components so we're
going to look at the general idea and
we're going to customize it for our
example if you want to learn more about
style components check out my course on
udemy and you're going to know
everything that there is to know about
style components now first of all what
is the idea well the idea with styled
components is the fact that we can
attach styles to the component
and it will be right away rendered now
there's a bunch of advantage with styled
components and the simple fact that your
css will not going to be colliding where
each and every style component we're
going to have unique class also we have
access to variables because in fact what
we're doing here we are writing
javascript now like i said this is just
going to be brief over you so first and
foremost if you ever want to find out
anything about style components this
will be installedcomponents.com
then if we head over to documentation we
notice also the api reference and what
they're telling you is that first and
foremost
the default export will be styled
then once we import styled from styled
components
then we can start using that style by
writing whatever the component name
would be and usually the uh simplest
example would be some kind of button and
then we use the styled which would be
the default export that we have and then
the name of the component now in this
case it could be another style component
this could be html element this could be
really anything you would want in fact
this could also be a react component and
what happens here once we have these
backticks which are template literals
then we can just write whatever css we
would want but what's really cool about
this that since these are template
literals we in fact can use javascript
in here and what we're all going to do
here we dynamically we're going to
access our image and place it within our
background all right now
what do we need to do first well we
would probably want to get the styled
components
and first and foremost if we head over
to the basics we just see this is the
install we would need to create i will
gonna head over back to my project i
will gonna clear everything and that's
not what i would want i'm gonna clear
everything in my integrated terminal we
will gonna install style components
right away
and we will gonna create a new component
now first of all we're just gonna test
it with the button
but i know eventually this will be
styled
hero so that will be our other
component the hero component only this
one will be using styled components and
then again let's head over back to the
api
like i said i will i'm going to be
skipping over a bunch of stuff and
remember we needed to import style from
stealth components
so import
styled from style components and notice
something interesting how we don't need
to import react now there's going to be
cases where you're obviously going to
combine them where style components will
be used together with react component
but in this case this is just a styled
component however it will perform uh a
lot like a react component so let's do
npm start now this is going to start up
obviously our dev server i can close the
integrated thermal i don't need that
from and then we're looking for styled
components because we installed them
people
then
next one up why don't we create our
simple button
and by the way i will gonna render this
somewhere why don't we head over maybe
home and let's grab the styled component
just so we can take a look first and
foremost how this is gonna work
so import now this will be styled
component however i do need to make sure
that i'm exporting something because at
the moment i'm not importing or
exporting anything apart from the style
so in this case i we're going to set up
const
why don't we call this whatever we would
like but we're just going to call this
simple
button then we need to write styled and
again what kind of html element in this
case we would want and i'm going to go
with button and here let's add i don't
know color
red and background
green something like this
background green and we do need to of
course so we're going to say export
export
we can do either named or default export
so in this case if we're just going to
say default
simple button
will be exported so far so good then
next one up we would need a home js and
we can name it again whatever we would
like so in my case i'm just going to
name this button
from and then we're going to access
components and styled hero
all right now somewhere all the way in
the bottom right after featured rooms
why don't we look at the button that we
just created with style components and
at the moment we don't see anything now
the reason for that because obviously we
have the button remember we created the
actual button so we would need to create
some kind of text
so whether that would be i don't know
hello or whatever so we're going to
create hero or hello and all the way in
the bottom i could see the little button
here notice i obviously can click it
this is an actual button but nothing is
happening now what's really cool here is
that
like i said this is javascript at the
end of the day so i could pass some kind
of variable i could set up i don't know
const
red and this would be some kind of red
color now i do need to use obviously
the quotation marks here
and i'm just going to say all right so
this will be a string
by the name of hashtag whatever we can
use maybe orange color f15025
and then for the color why don't we
change this why don't we say that all
right so we would want to access the
variable instead now this variable
obviously is not going to be red i don't
know why i'm writing red this will be
orange color
and also we can write orange and you
know what in order to
actually make this button more visible
why don't we add a massive font size
like i don't know
three rems let's test it out
and then notice check it out we do have
right now the color
however the color is not being displayed
properly because i actually gave a wrong
hashtag value i should add here f as
well but in this case i do have it here
the color is not red anymore in fact
this is orange because we are accessing
this dynamically
using the variable so now let's think
about it we have a style component we
can access some values dynamically and
what we are trying to do is
get this image in our styled component
so whenever we are rendering this hero
the big massive component
i would want to place here the image so
hopefully the bells are already ringing
in your head
because this is exactly what we're gonna
do now
how this is gonna work well first and
foremost why don't we get the default
image now you don't have to do it this
way but i just always find it useful if
we have some kind of default image so
i'm going to say default image from and
again we're going to be looking for the
images
then within the images they're obviously
going to be some kind of default image
and i'm just going to go with room jpeg
like so
then obviously i'm going to change this
around i don't care about the button
anymore what i would like to do instead
is get my default
hero and the way this is going to work
i'm going to name this differently i'm
going to say const
styled hero
will be equal to styled now in this case
i don't want to render the html button
i would want to render html header now
that is going to be the name of my
html element of course
and then what we would want for the
header well we can actually already
check what we already had previously so
that will be in the app css and what are
the styles that we're adding
well i am adding the min height here i
am adding the background as well as we
would obviously want to display flex
align item center and justify content so
we can just grab whatever we had over in
the css there's no point of rewriting
this because our main goal is to look at
how we can name this dynamic i don't
care about min height being hundred view
heights i can just go with 60 view
heights here
then display flex will stay the same
align items justify content all that
will stay the same
what i care about is this
this is what i'm really interested about
and we already saw how we can use one
variable
so first of all before we mess up
anything
let's just write that we are exporting
default styled hero
like so
and then let's change this value here
around let's say that i would want to
access this image
dynamically by again i need to use the
dollar sign since i am within the
template literals and let's say that i'm
checking for
default
img now this is obviously the variable
name that i have here so hopefully
everything was correct
let's save that and let's see what we're
going to have in the bottom
wow i have my massive image and i can
even go back in my recording we can go
back home
and for some reason this is not showing
right now and yes it is showing right
now what do you see here this will be
our massive image okay but at the moment
it's the same thing again i'm getting
this data so each and every time this
will be rendered exactly the same
because all i'm doing here is rendering
the image
now what's even more cool about style
components that we can pass the props so
what will happen at the moment i'm just
going to show you obviously this in a
home page because this is where we're
rendering and by the way i named this
button but the way this will work
eventually is that there will be some
kind of prop and we can name this
however we would like
but i'm just going to name this image
and then we dynamically will going to
access the images
that we had here from the room all right
now let me show you how this is going to
work first and foremost i don't think i
care about the button anymore
i can just get rid of it it will be on
my way i can also delete the import i
will gonna fix the style hero and the
way we access props in the styled
components is a little bit different so
this way if we're just taxing the
variable it's very simple i can just say
okay so give me whatever variable i
would want but if i'm going to be
accessing the props that are being added
to this style hero the syntax would be
following where it what it will not be
just a simple dollar sign
i will gonna have to again access
something dynamically but in this case
i'm passing here the function and this
function grabs one argument which will
be the props now the props obviously
will be the ones that are added here on
the style component by the name of style
hero in this case
and then i'm just going to be looking
for either i can return it or we can
even do a ternary operator again the
simple way would be something like this
where i say
props image now again this will be the
name of my current prop that i'm using
and just to show you how obviously this
will work is i will gonna save it
currently we will gonna head over back
to the single room and right after the
room context why don't we import this
i'm gonna say styled
component like so
and you know what no styled hero why i'm
calling the stone component and then
from and then obviously i need to head
over to my components and somewhere
within the components of course i will
have my styled component
so it's or styled hero i don't know why
i keep calling this styled
uh component well it is styled component
i guess but the name of it is styled
hero
now we will head over
to a return
if the room is actually defined and
we're going to change this around so
we're not going to be looking for the
simple hero
in fact we're going to change this
around
then we will use styled component
styled or again styled here or not
styled component
the prop name will be image
so the prop name again i use the name
here image you can use whatever name you
would want but i'm just going to say
image and that image
will be equal to anything that i would
want from that images array now this is
really up to you how you would not want
to do it but in my case i'm just going
to go with images and since i know that
this is an array i can just go with a0
now let's check it out what we're going
to have here let me first of all save
home
and then let's test it out in our
application
i click on it and what do you see as an
image well i see that this is going to
be my double deluxe room again if we're
going to head over to the prudential
now this will be a presidential room
there is one more thing that i would
want to show you with this styled
component and the simple fact that
if you would want
the default one you can either do it
here let's say set up some kind of
default if again you're not able to
access that image within the images or
we can do it here that's the reason why
i did set up this interstate so this is
really up to you i'm going to add
an overkill right now because i'm going
to add in both ways the default one so
i'm going to say show me images 0 or
and that way i'm just going to say this
dot
state and default image again you don't
have to do this this is definitely an
overkill but just to show you that we
can add these default images in both
cases where i can say okay if it's not
there then just render this guy and also
we can do the same thing here where not
only we're looking for the props but i
could set up here a ternary operator not
that ternary operator will be basically
like this i'm gonna check if
i'm passing any kind of prop
and if no image prop is being passed i
can obviously say like this i can say
all right so
props images if it's there and if it's
not there then just render whatever
default i have now where is my default
well this will be this guy so i can just
say ternary operator
if
the image prop is passed obviously
render that image prop
and then if it's not passed then just
render this
img okay
that's basically a protection
if
let's say you forgot to add that kind of
prop and this is how we can set up our
single room page to be dynamic where
each and every time we're going to be
trying to render something and i can go
back to my final application where for
each and every room we in fact will be
accessing
image from that room okay instead of
rendering the same old image all the
time
we have our styled hero component
awesome and now what's left to do is
just pretty much fill out the rest of
the information about our single room so
in this case i will gonna navigate to
the single room obviously this is gonna
show me the background image for that
double deluxe room but we already have
our awesome styled hero where each and
every time this will gonna be rendering
different images and like i said
it's pretty much the easiest part where
we would want to set up rest of the
information about that one specific room
i would want to render everything after
this styled hero so in this case since
we cannot do two adjacent things in the
gsx i will gonna also set up the react
fragment
so opening and closing will be react
fragment and then rest of the
information will gonna go here where
we're gonna be filling out
using all the values that we're getting
from that one specific room
first and foremost we're gonna start
with the section
now within that section there will be a
class that we have in the css
by the name of single room now this
should get me obviously my jsx right now
i'm just waiting on my emmett here it
goes
then within the section we are going to
start very simply by showing all the
images so if you're looking at at my
finished page you see that we have all
the images now this is really up to you
if you want to render all the images
that we have in the array basically
including also this background one you
just need to obviously do it the images
map because obviously we're accessing
the images and then all of them will be
rendered but we're also going to check
it out how we can do a little bit of the
structuring again with javascript and
render only three of them so the easy
way would be like this where we have a
bunch of images and by the way i would
want to place this in another div
single room images again this will be
just for the styling
and this is just gonna give me class
name that i don't want
but again we're gonna have to get my jsx
and then within this images this
will be where we're gonna render our
images
so i'm going to start with images then
we used a map method and then since
there's going to be a few of them i
would want item so each and every index
or each and every image in that array
and also we're going to add right away
index just because we're going to be
rendering the list and what i would like
to return is just a image with a key
and then the key will be indexed of
course and then source will be the item
so source attribute form my html image
will be coming from each and every image
from my array and i'm going to call this
item and then alternative we can just
say that the name the name of that
particular room which obviously we still
have access to so let's do this this
will be our first setup and at the
moment this will be complaining because
i should obviously have the return as
well
now this should do better and now we
have all of these images again we can
head over
back to our recording check it out
single room and i have these four images
and like i said if you instead would
want only the three images so this
background one maybe you don't want to
display
we would just do a bit of the
structuring here and in this case
instead of object destructuring we're
going to do array destructuring where i
do have my images array correct so i
could just write all right const and now
get me out the images out of that images
array and i could set it up this way
where i have the main image that is
going to be my first image and i could
just say let's say image number one
image number two and so on and so forth
and set this equal to a images array so
now what we're doing is we're just
grabbing the items out of the array so
that is going to be my first one then
second one and third one and so on and
so forth now the thing is that i would
like to get another array with the rest
of the images so essentially i don't
want to keep the count of how many
images i have in my array because in
this case i'm getting the second image
then third and so on and so forth but of
course there's cases where i don't know
how many extra images i'm going to have
whether that is going to be 5 or whether
that is going to be 50. so a better way
would be this way where i'm getting the
main image correct so i am the
structuring array and i'm getting my
first item but then for the rest of the
items i'm using the rest operator where
i'm just going to say dot dot and then
whatever the name of my array so in my
case i'm going to say default img but
you can call this however you would like
so again we are doing the array
destructuring and then in order to get
rest of the items apart from the first
one i'm just using a rest operator so in
this case i'm going to rewrite my
background as well but you don't have to
do it so i'm going to say okay
get me main img that of course is the
item number one and then instead of
looping over all the images
what i'm gonna do
is i'm just gonna say default
img and then just to double check
let's just cancel log
just so we can see that for sure default
img are going to be next images or rest
of the images in the array now let me
head over back to my bigger browser
window we can maybe refresh our dev
server first of all i can right away see
that still my style hero works excellent
so we're still accessing our main image
but then notice how rest of the images
don't have anymore that main image so we
got rid of that successfully and
essentially we're rendering out the rest
of the list
and if i'm going to click on inspect
within console we're also going to
notice that we have the array of three
images so essentially we have rest of
the images so that's how we can do array
destructuring using the rest operator in
order to get rest of the images without
the main image that is displayed in the
background well we are done with images
this will be our div so make sure that
right outside this div there's going to
be another div
now this div will be called single
room
info
and what i would like to access is
obviously right now
my jsx
and then we're going to start with
article
now the article class will be
description
and let's go with that let's get
description
and within the description we're gonna
have few things
first and foremost there will be a
heading three
and within the heading three we're just
gonna write details
details
then next one up will be the paragraph
so let me navigate to the end of the
line create a new line
and i'm going to be going for the
paragraph
and within the paragraph like i said we
were going to be placing
a description
like so
description and again what we're
accessing right now
is all the properties that we currently
have description hopefully this is
written correctly
description let's save that and let's
see what's going to happen sure enough
what i have next is my details as my
description
also still within this single room i
would want to create another article
article
then for the article class will be info
info
and then within this info there's going
to be a few things there's going to be a
heading 3 first and foremost
and we will going to be targeting info
and then also we would want to work with
the price
so let's say that we have a heading 6.
so for the heading six we're going to
have a price
and for the price we're going to do
simply a dollar sign
and then we're going to go with actual
price
so i'm going to write price let's save
and let's see sure enough what i have
here is info with a price after that we
would want to render size
so let's grab this guy
we're going to have the size
this should obviously give me another
thing but at the moment i don't see it
so why don't we grab the size prop
from our object and right after we
change the size prop i also would want
to add square footage
so square foot
like so
and then i have
pets and capacity and breakfast now just
to show you where this is going to be
located
when we're all going to head over to our
page we will going to have the max
capacity and in this case i would want
to do some kind of conditional rendering
because let's say the room has max
capacity of one it's not going to make
sense one people so we would want to say
if it's less than two then that would be
our sleep person
and then it will be
two three whatever four people if it's
plural now if it's going to be singular
then we would want to render one person
and also pets and breakfast will be
conditional some rooms will have pets
allowed some we won't so we're going to
do a little bit of conditional rendering
as well first and foremost let's start
with capacity
let's get heading 6
and for the heading 6 we would want to
render
obviously like i said capacity
and for the capacity let's write max
capacity
and then we'll just going to be like i
said doing a conditional rendering where
we'll use a ternary operator so in this
case i will gonna check what is the
value for the capacity if it's bigger
than one
then we're going to use a template
literal where i'm just saying okay so
they're all going to be a capacity
obviously rendered but it will be people
so if it's more than one so if the
capacity is more than one then we'll
render people if not then the capacity
will be
capacity will be person
and in this case we do need to have
again
template literals
person
now that should do it but we do need to
add here a question mark
for our ternary operator and now
everything is working and we have a max
capacity of two people all right now
after that we do have pets and breakfast
and there's few ways how we can also
check the same thing
so i will gonna say all right i would
want the heading six
but in this case i will going to be
checking for the pets prop
and then again we're going to do a
conditional rendering
so we're going to close out this curly
brace
and we're going to return
if the pets are allowed if that property
is true
on that particular room i'm going to
write that's allowed if it's not true
then i'm going to say no
pets
allowed
okay
that's going to be our setup and last
one will be breakfast and as you can see
in this case pets are allowed and for
the breakfast it's going to be even
simpler where we're going to use the and
operator
we're all going to check if the
breakfast property is true that means
the breakfast is for free
breakfast
then we use and operator
and we say free breakfast
breakfast
included and
obviously if this property on that
particular room will be false then we're
just not going to render that string
that's all
now right after this section there's
going to be one last thing
where i would want to render the rooms
or i'm sorry the extras that the room
has so right after this section
i'm going to write section with a class
name
like so class or why i'm typing class
name i just need to type
our room
extras
okay so this is going to be a room
extras and then within this section
we'll just going to head over to a
heading 6
and then we're going to write extras
and then last but not least i would want
to loop over this extras array
and the way we're going to render we're
just going to attach a class for that on
our list
so i'm going to say this on our list
we're going to have a class of
extras
extras and then within this on our list
why don't we do extras so obviously
we're accessing right now the variable
map again method
then we're going to use item and index
since these things will not change then
what is going to be rendered
and we would want to return each and
every list item
with that item that is in that array so
let's write list item
key
and we're gonna obviously access the
index because this should be unique
and then within the list item
let's close it out first of all and then
within the list item we would want to
return that specific item
so let's write item
and then here we're going to add
over here this dash
and let's see
we should have extras and if we're going
to check it out our recording
yep these are going to be the extras
that we are rendering if we're going to
go back home
again the presidential obviously going
to have a different price
different square footage
capacity is going to be bigger pets
allowed free breakfast because in this
case the breakfast property is true
and of course extras i added exactly the
same i'm going to be going and running
around and changing these extras for
each and every room but this should just
give you an idea how we can create
whatever arrays or whatever we would
want and then render them
awesome we did complete single room page
now what are we doing next well let's
check it out so this would be the double
missing room
yada
and then these are going to be the rooms
so what we would need well rooms will be
our last component but obviously when i
say the last component what i really
mean is that within the room page there
will be in fact two components one of
them will be for the searching and the
second one will be displaying all the
rooms that are being searched for so
let's say we're going to be searching
for rooms that are less than 205 and
obviously these are going to be three
rooms if you want to search less so on
and so forth we're going to be
displaying the rooms
in order to make this simple because i
still want to show you how we can render
the context within the functional
component and there's actually two ways
what we're going to do is we're going to
set up one container component that will
going to hold both of these values okay
now it's also a little bit easier
because i think this is going to
structure our code better and the plan
will be very simple we're going to head
over back to our components
and then within components we're going
to create three new files so the first
one will be rooms
container that's we're going to be that
parent container for both of them and
for now like i said we're all going to
create this as a functional component
so let's make sure that this is
functional
let's actually access it and the moment
we're going to do that of course we
again are using
what we're using while we're using the
es6 snippets of course so let's head
over back
and that's not what i wanted let's head
over here
and yeah let's actually get those
snippets
for some reason again my vs code is like
slowing down on me
and let's fix that yep now i have my
functional component
and then within the functional component
let's just write hello
from
rooms
container and we might as well can right
away import both of the things we're
going to be creating so first one will
be rooms filter so i can just call this
the rooms filter from
then this will be in the same directory
so at the moment we cannot access it but
i'm going to call this rooms
filter.js then we're going to copy and
paste that and the second one will be in
fact uh the actual room list so that
will be where we're going to be
displaying the rooms that are we are
filtering so room list
and room list and why don't we right
away render them again there's going to
be an error if you're going to save the
file but eventually they will be there
so rooms filter
let's copy and paste that and we're
going to call this
room list
once we have this set up like i said we
would need to create these two
components so first one will be room
list js where again this will be
functional component
and we are just going to grab all the
rooms that we're going to have
and that way let's just call this hello
from
room
list like so
and then what else we have that room
uh filter yeah
new file room
filter.js and again let's call this
functional component
room filter
and just hello
hello from room filter
then let's save them one by one room
list room container i will gonna live
these tabs open because obviously we're
going to be doing a bunch of work here i
can close the single room i will going
to leave the contacts open because we
will going to do a little bit of work
there we don't need the room
and what else do we have i don't think
we need featured rooms anymore either
all right now
we would want to navigate to the room
page just so we can see what is
happening
so at the moment nothing is happening
because we do need to have our container
so again let me open up the sidebar
we will gonna head over to the rooms
page
and let's say import
our rooms container i believe that was
the name right so rooms container
and then we all gonna say
that from
and that
so components and then within the
components we had a rooms component
now be careful as you're saving of
course your files notice how there is an
issue where basically i'm one place i'm
saying a room list and then a room
filter
and then the next one is let's say rooms
so again this is singular and plural
issue
where that's the reason why sometimes
there's an issue okay now in this case
it says cannot find rooms filter
which is weird so let's head over to
filter this should be in the same thing
so
actually don't understand why we can't
access it it's in actually the same
directory so it says cannot resolve
rooms filters and using components
interesting why we can't get rooms
filter oh because it's room yeah you see
this is the issue sometimes when you go
with the room and rooms and that's you
know that's why sometimes i just told
you to be careful in fact i made a
mistake myself okay now this will be
rooms and at the moment we're not
rendering anything
so let's head over back to rooms
and again we would need to create of
course the fragment because otherwise
this is not going to work and we're
going to have
to have no
adjacent jsx
so this will be my fragment
and then let's render room container or
rooms container or you know what this is
getting really really annoying what i'm
going to do right now is i'm just going
to rename it so by mistake i in fact
called it rooms and it should be
probably a room container because
otherwise this is just really really
getting annoying so let's say this will
be rooms
as well as within the actual rooms
we're going to get a room
and this will be from room so let's save
that and at the moment this is again
complaining is not defined
because we have rooms container and now
let's say that and yes finally
everything is successful
where we have hello from rooms
and then we have two of the components
one is filter and one is
the room list
now my first thing
is that i would like to show you
how
we can obviously work with the context
as far as the functional components are
concerned because at the moment
we want to access the context because
there's some things we would want to
pass it down to a room filter as well as
the room list so we'd want to grab the
rooms the sorter rooms
as well as the loading because we will
gonna have to check loading here however
that one obviously we're not gonna pass
it down that one we just wanna check it
ourselves but also there will be a
method
and that's what we're going to be
looking for okay
now what we want to do first is head
over back to the context
and notice what happened so the first
time we had we had this context correct
where we had this dot context and we
were able to access it because we were
working with a static type and then this
was equal to the my context and we set
the sequel to a this dot context and
then we got the value
if this is a functional component we
cannot do that
now instead what we are looking for is
for the consumer that we created all the
way in the beginning
and the way we can access that is in
fact using the render props
where the return
in between the component will not going
to be just a simple some kind of value
but in fact this will be a function
now this function takes an argument
of our object that we placed
now just to show you where this is
in the context remember all the way in
the bottom we had our value that was
equal to a state
so
here
we can access that value but i think
it's going to be easier a little bit to
show you how this works but the general
idea is like this so
rooms container
first and foremost now we do need the
consumer remember we imported in fact or
exported three things room provider room
consumer and room context and all the
time we have been using this guy the
context one now we in fact need this
consumer so let's head over to the
container
we're gonna import we're gonna call this
or by the way this is a name import so
we need to call it
like it is
room and this was consumer
then this will be from the context so
again we need to access the
context of course and then once we have
accessed the context i also would want
to right away get the loading component
so i'm going to say all right import
loading
and that will be my loading component
loading component
and now like i said
what happens is that i will have to use
this room consumer to access my context
so the way this is going to work is
going to be very interesting especially
if you're doing this the first time so
we have our component room consumer and
like i said in order to access this
information
we need to run the function here okay
and this is something called render
props
now within the function the only
argument here is going to be this value
the value that we are in fact
passing
in our context this is exactly what
we're accessing so what we can do is
since this is the function i obviously
will gonna have to do some kind of
return however in this case why don't we
set it up
where we have right now our divs oh so
this would be my return
let's place that that is our return but
since this is a function we can start in
fact destructuring it we can actually
start looking at what values are we
getting so again this would be the same
thing as we would set up in the class
this dot context type and then accessing
by this that context so why don't we
check it out const
and again maybe we can just value uh
maybe we can just console.log just so
you believe me that this is actually
happening
let's write value and i understand that
in the beginning
this kind of syntax
might be throwing you off a bit because
again we're just not accessing simply
the
variable that we're getting from the
actual context in fact we do need to run
this function and that's the reason why
of course if
you have the class this is probably much
simpler and also in the rooms filter we
will check it out how we can use it
as a hook where we can do
a lot
like we're doing within the class just
by using the hook again that will be
in the rooms filter component so far
we're dealing with this render problem
because i want to show you a couple ways
how we can do that now in this case i
will gonna head over to my recording i'm
gonna go to rooms and if everything is
correct i should have
my value object and of course i do
and now check it out so everything that
we had in the state we have access to
and we already know how to the structure
in fact i think we're experts already
and that's it let's just start grabbing
the values so i'm going to be looking
for loading
i will going to be looking for
sorted
rooms as well as the rooms and this will
be from the value now my plan is to pass
the sorted rooms down to a room list
and then the rooms into rooms filter
please remember that whenever we're
going to be working with rooms filter we
also we're going to grab some more
functions that we haven't set up yet in
context and we could technically set
them up right now and pass it down to
rooms filter however since i want to
show you how you can use use context
which we'll do in rooms filter this is
why we're going to be doing
grabbing a little bit of information
from the context
in our container and then a little bit
draw more from filter and understand
that you can do it either way i could
grab everything within a rooms filter or
i can just pass it down
like here within the room container the
only the reason why i'm doing this
because i want to show you multiple ways
how to do that okay and in fact in the
next video
we're going to check it out how we can
do this with a higher order component
again it's kind of important whenever
you're going to be working with context
to kind of know these ways how we can do
that so in this case i could say sorted
and i'm just going to say that this will
be rooms so i will gonna set this up and
you know what in here i'm actually gonna
pass the rooms so the sorted rooms will
be passed into rooms list
but i will gonna call this prop exactly
the same
so i'm going to say yes there will be a
rooms prop so each of them we're going
to get rooms prop
but
the difference would be one we'll get
sort of rooms and the other one we're
going to get the rooms and you'll see
when we start filtering why in fact we
are doing that but i also would like to
check the loading because let's not
forget
eventually when we're getting our data
from
the external api we need to make sure
that the actual data is there and that
would still require checking it within
the room page all right now in this case
it's very simple i'm going to say if
loading
if loading is true
then i would want to display or return
in fact the loading component
loading component and then if it will be
false which obviously can be our case
because this is done locally
then of course we're just going to be
rendering and passing down these props
into rooms filter and rooms list now
let's test it out just so we know that
loading is for sure working again i'm
going to head over back to set state
and i'm just going to say that or you
know what i could have just done it like
i could have commented out and now i
should have a massive loading because
obviously we didn't change it from two
to false so we know that that is working
and why don't we check it out what would
be another way how to write this because
like i said you might be thrown off a
bit from this
component where we are pretty much using
this render props where we are using the
consumer
and then we're passing it this way where
we're using the function now this is not
unique to context you'll see in fact
uh all over the react that somebody
might use this kind of pattern
especially before hooks of course now
that there's hooks there's probably less
use of this case but you will gonna see
this so just remember this is a function
the argument is whatever we have
currently in the context and then you
just need to access it and make sure
that you're obviously returning that
this is a function but you can do all
kinds of functionality right here on top
don't do it in return that is against
the rules of jsx but you can definitely
definitely do it here on the top all
right
now while we're still in a subject of
course
why don't we cover how we can do this
with a higher order component
however what i would like to do right
now
is in fact first of all set it up and
the way we're gonna set it up will be
within the context
now let's go somewhere here
let's create that component
let's say that you don't like this kind
of syntax you're like i cannot stand the
fact that i do need to pass
the function
and then i need to access this value
so let's say that you decide to go a
higher order uh component rod now how
this is going to work i'm going to say
export i'm going to call this function
we can just say with
our room
consumer it doesn't really matter how
you call it
and then within this function first and
foremost i'm going to pass in the
component
so there will be going to be a component
that i'm going to pass
within this function but we need to
remember that in this case this will be
a room container
but understand that you can do it
obviously with any component where you
want to hook up the context now once i
pass it within the function what's
interesting about this function it will
return another function that's what they
call it higher order components where
basically they return another component
okay
now let's call this return then we're
going to write function and of course
you can do this with an arrow function
but i just find it a little bit
more understandable if we write it the
es5 way where we're writing the
functions because otherwise if you just
have a bunch of arrows there i think
that
i mean some people might get confused
let's call this consumer
wrapper again we can call this however
we would want and what's important about
this function is that we're all going to
be grabbing props now i understand that
you probably will be asking well what
props are you talking about
we will run this
function with consumer within this room
container and of course in our case we
did not pass anything as a props
but let's say if we're going to be
running this with rooms filter notice we
are passing some kind of props so what
we would want to do is if we're creating
this higher order component we do want
to pass those props into the component
that will be returned okay now last
thing from this function what are we
going to be returning finally
okay we have our first function we have
our second function the one that's
grabbing the props and also we are doing
the return so what
on earth are we going to be returning
here well this is finally where we're
going to be returning a consumer so i'm
going to call this a room consumer
and remember we still need to follow the
rules
because it still will return the value
because remember we had this setup where
room consumer is returning this function
now in this case though
we will gonna return already right away
the component
that will be passed in so the way we're
gonna do that is gonna be like this
component
then we're going to access the props so
dot dot
and props
that component might or might not have
let's make sure that i'm typing actually
correctly because i would want to access
this particular component as well as i
would want to right away set up context
and the context will be equal to the
value the prop of the context obviously
is not mandatory you can call this
however you would want the most
important thing is that you are
accessing this value here so this way
you're kind of skipping where instead of
running through your whole application
and each and every time using a room
consumer what in fact you will do
you're just going to grab this higher
order component and you will wrap your
component within this higher order
component and your component will be
returned right away with the props that
component has which in our case we
didn't but like i said again for the
room filter let's say you will gonna
have
as well as context prop or any kind of
prop how you'd like to name it that is
equal to this value so how this is gonna
work
we already are exporting and now i'd
want to go back to the room container
and you know what i know this might be a
little bit redundant
but i'm going to select everything
i will going to comment this out just so
you can have it for your reference and
we're basically going to retype
everything from the scratch now this is
not going to take like ages or anything
like that this will be quite uh fast
because again everything is already
there now some things we might as well
copy and paste it like let's say imports
these are obviously going to be mostly
the same
so let's copy and paste that
and we're going to select them all this
will be my loading now the difference is
of course i don't want room consumer
i want with room consumer that was the
higher order component that we created
then i also would want to create
obviously here function
then room consumer i'm going to name
this
like so
and then within the props i will going
to be able to access to the context now
one thing that we do need to do is as
we're going to be exporting this we need
to wrap
the
room consumer the one that we currently
have or you know what let's call this
room container sorry
room container we would want to wrap it
in the with room consumer so let's write
it here
export
default just so we can name it however
we would want and then we have this room
consumer and we pass in the room
container and that's the reason why
we're going to have access to this
context okay let's rent the room
container now we have successfully
wrapped
the container
in the
with room consumer so how a higher order
component and now we're going to have
access to this context just like we
normally would with the props and again
here's the question what do you find
more easier just setting up this room
consumer with the value or if you have
to use it all over the page you maybe
would want to go with higher order
component but there's the last thing
that actually is again very easy one
which we're going to check it out in
rooms filter
where you can just use the hooks again
this is really up to you now let me
quickly finish this we're going to say
again loading
loading
sorted rooms
and then rooms we're obviously passing
this will be coming in this case from
the context of course
then we can also do right away for
loading and then of course this all will
be exactly the same so we can just copy
and paste that
okay a little bit of copying pasting not
too much
okay so we got if
then in this case this obviously is
working really well now the only
difference is that i do need to add here
obviously the closing tag and this
should fix everything that i had
on the errors hopefully it will
so in this case i am accessing if
and for some reason i'm not getting back
to return
and that's why sometimes the issue with
copying pasting i guess
let's delete that let's save it and yes
it is working everything is working
correct again this is really up to you
however you would like to do in the
rooms filter
we'll check it out the
hook that we can again
use to access the context within the
functional component again if you would
have some kind of class-based component
it's obviously just using the static
type
we have successfully finished with a
room container so by the way we can get
rid of this guy we don't need it here
and if you really don't want to have
this div here of course you can just
delete it and this will become react
fragment and next on our list will not
be rooms filter in fact it will be a
rooms list now the reason for that is
because this will be a more
straightforward where we just want to
render all the rooms that we're going to
be filtering and the only thing that i
would want to show you at the very end
is the difference in css a little bit
and pretty much it because we were going
to grab the room container or i'm sorry
room component that we already created
and we'll just going to render the list
that we're getting okay
now i can close the room container i
will not need it anymore
then where is my buddy where is my room
list here it is
and first of all like i said let's
import the room component from
this will be in the same
folder of course or directory then i am
getting as a props i'm passing here
rooms so i'm grabbing this rooms prop
and then i obviously would want to
render them
now one thing that i would want to set
it up is if there are no rooms because
we will going to be filtering and
there's going to be case that rooms
array that we're going to be getting as
a prop will be in fact empty so that way
i would want to render that
unfortunately no rooms match your search
parameter now you don't have to do it
but i think this is just going to be a
little bit better user experience
now the way we're going to do it is
going to be very simple i'm just going
to check if the rooms
room's length
is in fact equal to zero
then i'll gonna render one thing so i'm
gonna say return
and then in that case we're gonna go
with a div by the name of
empty
search and again this is already set it
up in our css and let's just write this
long text
and hopefully
i will try to
not mess it up
as far as
the spelling is concerned no rooms
matched
your
search
search parameters
like so and then let's do another return
which in fact will be normal return
obviously since the array in most cases
will gonna have some kind of items in
this case i will gonna use section here
so let's use a section with a class of
room
list
like this and this is obviously not
giving me what i would want so
let's write section
and then let's add right away class name
and we're going to call this a room list
or you know what no rooms
rooms list
and we're going to have the section now
within this section there's going to be
a room list center so simple there with
the room
list
center and then within this div
we would want to map our array so let's
call rooms again the prop we're getting
map method
item each and every room
as an argument and then we would want to
return that room wrapped in our room
component that we already had the key
here will be the same item
item id
and then room
will pass as an item so the room prop
that we're expecting in the room
component we're just going to pass each
and every object that we have and that's
it that will be our massive
and interesting room component
and the moment we render it notice
obviously we are getting a bunch of
bunch of rooms
now there's one thing that's missing and
that is again this s
so i apologize there's rooms and room
and this is what's missing that's the
reason why it's rendered this way the
moment i'm going to save it obviously
right now the rendering will be better
we can check it out in the context
let's say
i will going to say sorted rooms will
just gonna be an empty array because
remember we're passing the sordid rooms
the rooms itself will be passed in a
filter so again if i'm gonna comment
this out notice we should have the text
unfortunately no rooms matched your
whatever parameters and we're going to
get that text if our array that we're
going to be getting from the context
will be empty now the last thing that i
would want to show you
as far as css is concerned and again
we're going to do finding because we
have rooms list
now notice how for
rest of the grid i was using autofit
when i did my function with repeat and
then i used min max where minimum column
width should be like this and then
maximum is going to be one fraction
that would be part of the screen
and
in the rest of them i used autofit and
in this case i used autofill now if you
want to see the difference is that with
autofill
if there will be extra room
within let's say your layout it will
gonna enter this one empty one so
there's gonna be this one empty column
however with auto fit this is just going
to make sure that you have three columns
so they all going to be spanning all
across so if with auto fill if there's
going to be extra room for that column
the same with a rest of your columns it
will be inserted so in this case i think
it looks a little bit better because
let's imagine that if we have one
component it would be just spanning all
across the page because it would take up
all the space that would be the effect
with auto
fit now with autofill it just says okay
you have room for one column but if you
have more i'm just going to be creating
the empty spaces okay that's the only
thing that i would want to show you as
far as the css concerned
that i find of course important and once
we're done with a room list then we're
going to start working on the room
filter
all right guys i think we're ready to
our most important component which we
will use for the filtering before we do
anything within the search filter or
room filter component i would want to
make some changes in our context and the
reason is very simple if you have done
any kind of work with react or
especially with react forms you know
that there's a option for using the
controlled inputs now what does that
mean that there is a value in the state
that is in fact reflecting whatever you
have right now and then you also have
the onchange handler which makes sure
that every time we're going to making
change it is also affected in state and
this is exactly what we would want to do
here as well so we will going to have to
set up some values in the context state
then later on we will can also set up a
function the handle change function as
well as we are going to pass them down
into a filter component and we'll attach
them to each and every component
obviously not all the values from the
state but that particular value just so
we can control the input okay first and
first and why don't we head over to
context
then within the context like i said we
would want to add more values after the
loading i would want to add type
and these will be the default values or
basically i'm saying type by default
will be all if you're wondering this is
obviously our first select box now i'm
not gonna go one by one because you'll
see obviously what is happening meaning
i'm not gonna scroll over to the page
just to show you where we're gonna be
using it
because my first
uh deal is to actually render them so
capacity
one that will be the default price by
default will be zero
then min price
will be also zero
also i would want max price
that also will be zero
then mean size
again you guessed it zero
max size
you guessed it zero
and then we have breakfast
which uh will be by default false
as well as last one pets by default
also will be false so we have set up the
values in a state
before we start working on our handle
change
i would also want to make few changes
here
notice how we're using this that state
where we're changing the values in state
so as far as the price and the size is
concerned i would want to set up the max
ones
not as zero but whatever max i will be
getting from my data so what does that
mean well you see by default once you're
gonna refresh it notice my max price
will be all the way up to 600 as well as
my max size will be right here so those
are the two values that i don't want
zero but i want specifically from the
data so i don't want to guess what is
the max price for the room in fact i
would want to calculate that from the
data that i'm going to be getting the
way we can do that i'm just going to set
up the variable
max price now we're going to use math
max
but we know that we would need to pass
it as a values not as an array so in
this case we can use the spread operator
and i can just use rooms now again rooms
will be the data that we're getting back
right here
and then we're going to write map
then of course item so return me the
price for each and every item so what
will happen
is that we will going to be returning
the array because we're using map then
we right away going to use the spread
and this way we're going to know our max
price again we can cancel log it but i
think we can skip it this way and the
same way i would want to set up with a
size
so we're gonna copy and paste that now i
will gonna rename this
this will not be max price it will be
max size and i will be looking not for
the price
but also for the size
and the way we're gonna do that right
now in a state
is first of all the price we're gonna
set it equal to max price because again
right away you see that my price is all
the way on the end that is my max price
and we're just going to say all right
max price then we already have in a
state the max price property so we just
need to write max and not there
but we need to write it within this.max
price so that will be equal of course to
the max price and last one will be max
size
that also will be equal to the variable
that we just created let's save that
and then we need to set up two functions
at least some kind of structures a
minimal structure for them
where right after the get room
i will gonna say handle change
that will be the name of my function
and i'm just going to say that this
function will be expecting an event
and you know what for the time being why
don't we cancel log the event target
type name and value and the way this is
going to work just like in regular
javascript we have access to the name
object then within the event object we
have the target
uh that we're clicking or
that is actually being changed not maybe
we're clicking on it
but then we also have option of
accessing the value from the target or
from the event the name
as well as the type so the way we're
going to do that we're going to be const
let's just go with first of all i don't
know maybe type
and that will be event
target
type and then we're going to copy and
paste that and these values are just
going to change to name
name like so
that will be my variable and then we are
looking for not type but we are in fact
going to be looking for the value
so then dot target value and just so we
can see everything that's happening in
fact we're going to do a simple log of
type
name
and value okay
and then eventually we're going to call
another method
once we're done changing the values
because what we're going to do with this
function is in fact we're going to grab
everything that controlled inputs were
going to give us and we're going to fix
the values in a state because notice we
have a bunch of properties so what we're
going to do is we're going to access
those properties and change it from
within this handle change function and
then once we run the function after that
we're going to run another function
which we'll call
filter rooms
filter rooms that
will not look for any arguments
it will just grab the values from the
state
and filter rooms and at the moment we
can just say hello doesn't really matter
i'm not going to call it anyway okay
now what we would want to do though is
in the state we have get room but i also
would want to pass
not both of them not filter rooms but
just handle change
so i can write handle change will be
equal to
this dot handle change and once we make
these changes
in the context we are ready to head over
to a room filter
and start working with our data
once we have our general setup in the
context.js i think this is the great
time to head over to room filter
where we're going to do most of our work
well it's going to still head over once
in a while to context.js because we will
going to have to add more functionality
than just a simple console log
but most of the work will be done here
and first and foremost we're going to
have to do some imports now i'm going to
be importing right now use context which
is a latest way how we can actually
access context and this one is using the
hooks so i'm going to say from and this
will be from react and again this will
be used because this is a functional
component and of course we cannot use
the static type here that is the reason
why now we also would want right away a
room context remember that was something
that we used when we were not using the
higher order component or the render
props because we used actual room
consumer now this is
a whole context so hold the whole object
that we're creating again we're
importing that
and then this will be from the context
of course
so from the context and last but not
least we do have the title
so i don't know whether you remember but
all the way in the beginning we created
this title component and that's what i
will be right now importing
let's grab it this is my title
and first you probably are wondering
well how we can access the context well
very easy the only thing we need to do
is set up some kind of variable which in
my case will be context and we can use
use context
room context and if we want to double
check what we're going to get
let's just go with the context
and let's check it out of course inspect
not here but here
and voila people we have our object so
we don't need to use render props if we
don't want to we don't need to use
hieram component
but we can use right away the hooks and
in this case the use context of
obviously it is
very good to know them the higher order
component than the render props because
like i said this is not unique
just to a context api you'll see those
patterns as well
but probably i think you will going to
be sticking with use context because
this is as straightforward as it gets
just get that context api
set this up equal to some kind of
variable and you're good to go all right
now what we would want to destructure
from this particular variable well all
the things pretty much that we have in
the state and when i say all the things
of course not all the properties but a
bunch of them now let's start by handle
change that was the function that we
needed then i'll need a type and again
only thing i'm going to be doing is
listing basically a bunch of these
properties all right so type capacity
price because these will be used as my
value
on the inputs that's why i'm going to
have the controlled input
capacity
capacity then let's do price
we can also do i don't know min price
mean price then also max price
and i know this might be a little bit
annoying but i need do need to type them
out
mean size
max size
breakfast
breakfast and pets
now this will be of course equal and
we're gonna set it equal to context
context let's save that okay now we have
access to the variables awesome
and why do we
start working right now on what we're
going to be returning now in this case
obviously i have the div
but instead i would want section
section and now we're going to add some
class name here so i'm going to say
class name
class name
will be
filter container
filter container and in the first video
we're just gonna pretty much set up the
first one let's first input the select
box
because
there's gonna be
quite a big setup
meaning we're gonna have to set up the
input box and then we're gonna have to
do a little bit of
context where we're just working with
handle change as well as we're gonna
have to get unique values so why don't
we start slow
where we're just focusing on one input
and then you'll see that it gets faster
but the first one will include bunch of
boilerplate that we're gonna have to do
okay now within the filter container
we're gonna have a room
by the title of search
rooms let's render that dude
and let's see what we're gonna get
that is obviously my title awesome
search rooms
and now i'm gonna be working with a form
for the form there will be no action
but i will gonna add class name
now the class name will be form
filter form sorry
filter form
and then within the form i will right
away going to set up
some kind of
comments because it will going to be
easier
now that way i'm going to comment the
line
and we're going to say select
type and let's write
end of select type and the select type
otherwise it's just going to get messed
up at least in my opinion these comments
kind of
show me where i'm starting with this
select input and where i'm ending
then there's going to be div with a
class of form
group
now within this div i would want first
of all a label
now label will be for the id of type
and then we're going to write a room
type
after the label we'll have our select
box for the select box we do have a name
and we do need to use this
name input now what is the reason for
that because we will going to be
grabbing that value
right here when we're going to be
working with our handle change so that
is important that that name in fact
matches so in this case i type type and
the reason for that because
of course here within the state i also
have the type and you'll see why that is
important just make sure that you
actually type this type the id is just
for the label so i'm going to say type
and then we do want a value
so i'm going to say value and the value
will be the type that i'm getting
back from the context state so this is
how we're creating a controlled input
then we also would want some class name
for styling
i'm going to say form control that i
added
for the styling and last but not least
we would want that handle change so
on change we're going to set this equal
the function that we're getting from the
context
and the moment i save it
notice this will be my input so far so
good now what is missing though
as you're looking at it what is in fact
missing here
well we're missing the values that we're
getting from the state and the way
obviously this data is going to work if
i'm going to head over back to the data
js
for each and every
room
there will be type of room now the thing
is though that i just want
don't want all the rooms that i have
because types are obviously going to be
repeating let's say if you're scrolling
up a little bit
you'll notice that let's say type is
single
then i scroll over to the next
uh
room it's also going to be single so
what happens is that i only want unique
values if i'm looking at my finished
project check this out
i do have here
only the unique values not repeated
otherwise i'm going to have for each and
every room i type so the more rooms i'm
going to add it the more types they're
going to be even though they were going
to be repeating so we need to be careful
there's few ways how we can do it we
could technically set this up like this
where if i'm going to head over to room
filter
then within the select
i could be like okay so i'm going to
grab the select and now i'm just going
to manually add these types so first and
foremost we would do let's say
option we're going to set some value i'm
going to say this i don't know single
and then val and then the actual input
would be single we could do it this way
the problem though with this way is
again you don't want to do anything
manually you want to check the data
that you're having and by the way where
are we having the data
remember when we were using the room
filter
let me show you
we had rooms container
and what we passed into rooms filter we
passed everything from the context so
all the rooms from the context and this
is what i was talking to you that i just
wanted to show you how we can pass the
information we could technically get
this from the context the same way so
this is a bit of an overkill where i
could get that information directly but
i just wanted to show you how we have
many ways how we can pass the context
all right so what i'm would be
interested
is getting these rooms
that are being passed
and what i would like to do is instead
of
doing this manually where i'm like okay
let me head over to my data and just
find out what kind of types i have i
would want to set up some kind of
function
that will return only the unique values
how is this going to work
well it's very easy
first
we will gonna have to set up some kind
of function
that will only only repeat or return
unique values now we're gonna do this
above
where i'm gonna say get all unique
values
get all unique
values and then why don't we set up the
function
const get
unique
and we're going to be passing two things
the array of items so whatever items
we're going to be passing but of course
in our case that will be the rooms array
and then the second one well what kind
of unique values are you looking for
whether you're looking for a unique type
whether you're going to be looking for
let's say unique capacity and so on and
so forth in our case in fact there's
going to be only two there's going to be
this guess the capacity as well as the
room type because the rest of them are
obviously different inputs
now in this case i will going to say
value
and then since this is a function i
would want to return something so i
would want to filter this out
if you're struggling with what i'm about
to write please head over to my channel
you're going to head over and you're
gonna see that there's a playlist
for javascript challenges and one of the
challenges in fact is looking for unique
values because i'm not gonna spend
too much time here this is very
straightforward javascript and again if
you need more information please head
over there that is one of the solutions
that we used so what i would want from
this function to return is in fact an
array
but i will gonna spread it out right
away and i'm gonna use new set
now the key here with the new set data
structure is the fact that set only
accepts unique values so within a set i
can just map over whatever items i'm
going to be getting which again by the
way will be rooms since we're going to
pass rooms right here and then what i
would like to return
will be
item
and that item value
so item
value and what's happening here again
we're using the dynamic properties this
will be a string so i'm going to pass in
the string
it will going to check
what kind of value you have for the type
and if that value will not be in a set
it will be included if it's in a set by
default set will not gonna include so
this is how we're gonna get all the
unique values now let's test it out this
function and we're just gonna pretty
much say like this we're gonna say types
types we'll use our get unique function
then we obviously need to pass two
things the array that we're going to be
checking as well as what we're going to
be checking for so i'm going to say
type now i do want to add
type of all
because that's something that i'm
interested because that's also going to
be one of the options okay where i would
want to get
all the rooms with let's say all the
types
now why don't we add here maybe comment
get
and let's do it properly
get unique
uh get unique types
then why don't we add all again comment
add
all
and why don't we say okay so we had our
array because obviously we're getting
back an array and we can just use again
spread operator where i can say i would
want to add all and whatever you had
already in the types
whatever you had original types and this
will be my types and what we can do
right now is head over to my
select
and instead of working here with these
values we could display the jsx or we
can work on this jsx right here where
again we're going to create some comment
map to
jsx
then types will be in this case already
jsx let's write types map
and again we're just going to wrap this
in the option that's it
now for the map we would want two things
item and index
then we have the function of course
and what this is going to return well
we're going to say we would want to
return
option
and we would want to wrap option
actually
option
for the option value will be the item
that we're passing
so each and every item that will be in
this types array and last but not least
we have a key
that will be index
and let's close it out however still
within the option
we all going to place our item now
lastly
within the select box we're just going
to say that we would want to access
types and what you see here is okay so
item is not defined room filter seven
okay let's check it out item item of
course because i'm using the items here
that's the reason
let's say that and what do you see here
on the right hand side
as far as i can tell
if i'm going to open up i will have only
the unique values whether that's going
to be single double family on
presidential again if you need help with
this check it out one of the actual
challenges is getting the unique value i
went over already what we were doing and
then next is just getting these values
using that function and the reason why i
created the function is because we were
gonna like i said reuse it for the
second one for the capacity as well so
we might as well not do the double of
work
then i'm just adding here this all that
would be for all the properties
and last but not least
i would want to work with uh actual jsx
so that's the reason why i'm getting jsx
and last but not least i'm saying okay
so set the value for the type so now
what's gonna happen
if i'm gonna head over to the bigger
screen so we can see remember we were
doing the console logging
so we can clear the console for now
and then we can head over to rooms
of course we're already here
and if we're just going to click on it
let's say single this is going to tell
me what that i'm selecting
one
that is obviously the type that i'm
having
then i do have this
type
as well as the single now the type is
let's check it out what do we have here
otherwise it might be a little bit
confusing and you know what why don't we
add here the actual explanations
what we had within handle change
now uh
and you know what
we can do it probably with template
literals it's going to be easier this
is and let's set like this this is type
this is
name
and this is going to be the value so
this is
value
let's set this up
why don't we add maybe this is
value
and that way you'll see exactly what is
happening so name
i know a little bit annoying in the
beginning but i just want you to
understand because this is important
what we are in fact getting back so this
is
type
and now let's console.log everything
that we're going to have
where we're going to have this is type
so the type will be select one
then the name will be type and by the
way name will be the one that we are in
fact
changing in our state and the value will
be family we also can notice something
very interesting where all the time our
value goes back to all and the reason
for that is very simple because we do
have value set up on a select box and
we're getting it from the type and at
the moment we're just working with the
handle change where we're getting the
type the name and the value however what
we're not doing we're not changing
anything in a state so if i'm going to
head over let's say and in the type
we're going to type single notice of
course i'm going to be getting right now
in the single because this is the
controlled input where everything we're
going to be coming from the state so
that's exactly what i would want to do
next
where now that we have this information
so we have whatever change are we
creating i will gonna head over to a
context and we're gonna set up a little
bit better handle change where instead
of all of this console logging we're
gonna decide what we would want well as
i'm looking at the state right now
check this out
i have
type
then i have the capacity price and
all of that
and this is equal to some kind of value
and if you notice when we were working
with console logging
name
was
actually equal to whatever we had with
the state
and then the value is whatever we
selected
so how this is going to work
well i would want to first of all decide
whether i'm going to have the checkbox
or this is going to be something else
because with the checkbox in fact we're
not going to be looking for the value we
were going to be looking for the check
so first and foremost we're going to say
like this we're going to say that there
is going to be a target
now target will going to be very general
where we have event
target
then after that
i would want to set up the value again
by the way i can just delete this guy
because this will be an if statement
where i'm going to say const value so
again this is because we have the
checkbox if you wouldn't have the
checkbox you wouldn't have to do that
then event
type and i'm going to check if the type
is equal to the checkbox
then instead of target value
we'll have a target checked
so in fact we're going to say okay if
there is checkbox
then use target
check
and then and by the way this is not what
i wanted
dot checked and then if it's not a
checkbox we're just gonna use like we
did before
target value that's number one
and name will stay the same so there
will be target name
as well as the target value and now it's
really interesting the way we can do
that within the this dot set state is
the fact that i can again use the
dynamic variables in my object so
instead of saying okay so once i get
these values this is just going to be
for the type what i would want to do is
for all my inputs every time i'm going
to be changing i'll be dynamically
checking
what is my name and then the way we can
do that is very simple i'm going to say
whatever name property i'm getting back
just check that value in a state and set
this equal to whatever value we have
currently from our input okay now name
and we're going to set the value the
last thing that i would want to do is
run this this dot
filter rooms because depending on
whatever we're going to do with our
input we're also going to be changing
these values so once
this runs once we run this that state as
a callback function we're going to run
this filter rooms so we're going to
change this value in a state and then
depending on that we're going to filter
our sorter rooms remember that was
something that we're going to be passing
down into the room list the sorted rooms
let's change that
and now let's check it out
i will gonna have access to it and now
in this case i will gonna call single
now this calls me hello and the reason
why it calls hello because we already
have here
the filter rooms and obviously with
filter rooms we have console log hello
all right now i do think that it will be
a little bit more beneficial if we're
gonna head over to react tools
then we have the room provider and now
let's check it out what we're gonna have
for the type as you're looking at it
what is the type right now i believe
this is single so if i'm gonna head over
here to family
what i'm gonna have i'm gonna have the
family the same i'm gonna have within my
input family now if i'm gonna go back to
all
this of course will be all and so on and
so forth and this is exactly what we're
gonna do later on with the rest of the
inputs where we're going to have access
to a value in a state
because this is an object and we can
access the properties dynamically by
passing in the value and then we'll just
going to set it equal to whatever value
we're getting from the input and i
understand that probably the most
confusing is this part as far as the
handle change is concerned because again
we're not doing it one by one we're not
saying type will be equal to value no
we're saying whatever i'm getting back
doesn't matter whether it's type whether
that's capacity whether that's money it
doesn't really matter as long as you
name them exactly like you have in the
state you should have no issues all
right
now we also would want to
set up the filter rooms and like i said
the first one will be the longest one
and once we already set up everything
this is where it's going to go faster
okay
now in the filter rooms first and
foremost i would want to get
rooms
from my state
not sorted rooms sorted rooms will be
passing down the rooms the original
value that we have because the changes
we're going to be making to the sorter
rooms but if we want to ever want to go
back to original values this is why we
would want to access rooms so again
we're going to have to do a little bit
of destructuring where we have rooms
then we'll have type
then we have capacity
then we're gonna have price so again
we're just gonna be checking these
values
mean size
uh max
size and what else we have we have
breakfast
and we have pets now where is this
coming from
very simply it's coming from this dot
state again very important to understand
and this is a callback function
because this dot state is asynchronous
so we need to make sure that we only run
this when the state is actually changed
okay
all right we have successfully
destructured our state values and again
please remember rooms
not sorted rooms sorted rooms will be
the ones that we're going to be changing
then we're going to set up some
temporary variable we're going to say
let temp
rooms is equal and now why don't we do
the spread operator
where what i'm getting back from the
state
we'll use the spread operator now we're
going to have an array and why don't we
set up our first if statement
where i'm going to say if
type
and now i'm talking about this specific
type
is not equal to all
is not please remember this is again
important if it's not equal to all i
would want to filter my temp rooms so
the way i'm going to write is temp rooms
is equal
to temp rooms filter
and then we can say
return me
only the rooms
that match the current type because what
we were going to do right here is just
like i showed you
we changed the
values for the type
one of them was single then we had all
and whatever so what i'm saying here is
unless this is all
in that case we're just going to have
our original value we're not going to
change anything if
the value for the type is anything but
all then i do want to filter it then i
do want to return only the rooms that in
fact are matching the room type that i'm
passing so return me only the rooms that
has the same type that we're getting
right now
from the state and obviously when i'm
talking about the type i'm talking about
the value
now last thing that i would want to do
within this filter rooms is again set
another this that set state and in this
case like i said
what's important we got the rooms we got
the original value and i would want to
change not the actual rooms
but the sorted rooms that we are
accessing later on in my list so in this
case i'm going to write temp
rooms
so set this equal in a state the sorted
rooms
to the temp rooms okay
now let's save that
and at the moment again this is roms i
can see already there's some kind of
temp
uh
not the temp there's already some kind
of bug not some kind of bug i can see
that i'm accessing roms
not rooms let's do that
now once we save that it complains about
uh
81
and then of course this is not temp
items this is temp rooms
yep bug scrolled in
now let's test it out we're gonna head
over to my recording we can maybe make
this big smaller
now notice i do want to still show you
what's happening here
so let's click on double and voila
our type is double so we changed it and
what kind of rooms we have
we have only the rooms that have the
type of double that's it that's the only
thing we need to do and as long as we're
going to be changing that value
that's when we're going to be displaying
only those rooms now if i'm going to
click on all
notice
now i'm going to be getting again the
full value because i have type of all
and i'm going to grab all the original
rooms that's the reason why when we
passed down to room list we are using
the sorted list the
sorted rooms but if we would want let's
say again use the type all i'm going to
get back all the rooms so that's how we
can do the filtering this was our first
filter so like i said the second ones
and third ones and the fourth ones
should be already much faster because we
have all our structure i know the first
one was a doozy but once we have all our
structure i think it will gonna go
faster and the next one will be in fact
the guests
so i'm gonna be checking
how many people are max for each and
every room and again we're gonna do a
bunch of the same things so in this case
i can and i will gonna copy and paste it
and we're just gonna be changing here
the values because i don't see the point
of retyping all the divs and everything
now this will be guests
and i'm not going to call this type
and just say okay so there will be
guests and that's all there will be no
type
then i will gonna leave the form group
so form group will stay
type will not be my label in fact this
will be named capacity
we're just gonna write here guest
that's all
guests then for select naming again will
not be type as well as the id so both of
these will gonna become capacity
uh value obviously again we're not
accessing the type
so we're accessing the variable by the
name of capacity handle change will not
change because we're going to use the
still the same function that's the
reason why we spent so much time on a
proper setup
and then for the types i would need to
do
very similar like we did already
previously so
what we're going to do right here is
we're going to say
that first and foremost we're not going
to be getting the types we're going to
be getting the people so i'm going to
say let
people and again we can name this
however we would like
this is just the naming that i came up
with now we're going to be checking for
unique that is obviously the function
that we set up i'm still going to be
running through the rooms array
then we're going to be looking for
capacity so for each and every room what
would be the unique capacity
as well as we might as well can right
away set up everything with ajsx in this
case we don't need to add anything so
i'm not going to have to use the spread
and i'll add all the all string
and then why don't we do this why don't
we say people
map
there will be item
and the index again because this is an
array
like already previously
then let's just do a return and again we
are returning an option
so we're saying option
key will be item id
or you know what no let's just do
index here because obviously this was
just going to be an array with numbers
whether that's one two or three or four
and then what else we would want for the
option well we would want value of
course
the value will be actual item within
this array that's being returned
and then last but not least we would
want to display whatever we got in there
so item
now within the second select box we're
not going to be looking for the types in
fact we'll be looking for people
let's test this out
sure enough now we do have our guests
everything is working fine we should be
also able to change the values in a
state right away because our handle
change is already working i will gonna
head over to the bigger screen because i
do want to show you the react devtools
let's do inspect let's have a react open
and then i don't have a select box
that's not what i want
type will be all
but what we're going to be focusing on
is of course the capacity i want you to
keep track of something and that is
what type of value this is not what
value this is but what type of value
because as you're looking at notice that
this right now is a number however check
this out
once i save it notice these quotation
marks so what's happening right now this
is in fact string now this is simply
because when we are getting back the
value from the select box this will be
automatically as a string so we're going
to have to do
a little bit of parsing we're all going
to turn it back into a
number that's the reason why we're going
to do that within our function
all right now we're going to head over
back to the context we have our filter
rooms we did our first filter remember
we got our temp rooms so we were
filtering already but now what i'm gonna
do is
right after i got my rooms and
everything by the way i'm gonna start
adding comments because there's gonna be
a bunch of values that are repeating so
in this case i
probably think that
adding comments would make a little bit
more sense
let's say
all the rooms
then after that why don't we do a
transform values
values and what we're saying here is
obviously we already changed the value
in a state so now we're getting back the
capacity but capacity will be string
so what i can do right now is i can say
okay whatever capacity i had and that's
the reason why i use let here because
i'm going to be overwriting them i'm
going to say capacity will be in fact
used with parse integer which will make
sure that instead of string we're going
to be getting
the
number of course
now
this is going to transform the values
and now i would want to write the
commented
filter
by type
and then now we're going to be filtering
by capacity
filter by capacity
whenever we're talking about this kind
of filter
again it will be a lot
similar like we already had before and
the way we're going to write that is
just going to be if
capacity
is not
equal to 1
is not equal to 1 like so then we would
want to filter it again and the way
we're going to filter it we're going to
say temp
rooms again like we had before is equal
to temp
rooms
filter
and then what i would want to pass is
room
if the capacity property on the room so
room capacity is in fact bigger
or equal to a capacity
now if it's going to be one
then again we're not going to touch it
we're pretty much we're going to have
our original array
but if we're going to make sure that
capacity let's say is bigger if we're
getting a bigger value for capacity
let's say 2
then return me only the rooms
that will have this capacity property
bigger or equal to two all right now
let's head over back again we have all
our rooms
check this out if i'm gonna let's say
three
then my value changes in a state and
what do i see i see only the rooms that
have the capacity of three
that's how we can filter by capacity
next one up we have filtering by price
but i do want to
close the console just so you can see
that obviously both of them would work
together so if i'm going to go let's say
for
all then in this case this will not show
anything and that's the reason why i
said to you the more data you're going
to have the more interesting this will
be by filtering of course if i'm saying
that i'm just looking for a room type by
the name of double and then i'm
expecting that this will have a guest of
three unfortunately within those
particular rooms we cannot have three
guests however within the family room we
can check it out okay so all the family
rooms as far as i can tell have right
now right now the
guest minimum of three meaning we can't
stay three people if you would want to
but we also can obviously do that in
prudential that's the reason why it
shows all the rooms which in our case is
just one
that you can stay with the request if
i'm going to go back to all then this
will show me all the family ones and i
can stay
at least three people can stay there
now within the
single and double there is a max and the
max for the single let's say would be
one and four double this will be two
however if i'm going to go let's say
with two
then this again will gonna show me
all the rooms that i would want
let's say in this case all the double
rooms
that two people can stay in and all of
them can stay
in all the double rooms all right now we
do see that both of them can be used
together
so that is working
now next one up we all gonna have the
price
and the more filters we're going to add
it the more of course again
it will depend of how much data you have
because for 13 rooms and if we have six
filters understand that it's kind of
hard to combine them where we can check
by all of them all at the same time now
we can always check them obviously one
by one because we're just returning all
the rooms
but the more filters you're going to
have the more it will going to make
sense to have way more data that way
this will be interesting otherwise of
course for all the double rooms there's
only two people that can stay for all
the single rooms one and so on and so
forth okay now as far as the money is
concerned as far as we're working with
the price
why don't we grab here or you know what
we're going to create a new one because
in this case we will going to create a
input with the type of range
so it's not like we can really
repeat everything within a select
let's write the room
price copy and paste that
let's say
end of room price
end of room price and then here we're
going to write again first a div
with a class of
form group
within the form group
we're going to have some label
then i will going to go with price for
my label and we're just going to write
room price and we can also access
the current price that we're going to
have because what we need to remember is
that we're all going to be changing this
notice how the price will be changing
and we'll be displaying whatever price
we have currently whatever value we have
in the state
that's the reason why we're going to
access price here after the label we're
going to work with an inputs
so i'm going to say that there will be
input now this will not be
simple text
in fact we're going to have range and
now name again
is important because it needs to match
whatever we're going to have in state so
this will be price
and for the range we have min max that's
the reason why we set up mean price
and max price values that's the reason
why we're getting them out of the state
so max
attribute will be equal to the max
price
and then we'll have an id now id again
will be used
with a label let's just write price
and we also need of course the value
value will be the price that we are
getting currently from
the state
on change
will work with a handle change like we
already did before
handle
change and then last but not least we
have the class name
class name and the class name will be
simply um what we have we have form
control
form control let's check it out
control and not control x in fact this
will be control once we say that yep
this of course is the room price but i
can change that oh no actually
everything is working already yeah right
because we already have the handle
change now as i'm going to be scrolling
i'm not filtering anything but you
notice how the value is changing and
that's the reason why i have 600 if
you'll notice in all my rooms the max
value
will be 600 and that's something that we
didn't by the way we already had the
filter here but the reason for that is
because my presidential is 600 if some
room would be let's say
thousand and thousand dollars would be
shown
and remember we did that in the context
in the very beginning when we were
getting our data
now once we have the room price all this
is done
what we need is filtering because at the
moment again
we are just getting the type as well as
the capacity again as we're looking at
our state
what you'll notice is that
from the range again the same thing
happens like we did before
where the value will be changing in
state all that is going to be happening
but
notice the max price is 600
the moment i touch it the price is 577
and as you can see here quotation marks
that means that this is a string and
again something that whenever you're
working with the range the return that
you're going to get back
will be in fact a string so what we need
to do is again the same thing like we
did with capacity
then in this case we're just going to
change this around
where we're going to have not capacity
but we're going to write price so the
price that we are getting
from the state first and foremost
and now let's do a little bit of
filtering where again after the filter
by capacity you know what i'm going to
add here change
state just so i can see
where i'm actually changing the state
and we're going to set up another filter
now this filter be filter
filter by price
and then what we're going to do over
here we're going to say if
and in this case we can just go with no
if statement because what we need to
understand that if
in general we're going to be changing
the price then we would just want to
display all the rooms that are being
obviously rendered right now in that
case we can skip the if statement we can
say temp
rooms equals to
temp rooms
like so and we're gonna run with filter
now within the filter we're gonna have
what well we're gonna have not temp
rooms
but we're gonna have temp
and temp room instead of temp rooms
and then filter and what are we saying
here we're going to say room if
your price
is less
than the price that we currently have in
the range then that room will be
displayed
so let's write room
price if your price is less
than price then obviously our rooms will
be rendered okay let's save that
and if we're going to go to the bigger
screen again i'm going to close this one
right now
and if you're going to notice something
that
if i'm changing the price
also
the rooms that have the price
less
than what we currently have in the range
only those rooms will be rendered i'm
going to go up to let's say 431 the last
room will be 400
and then i have 280 and that's how we
can filter according to a price that
we're setting here in our range
now that we are experts already how we
can work with the filtering
why don't we complete our application as
far as our search rooms component is
concerned because in this case we will
gonna set up filter according to the
size
as well as we are going to create these
check boxes and set up the functionality
okay now we have the end of room that is
not what we want right now we would want
the size and i'm going to say end of
size
and off size
as well as we will going to have a div
by the name of form
group
within this form group we will going to
have label a label will be for the size
in this case
and then we're going to call this room
size after the label
i would want to set up div
now within this div and we're going to
call this size
inputs and not input but in fact inputs
and then within this div we're all going
to place these two inputs one will be
for the small size and the other one
will be for the big size uh input type
will be number
we're gonna head over with a number and
then as far as name is concerned we're
gonna say min
size
id in this case we'll just gonna be a
size
of course because this is what we have
labeled for
size then our value will be from the
state
mean
size
and then what else we would want well we
also could use on change
that will be equal to our handle
change and last one will be class name
class name will be of course for styling
self explanatory
size input size
input so size hyphen input all right
that is my input and what i would want
right now is copy and paste this guy
copy and paste that and the second one
will just have different values where
instead of min size will change
everywhere to the max size
now that obviously is in two places
so value
as well as the naming will be
max size instead
that should do it that will be my room
size min and max and again remember the
filtering that we did
all the way in the very very beginning
when we did have component did mount we
checked for the max size and we set this
up in a state so that is exactly why we
have this value of thousand again if one
room would have a bigger size bigger
square footage obviously that will be
rendered and then last but not least i
would want to show these check boxes
so in this case let's write extras and i
just want to complete here everything
within our component and then we're
going to set up the context there's no
point for us to jump back and forth
because we already should have the
general idea
and of extras
now in this one
again we're going to start with the div
form
group within the div
we're going to have a
two other divs
one of them will be where both of them
in fact will be single extra
single
extra within this div what i would want
is input by the type of
checkbox
name will be breakfast and again this
needs to match whatever state values we
have
uh for the id i don't think we need
anything
just delete it because there's not going
to be a label or you know what no
my apologies there will be a label so
why don't we write here break
first
like so and right after the input we're
gonna write our label and i didn't
notice that it was right after it and
why don't we write uh breakfast since
that is the div and let's just write
breakfast
here as well
okay we have our setup for the input we
do need to have obviously the value
however the value in this case will not
going to be
value attribute by itself but because we
are working with a checkbox we need to
set the sql as checked now for the check
we will going to be checking what is the
value that we're getting back from the
breakfast property in state all right
and we also have the on change
that will be applied later on
so i'm going to say unchange
and they'll change let's save that this
will be my breakfast and just to show
you that this is working if i'm gonna
head over back to a
state and i'm gonna set this equal to
true notice the checkbox will be checked
okay
let's do that let's say
false
back to false and last but not least i
would want one more div exactly the same
just the value will not be breakfast it
will be pets
now in this case i will gonna select
bunch of them
because i would want to pretty much
change them all together so i have one
breakfast second breakfast
this guy's a breakfast
this guy is a breakfast and this guy's a
breakfast we're going to delete them all
i'm just going to write pets
that should be the value that i'm
getting back from the state so pets pets
and pets this should do it
once we have this kind of setup
then
we have
context of course
and we can do all our changes in the
context
first one we are going to be looking at
is not going to be filtering by price
but in fact we're going to filter by
size the way this is going to work we're
going to say and this is change state so
let's leave that but again we don't need
to even use the if statement
and just say temp
rooms
and temp rooms is obviously the array
we'll have and we're always going to
filter it and we're going to say filter
by and in this case we're going to say
room
and now i'm going to be checking we want
to make sure that we are only returning
the room
which size is in fact
bigger than minimum size that we're
going to have over here and smaller than
maximum the way we write that we can
just say
room size
is
bigger and by the way i need to write
bigger here
i need to say
bigger
than a min size
and then also i need to use the and
operator so i'm saying and
room size is
less than the mac size
so min and max okay
this is going to filter depending on the
room size and we also have two more
filters
and those ones will be the breakfast and
the pets
why don't we add here that
filter
by size
and filter let's say
filter by breakfast
breakfast
and then copy and paste that and this
will be pets
pets and again very simple filter where
i'm going to say if
breakfast is true
so in fact if we click on it
then we were going to be checking
basically
temp rooms again
temp rooms is equal to
temp rooms
filter and then return me a room
that room breakfast
is in fact equal to true
okay and very
similar way
where we have filtered by pets
you can just copy and paste that
filter by pets and instead of breakfast
of course we're just gonna have to
change it here
we're gonna say we are selecting both of
them
and we would just want to select pets
whether the pets is true then of course
we're gonna be returning only the rooms
that allow pets uh one thing that i
wanna mention is the fact that the
reason why the checkbox
it doesn't use the value attribute it
just uses the checked attribute that's
the reason why we checked the type and
if the type was checkbox then we know
that we're targeting the checked
attribute
instead of the value attribute we're
almost ready to take our baby out for
spin
but i am noticing that there is a bug
because in this case i set this equal to
target so i went with event not target
this is equal to target and instead of
what i'm not checking is i should be
checking
target
type
not the event type right
now let's set this up we're gonna head
over to our document and in this case
why don't we start checking which rooms
have the breakfast and which don't so if
i click on it i'm being shown that these
four rooms have the breakfast if we
click on it again now we see all the
rooms
same thing we can do with the pets these
rooms allow pets however these rooms can
have pets and the breakfast if you're
gonna get rid of the pets now you're
gonna have only breakfast so what we can
see is that all the rooms that offer
breakfast also offer pets however
there's rooms that don't offer breakfast
but do offer free pets and of course we
can combine it with all the rest of the
filters that we already had the same
goes with size i could go to let's say
zero square footage in this case this is
not going to work but let's say
these rooms are at least
500 square footage
and i can obviously add it to the price
and so on and so forth this is how we
can set up all the filtering in our
application
awesome guys we have a fully functional
project however there is one thing that
is bugging me and that one thing is very
simple
currently we are using our local data
and while that not be a big issue and
overall it was really good when we were
setting up the application because if we
needed to do any kind of changes we
could just do it in our data js the
problem will be later on when we're
hosting this application let's say on
netlife because if we're using the local
data that means two things first of all
we always will gonna have to have access
to this project on our machine honestly
if we would want to make some kind of
changes and let's say if we would want
to add one more room
we would need to get that image we would
need to import this image in a file set
up the object as well as what that means
is that most likely you'll be the one
who needs to add these changes and for
the simple reason let's imagine scenario
where person is not aware of what is a
javascript object or something like that
and they're struggling with this kind of
setup so wouldn't it be nicer if there
would be a external resource
where we can set up our data separately
from our project in order to set up the
data we're going to have a nice
graphical interface
so even
somebody who doesn't know anything about
our project would be able to do it and
we could access that data
using the cdn and not only that we could
access the data
even though we would have different type
of application let's say currently we're
obviously using the react application
well we could do the same with gatsby we
could do the same with venandle.js
and that external platform
will be by the name of contentful and i
already named all the nice features
about contentful but why don't i repeat
well contentful is a content
infrastructure and what that means is
that we can have a nice graphical
interface to set up our application and
then we can consume our application
regardless whether we have react
application gatsby application vanilla
js application just to name a few and
counterfall is something called headless
cms or boyf which would translate to
bring your own front end and this is
exactly what i mentioned before
where regardless of the type of
application we're going to have we will
be able to consume our data without
changing the data
obviously
contentful has
a paid versions and all that but we will
going to use a free one and the free one
just requires for the email nothing more
so i would encourage you to sign up you
get like 5 000 records two spaces and
all that so i don't think there is no
reason why you shouldn't try it out and
set it up for this application now next
one up i will gonna log in again
hopefully you're gonna sign up for the
free version and you're gonna be able to
follow along now once we click on login
i will gonna be directed to a space and
this is something you won't gonna see
because most likely in the beginning
you're just gonna have to sign up for
the example space so you'll be met by
this type of screen now in this video i
would like to do a brief overview what
you should expect from the interface and
next we're going to be setting up the
content model as well as the content so
as you're looking at it there's really
four things that are really important
especially in the beginning
as you're working with contentful so
first of all would be the space again
most likely you'll gonna have the
example space but if you would want to
create a new space and you can think of
it as a database as a project you can
just click here on creating a new space
as you're using the free ones you can
see that i'm using one of two and that
means that the moment i'm going to
create a second one that would exceed
what i can use with obviously the free
one or that would pretty much limit to
two environments now i'm going to open
this up and i'm going to call this
example just like you probably will
going to have in the very very beginning
so i'm going to say proceed then we're
going to create a new space and before
we start talking about content model or
content i would want to show you that if
you have that example space or in
general you have a space and you do want
to delete it you will need to head over
to general settings and notice then it
says remove space and all its contents
and then you just need to say okay so
this is going to be the example one or
whatever space you have and if you would
want to remove it
you just need to type
example obviously the name of it and i
went all caps here
an example and we're going to remove the
space then again i'm going to go back to
the space that i already had depending
on what you have you can either create a
new one or you can keep on working on
the example one that let's say you
didn't delete
then we have a space home and what's
really nice over here is the
documentation for how we're going to be
consuming the data we were going to use
the sdk which means software development
kit but you can obviously access this
also with api we're not going to do that
right now because we still would need to
have a look how we can set up the data
then next one up we have the content
model and notice we have beach room or
beach resort room obviously this for you
should be empty
because if you just set up the data but
for me i already set up the data that
we're going to be consuming with this
application again what content model
would be if we're going to head over
back
that would be the structure
for your inputs so let's say in our case
this is obviously a room so content
model would be structure for that room
input and you can think of it again as
an object you can think of it as any
kind of structure that would give you
availability later on to add that
particular data notice i have few
content models here for multiple courses
and tutorials let's say i have coffee
item comfy house products and so on and
so forth and what you're noticing here
these would be the fields so this would
describe
what kind of content i'm actually going
to be adding all right
now once we have the content model then
after that we have the content so once i
have set up the blueprint of how my data
will be structured
then i only need to work as a factory
and just keep adding any kind of data i
would like so if i'm going to go over to
my beach resort room you'll notice that
i you have or i have 13 entries and this
will pretty much be each and every room
all right now last but not least
as far as the general interface we would
be interested again in the settings and
setting up the api keys so why we're
interested in that because in order to
consume that data we will gonna have to
use these api keys we can head over to
api keys again for you you most likely
will just gonna have one example one but
i already set it up a multiple ones for
my different tutorials and projects and
the way you can just add a new api key
very simply just click over here we're
adding new api key you can name it
however you'd like you can have
description but yeah what you'll be
interested is this data one will be the
access token and the second one will be
space id now once we have the general
idea how the contentful
interface works next one up we're going
to be setting up the content model as
well as the content for our data
once we have the general understanding
how we can work with contentful
interface next one up we would want to
set up the structure
for the data that we're going to be
creating
i already have the structure i already
have beach room resort as well as i have
all the data here now i do want to show
you how to do it from the scratch and
this is the reason why i'm going to set
up the example one however in the next
video when we're going to be adding the
data i will going to keep on adding to
the data to a content model that i
already have because there's no point
for me to create two of them and just
keep adding to the new one all right but
i do want to show you how to do
everything from scratch so first things
first we would need to go with add
content type and the name here is
important because this will be used as
api identifier so you will going to need
to access it later on because by default
you are going to be getting all your
data and most likely you would want to
limit of what kind of data you would
like to consume so in my case i will
gonna call this beach
beach uh resort
room and you can call this however you
would like i will gonna go with example
because
by the next video i'm gonna delete it
anyway so i'm gonna write a create a new
one and notice this is the id that we're
going to be using
like it says here use this id to
retrieve everything related to this
content type via api all right so this
is something that you would need to
remember regarding of what kind of
naming you have and the next one up is
very very simple where we just start
adding the fields we would like so i'm
going to go with the first one and the
first one will be name as you can see
these would be the type of fields we can
have whether we have the rich text text
number
and i'm not going to name them all of
them you can obviously see them as
you're working with contentful now we're
going to go with the text this will be
the first one for the name and here we
have two options we can go with the
short one or the long one so for
description we're gonna go with the long
one but for the simple name field i'm
just gonna go here and i'm gonna say
that i would like to create
and the moment we created we have two
options we could have configured in a
previous screen or we can do it here now
what do i mean by configuration well a
lot of times what i see especially in
the courses and tutorials where
people forget to add that particular
field so let's say they do set up here
your content model but later on when
they're adding the content they like
skip some kind of field and then when
they're trying to access it they write
me hey john listen there's something
wrong with application i cannot access
that particular field well the problem
is that most cases the
student or whoever is watching the
project just skips adding that field so
in order to avoid that we can just go
with required field so that way we're
making sure that we're not going to be
able to save
this particular content as we're adding
that content into this content model if
we skip that field now this is really up
to you if you're 100 confident that
you'll not be that person then obviously
you can skip this but in general i
always prefer to do it myself because
that way i am not skipping something all
right now first one was the name then
after that we have the slug and again
we're going to go with simple text
i'm going to go in slug we're going to
create and in general i'm going to go to
validations in required field now i'm
also going to show you how we can do it
right away as we're saving next field up
will be price and for that we're going
to go with integer in this case we have
a decimal so if you're going to go with
the rooms let's say that have decimal
price obviously go with decimal i'm
going to go with integer and i'm just
going to call this price
all right now i'm going to create it and
in this case notice we also have create
and configure and that way we right away
go to validations and we can just say
required and obviously you have other
options but again we're going to be
skipping in this tutorial then we have
the type right after the price
we're going to go with the type
type will be again short text so we're
going to go with type short text create
configure validations
required field and next one up we do
have the size for the size again we're
going to go with integer so number
integer
this will be size of the room so what
would be the square footage validations
required field
all right then we do have the capacity
so what would be the max people of how
many can stay in a room again we're
going to go with integer
so let's call this size create configure
and in this case it's complaining that
it's already there well because the name
obviously isn't uh size its capacity
my bad capacity create and configure
foundations required field all right we
have that
then we have two of them pets and
breakfast that will be boolean
so we just go with let's say boolean
here and we have pets whether pets are
allowed
again we set up the validations
all right next one up we have breakfast
again we're gonna go with boolean
breakfast create and configure and in
this case again we are going with the
required field
after that we're looking whether the
room is featured
so whether the room shows up on homepage
this is where we're setting up that
featured room and in this case again
we'll go with that field again we're
going to go with boolean
featured and i will going to be skipping
over here because this is as
straightforward as it gets
again we're going to go with a required
field
and then we have the description extras
and images and just to show that
obviously you don't have to always have
everything required
i will not gonna create them as required
fields but again remember if you want
them as required fields make sure that
you click on configuration let's go with
a description and for description we
will going to go with long text because
technically we could fit everything that
we have here of course i don't think we
have 255 but i will gonna go with long
text now in this case how we're going to
call this description
like so create and again in this case
i'm not going to be requiring that field
extras will be what we can see in a
single home page
notice if we're going to be navigating
here
these were going to be my extras and for
extras we're going to use something new
that we haven't seen yet and that is a
json object
so what we're going to say is the json
object this is what we're going to use
for
extras create and configure if you want
to have required or i'm just going to go
with required and then last one will be
images
now for the images notice that we are
obviously using multiple of them because
for the single page it's not just one
image in fact this is many files so this
is the
difference if you just want one image
you go with one file if you want
multiple images you just say that
images and this will be many files okay
now once we create it i will gonna save
it again remember this is where we're
gonna be able to find the id obviously
i'm gonna come back to this i'm just
giving you a heads up and then once we
save it in the next video i would like
to start adding the content because our
content model is there so we have the
blueprint of what kind of data we would
like to add and if we would want to add
the data again we're heading over to the
content and then we have option
basically decide where you would want to
add the entry if i would want to add to
beach resort room which i will do i
would add it here if you want to add to
example or the one that you created
obviously you would need to click on
that in your case most likely just
because you just started this will be
the only option
the content model that we just created
but in general once you're gonna have
multiple this is where you will need to
use this drop down and decide where you
would want to add the content once we
have successfully set up the content
model now this would be a great time to
start adding the content before we do
that i will gonna delete my example
because like i said previously i will
gonna be adding my content to previously
already created content model and in
order to delete that particular content
model we just need to head over there
click on deleting
then i will gonna select the name here
since i'm lazy to type it out and sure
enough we can just delete it and the
content model is gone
then we're gonna head over to the
content and like i said we would need to
decide
to where we would want to add it to
which content model well in our case i
will gonna go with beach resort room and
we're just gonna click on adding the
entry again the same would go here we we
can click anywhere we would want but we
have the suggested one already alright
now in this case once we click on it we
are adding the entry and then we just
need to decide what would be the name
since i'm going for all the rooms i'm
going with single then double then let's
say family in this case just because
these will be examples i'm just going to
name them triple
and we're going to start with economy
and then we also would need to add a
slug in your case as always you can come
up with whatever names you would want
then for the type this will be
triple price let's say will be 500 bucks
size will be 1200 uh square footage
then capacity we're obviously going to
say that max
three people can stay there uh no pets
allowed no breakfast no free breakfast
it will not be featured and again just
because i want to save a little bit of
time i'm just going to grab the
description that i had already
previously we're going to copy and paste
that then next one up we have the extras
and for the next again i already have
this array set up like this for the json
one so i'm just going to copy and paste
it in your case if you want to create it
from scratch this is really up to you
then we have the image and we have
multiple ways how we can add images the
first one the most easiest one would be
from your local machine so i'm just
going to click on it this is going to
select everything that i have i will
going to head over to a desktop
then i already added them to the images
and most likely you're gonna have these
images as well
and we're gonna start by room 13. so
we're going to open that all right this
will be our first image and then always
always remember to click on publishing
otherwise again this is the part where
sometimes uh somebody who's watching
tutorial or course skips and then you'll
have no access to that image this would
be our first and only image currently
but remember we set it up that we will
have multiple images and what we can do
here the other option would be link
existing assets and in this case i'm
having all the images that i already
have in the contentful in your case
again probably you'll just gonna have
this one image so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna find
where i have those linked images and
remember when i had a single room for
all the rooms i had these three images
that were basically describing that one
particular room and the way you can do
that is since again you're linking your
assets you can just say okay show me
this one this one and this one so these
three will be added and the way i did it
is i added for all the rooms now once we
have this set up the only thing we need
to do is click on adding and then we
have a few options we can click here
where we're going back to
all the content that we have or i can
just add a new one here again multiple
ways how we can
create a new content and in this case
i'm back in the content screen where i
could search for different type of
contents so this is going to give me
coffee item again coffee product or i'm
gonna go back to beach room sort this
will show me all the entries that i have
and then if i would want to add new
entry obviously i just click here and
again if you want you can add it to
different content types but since we're
working right now with beach rooms it
will only gonna make sense if we keep on
adding the content all right now let's
go with content
not content sorry triple
and let's call this basic
then again we're gonna do the same thing
so lots of repetition here
triple basic
type will be triple
then uh price let's go with i don't know
six hundred dollars again i'm just free
riding right now here um i don't know 30
or 3 000 square feet
capacity still will be three people no
pets
no breakfast or you know what let's give
it a breakfast here but no pets it will
not be featured and say mulch peel here
we're gonna go with description
i'm just gonna make sure that we copy
everything correctly
then copy and paste json the same deal
we had our extras
okay so just a little bit of data input
here
then last one will be images and again
in this case i will gonna show you that
we are not limited to adding from the
computer or from the assets we already
have we can obviously also do the web
search so let's say here you would look
for i don't know hotel so this is just
gonna give you all the images that you
can add for the hotel i will not gonna
go with this route i will still going to
continue adding from my device but just
to let you know this is also your option
i'm going to go with room 14
this will be my image
all right as always let's make sure that
we remember to click on publishing
then we're going to head over back and
like i said we would want to add these
new assets and by the way this is not
what i wanted to do this is going to
give me the draft where i can just
delete it so in this case i can say all
right i don't want this asset and last
one i would want is link existing assets
or the way we would do that of course
again we're going to find for the images
that will be added to all my rooms okay
now this will be added again we can just
get rid of that guy because we don't
need it and then we just click on
publish so this will be the second one
and i'll show the third one which will
be the last one because again you
probably don't want to watch me do the
data entry so it doesn't really make
sense to do more in three now last one
i'll show you that we can do it from the
actions tab right here so we don't have
to go back
just click here create now this will
gonna create a new m tree and then i'm
gonna check it out what was the naming
that i used so i used single standard
okay so this will be my last one so i'm
gonna go with single
or you know what not triple uh triple
standard
standard room this will be standard of
course the slug will be the same just
with a hyphen
like so type will be still triple
price i don't know we can go with maybe
200
again we're just free writing here
uh size i don't know maybe go with 400
capacity still three
and why don't we add for this one the
pets are allowed as well as the
breakfast but it will still not be
featured and last but not least i would
want to head over and again add the
description
like we did before so let's check it out
this will be my description
maybe let's get rid of all the quotation
marks here
like so
and we have also obviously our json data
for
extras so let's select that
this will be added here and then let's
add also the images like we already did
before
where we're going to click on that
then we're going to head over to room
15.
this will add our image okay so far so
good you can obviously right away
publish it and let's link our existing
assets which by this time if you have
been coding along you should have at
least some images already there so you
can click on existing assets then we're
going to find them i'm going to say this
guy this guy and this guy
will be added and of course i'm just
going to publish that
then the moment i do that
once we're were gonna head over back to
all my data
i should be able to see that i have 16
where previously i had 13. once you have
added whatever rooms you would like
obviously in your case if you're trying
to access it it would make more sense
the more rooms you're going to have
because like i said the moment you start
filtering it it makes sense that you
have more data otherwise if you have
three rooms the filtering is also going
to be kind of boring once you have added
the data next one we're gonna look at
how we can access this data from our
application all right guys we
successfully set up our data structure
as well as we added the data so now this
would be the time where we start in fact
consuming our data and the fastest way
of doing it would be using the sdk and
for that we will gonna have to install
one more package by the name of you
guessed it contentful or contentful
doesn't really matter however you would
want to pronounce it i will going to
stop the dev server i'm going to clear
the console right now and we're going to
copy and paste it here the npm install
contentful or contentful and let me just
copy and paste that and sure enough this
will be installing right now while this
is being installed why don't we right
away
check it out the documentation and what
we're really interested
is creating the client
as well as running the method of getting
entries again there's a bunch of things
that you can do here and if you would
want to get a single entry obviously
check it out the get entry but what we
will be interested
is getting entries now as we're
scrolling down
you're all going to notice that first
and foremost we do need to install it
they also let you know that if for
example you're working with simple
vanilla javascript application you can
do something like this where you are
using the cdn but it will not be our
case of course because we do have the
content full installed and then we just
need to require it of course and then
run this method create client
and we need to pass here the object with
two parameters one would be space and
the second one will be access token now
i'll show you in a second again where we
do need to get this information but i
think this will be our first step
so why don't we clear the console we can
start the dev server
obviously these will be two first steps
then i can close it and we can create a
new file so within the source i could
say you know what i would want a new
file
and i'm going to call this file let's
say
contentful
contentful and we're going to say js and
instead of using
the syntax that they give us here which
by the way we can do it you can just
copy and paste it why don't we set up
the es6 way what i'm going to say import
now in this case i will need to use the
named import and the method name will be
create client this will be from
contentful and then right away we're
going to use the export default we're
going to say export default and we're
going to run this method or the function
but we're going to pass in obviously our
own parameters so the first one will be
space and the second one will be access
token where can we get this information
remember in the very very beginning i
showed you that here we have the api
keys under the settings we head over to
api keys and we just need to create one
now i can name this however i would like
this could be store 4 or whatever i'm
just going to say resort
rooms or something like this
then let's copy this guy let's say that
this will be my space
and we're going to set this equal and as
a side note in the next video before we
deploy this on a netlify we will going
to create our environment variables okay
so if you are right now committing this
to the github please don't because you
probably don't want to share this
information
then i'm going to get also my
access token
and the same would go here for the
property on the object access token and
this will be equal to my string
now let's save that we have successfully
exported right away this function
so now our next step will be heading
over to the context
then right after the items i would want
to import since this is a default export
anyway i can name this however i would
want i will name this client and this
will be coming from my local content
file so the same folder all right now
once i have that i will gonna use client
and then if you're looking at it in
their example they give you this get
entry
where we are looking for specific
entries and this is what i was saying
where
these two probably will be your most
used ones where either you're getting
all the entries or you're getting
specific one now you have other options
here but these will probably be your
most used ones instead of getting the
entry which we will not do i'm gonna
head over to the get entries and right
away notice what happens so they give
you an idea what you should do and this
is exactly how we're gonna test it out
first by running client which in our
case obviously would be whatever we
would name it because that was a default
export the click client or create client
and then we're just going to run get
entries this will return a promise
and then we're going to consume the
promise with dot then and then we're
just going to be looking for response
and the reason for that because i want
to show you
what would be the pitfall
if we are not filtering actually our
entries okay let's copy this in our case
i already named this client so we're
going to have to
adjust it a little bit where it will not
gonna be client
but let's say all the way on the top of
our file i'm just gonna run it now first
and foremost i do wanna check whether my
dev server is running before i start
checking out the console yes everything
is correct and then we'll gonna head
over back to my recording and let's see
what happens if i open up the console
okay now in this case
nothing is happening but at the moment i
do have my array and what do you see
right now when i see array of 64
and the problem is the fact that i'm
getting
all the data
that i have right now so everything that
i have and by the way i'm going to save
the changes here so it's working but all
my entries are here not just my 16
the ones that i was looking for where i
said that i would want the beach
resort room as you can see right now i
can't filter it out but if i'm looking
at all my data in fact the value will be
64.
so
what i'm saying is if you're going to
have multiple content types
for let's say each and every project you
probably would want to filter it out you
can obviously do this in your file i
could go back and be like okay whatever
data i'm getting back i would want to
filter it somehow out but you can also
do it right away as you're making the
request and in order to understand more
information about this what we were
going to do
as we are getting the entries we were
going to head over to rest api reference
and this will going to give us more
details
now
as we're looking at it notice what
they're saying if you want to query
entries we would need to use
either content id or content type now in
our case we're going to go with content
type and if you're going to click on
querying the entries check this out so
they tell you okay
what would be the content type and then
within the content type we are passing
in the id
now your next question probably will be
well where are we looking for that id
and remember in the very very beginning
when we were setting this up
i was like a chicken and i was
reminding you all the time you need to
remember this id you need to remember
this id and when i say remember
obviously i don't mean that you need to
remember the id for each and every
content model that you have but you
should know where to find it so if
you're going to go to that particular
content model this is the id
that you'll have to use in order to
filter your data
depending on your particular content
model
so what we can do over here is again
we're just testing it out right now
don't worry about it but we do need to
write content
like so then underscore
type and then let's pass in that beach
room sort because that was obviously the
name of my content type if you have a
different name please add a different
name than one that's matching and voila
in our case we have the 16 items that i
was looking for so once i have this
information of course
we would need to
restructure a little bit of our
application because the moment the only
thing that i'm doing is console logging
and that is obviously not the extent
that i would like to do so remember in
the very very beginning i said to you
they're all going to be this function
by the name of get data that will be
responsible for getting the data from
the continental and instead
of doing everything in the component did
mount where we again used our method the
one that we created ourselves with
format data instead we were going to
move all this functionality into this
this dot get data and then we're just
going to run this
function okay now let's list it up first
of all let's build it we're going to
name this
surprisingly get data
then this will be a sync because i do
want to use a sync weight because this
is just a little bit
more straightforward syntax
as we're dealing with asynchronous code
so let's write it here async await and
you know what why don't we right away at
it within a try catch because that way
we're all going to be able to find more
errors if there are any and the first
thing
why don't we console log the error
just in case there is one and then
within the try what would we want to set
up
well we're all going to be waiting for
response and since we are using a single
weight i can just say okay let
response and this will be equal to
a weight
because i am using a sink weight and
then i have the client and in this case
i am using again get entries so either
you can copy and paste it whatever we
had here on top where we had the entries
and then you would want to add this
content type now we will gonna add one
more thing for the order but that will
be in a second so you know what since
i'll have to delete it anyway i will
gonna get rid of this guy i will gonna
delete that then
and we're just going to set this await
equal to whatever response we're going
to be getting so now we're getting back
this in this response variable all right
now okay so far so good we got our
response back
now what well we have all this
functionality
and remember again i was repeating this
over and over again when i said
we are creating this function correct
but then within the function at the
moment we were passing all the time i
keep repeating local data local data
local data and then once we're going to
get external data we will going to flip
it around
where all this data that we were using
all the time locally
we all just going to use externally and
we are
not going to change any functionality
below that all right so how this is
going to work well i am using right now
my response i'm getting my response so
it's very easy in fact i can
take everything that i had already
before
here we can just actually cut it out
because again i don't see the point of
rewriting anything
we can
uncomment this so we will
run this that data
however after the response
once i copy and paste that the
difference would be that i'm not adding
here the items then in fact we will
gonna
pass within our function response items
so the way this all works is i'm getting
back my response from the contentful and
on the response object there will be
items
now if i open up my response check this
out what happened here when we were
console logging remember we were console
logging response data items
this is the array that we already had
locally meaning like i said we had less
fields we obviously didn't have in a
system object so many options we didn't
have as well some maybe extra stuff that
they had within the fields property but
in general the setup was exactly the
same and again if you want to double
check that you can notice that whenever
you're going to be dealing with
get entries this is exactly what's going
to happen you will going to have your
response object and then within the
results pawn subject the property name
will be items and the way we structured
our data locally is a simple difference
that
as i'm getting this data right now
externally i don't pass items i pass
response items of course you could set
this up differently but the main idea is
very simple here that now the data will
be
from contentful it will be external data
and the difference pretty much is just
the fact that we are getting it from the
control i'm specifically saying what
kind of data i'm looking for and then
from the response i'm just using the
items and everything else here yes will
stay the same now what i would like to
do right now is comment out the items
just for sure that you know that i'm not
using the local data
we will gonna save that
and voila people if everything is
correct and i can by the way close the
console check this out i already can see
that i have featured rooms
so this is working really well
and then i have rooms all together so i
have all my 16 rooms check this out so i
have four rows with four columns each
now i know that i successfully got the
data because if you remember
locally i had only 13 items and now
we're working with 16 items and again we
didn't have to change any kind of
functionality or anything like that
that's the reason why we went through
the pain in the beginning
when
we structured our data exactly
like they would the only difference
obviously is that we are getting back
the object and we placed everything
already in this items so that was our
items array but this way we don't need
to recreate anything i don't need to
refactor anything because it already
matches the format that we're getting
back and again we can do all the
filtering and everything and i'm not
going to bore you right now however
there is one thing that you probably
noticed where you're like
okay so i get single standard
then right away i have triple standard
then i have double economy and again
we could actually set up some kind of
filtering right now here i could say
okay whatever items i got filter
depending on that and only then update
rooms you could do it
but since this is a case where i would
want to show you that we can also do it
from the contentful why don't we head
over again to documentation
and be rockstars and find out how we can
do that
so if i'm gonna go again back to
api reference
we all gonna scroll down
we eventually will to hit the order or
let's say reverse order now let's test
it out we would say let's say order and
there we're going to give you an example
here pretty much where we can order it
depending on a date and again in this
case i just want to
speed this up
so i'm just going to grab this
information order
we're all going to head over back and
the next one
will be depending on order now they do
warn you right away that
you do need to right away set up a
specific content type so notice they're
saying you must set the content type
otherwise obviously you're going to be
pretty much working with all of the data
that you're getting back now in this
case why don't we set this up so in this
case i'm using the order now let's save
that
and
yep what happens here is that i have
single economy which was first then
single basic single standard single
deluxe and so on and so forth let's
imagine that you don't believe me you're
like okay
i don't believe that this is actually
working maybe he's just saying that that
was how the order came in okay just to
prove my point
we still have the comma i will going to
comment this out right now and why don't
we set up instead we can use the order
property again that's what we need to do
and then what is the property that we
would want to order in well why don't we
try it out the price and again if you
want to find out what property you
should order by
you just need to go back again to your
local data and remember each and every
object has all the same properties so
what do you have within the fields we
have name we have slog type price so why
don't we order them by price okay why
don't we start very simply by ordering
them by price
as we're heading over again back to
context.js
now where is the price it is in the
fields property and then we're looking
for the price let's save that
and yeah
now everything is grouped by the price
again we have 100.50 to 200 250 again
250 and i can go on and on and on now
last one why don't we check it out how
we can do the reverse order because
again this is something that they
suggest in the documentation where the
next one would be reverse order and the
only thing we would need to do again is
use the order property and then flip the
sign
where this would be
a
negative sign or subtraction sign
now let's test it out
like i keep saying all the time let's do
the negative one and now i should start
with 600 or whatever was my max yep it
was 600 and then obviously we're going
reverse order
as i said before all the things that we
could do manually of course ourselves
but what i'm trying to show is that
contentful gives you nice options where
you can already get your data structured
the way you would like
we successfully have pulled data from
the contentful and now we're ready to
deploy our application online well
there's many awesome platforms that we
could use in our case we're going to use
netlify because it's an awesome
hassle-free service and even free
account allows you to do a bunch of
things in order to get the free account
the only thing you would need to do is
sign up with your email and they will
not gonna hassle you you're not gonna
have to leave your credit card or
anything like that and you're going to
be good to go assuming that you already
have signed up for the account i'm just
going to log in and in your case
probably if you just sign up for the
service this screen will be empty in my
case i have a bunch of projects for the
tutorials on the project there's two
ways how we can do it we can do a single
drag and drop or in fact we can use the
continuous deployment using the github
this is the option we're gonna choose so
for that you're also gonna need to have
a github account however assuming that
you're watching a react tutorial it's
safe to say that you probably already
have one so i'm just gonna be kind of
skipping a lot of things because i do
find it very very basic first and
foremost we're gonna have to create a
new repository i'm gonna name one i
don't know
react
beach
resort
and let's say recording
and then what i would like to have is
the
external url and in my case it's saying
okay you can have it and the reason why
i would want the remote url because this
is going to let my git know where to
push the application that we have built
then we're going to head over back to my
document and before we
actually set up the git i would like to
change these variables to the
environment variables because i wouldn't
want to push them up to the github now
in order to do that we're going to first
create a new file we're going to call
this dot env
development like so once we have this
file i would also right away want to add
this to git ignore so this way the file
will be ignored when we're going to be
pushing this up to the github
and let's call this not git ignore but
in fact env
development just make sure that you add
this dot in front of it and once we have
the
development file within
the file we're going to create the
environment variables
now in that case we can change how we're
accessing them so instead of just
placing the string here so the rest of
the world can see our secret variables
we're going to set them up in the
environment variable file and the way we
work it with create react app the naming
would be react
underscore app and then whatever name of
your variable so in my case i will going
to call this api
and let's call this space i'm going to
set this equal to whatever string i had
first and foremost and the second will
be this access token
so let's grab this value as well by the
way we can probably cut this out and
we'll just go with naming react
app
access
token and then let's copy and paste that
once i have these two values what's
going to happen is my application will
break even though we were going to be
accessing them now let me show you how
this is going to work first and foremost
if you would want to access these
environment variables we go with
process.env
and then whatever name we had so in my
case this was
react app api space
so let's copy and paste that and the
second one will be exactly the same but
of course the variable name should be
matching whatever i had for the access
token
so let's delete that
and we're gonna go with the react app
that is again the important part and
let's call this access
token once i'm going to save it my
application will going to break and the
reason why it will break because every
time we're creating these environment
variables we do need to restart the
server so let's stop the server
clear the integrated terminal
and let's run npm start just double
check that everything is working because
obviously it doesn't make sense pushing
this up to the netlify if you already
have some errors locally thankfully
everything is working so everything is
awesome and now again i'm going to have
to clear the integrated terminal as well
as stop the server and my first thing
would be setting this up as a git
repository so we're going to initialize
the git
get in it now once we do that the next
one would be adding all the styles or
not i'm sorry not all the styles all the
files so in order to do that of course
we're going to say git add and we're
going to add all of them
then after that why don't we do the
commit so git commit and what would be
the message i don't know
react
beach
beach application
something like this
at this moment we're committing and now
we would need this remote url so in this
case i'm going to copy and paste this
line
clear the console probably first now
this will gonna create my remote url and
last but not least i would want to push
it up to my
github repository so let's go back
get push
u
and origin will be master in our case
hopefully everything is working
hopefully we didn't push up the
environment development file because
otherwise everything that we did is kind
of useless anyway
uh let's refresh the browser let's see
okay this will be my project awesome and
now we're going to have to head over
back to indentify and we're gonna have
to click on this tab where we have new
site from git and of course in this case
i would need to choose my provider in my
case i will gonna choose the github and
then why don't we find right away the
file that i had or not file the
repository
and it was the react beach resort
recording however before we do anything
before we click on deploying the site we
would want to check out the advanced one
and add the same variables that we had
before otherwise basically you're going
to deploy the site it will going to
break and then you're going to have to
add them anyway so you might as well
skip that step and the way we're going
to do that we do need to copy and paste
these values so number one
and number two would be the value of
course
so this will be my space one
and then after that i would want another
one the access token
so let's go with this guy
copy and paste
and the same i'm going to do it over
here
copy and paste
once we have that let's deploy the site
now notify we're going to start building
the site and while the build process is
happening we're just going to go to the
site settings and we're going to change
the name and again why don't we change
the to react
beach
resort
recording
yeah i should do it let's save that and
it says the name is already taken
okay unfortunately that is the case why
don't we say youtube as well
i think this should work
and yes it is working we change
successfully
site name let's look at the deploy
currently we can even check it out how
the build process is happening
and as you can see right now this is
being built and if there will going to
be some errors you will be able to see
them now i do need to warn you that it
is kind of hard to work off the netlife
errors as you're getting them in most
cases you do need to troubleshoot and
that is not as easy as it seems but
anyway you can see if there's some kind
of error and let's say there would be an
access token error or something like
that it might show up here okay now
let's head over to the github we can
might as well close that the site is
still being built but no it's already
live awesome
let's
head over back to a site we're going to
click on here and of course this will be
my site and check this out i do have my
rooms awesome and if you remember we
were using the order and the order was
reversed so in this case everything
comes with a higher price first
then we do have the rooms
so we have the rooms we obviously can
have an option of filtering it
we can also have the error page where if
i'm not going to be able to find the
page let's say we're going to go with
hello notice remember we had our 404
page not found and this is where that
file remember we copy and paste in the
public dose redirect so if you're not
going to copy and paste that if you're
not going to use that simple line of
code then it will going to be directing
you basically to your
default netlify error page as well as
when you're going to be refreshing the
single page if you're going to click on
here and if you're going to be
refreshing the single page it will not
work in our case notice nothing breaks
and this is why it's important to
include those redirects we do have all
the pages everything is working and just
to show you that we are actually
connected nicely with contentful
let me show you one last thing if we're
going to head over let's say to con in
full and just because this is an easiest
option i will going to delete one of the
rooms that we have just so you can see
that this is working and the room that i
will gonna delete will be presidential
because that way we for sure know that
this would be something unique so first
and foremost we're gonna have to go with
then publish
okay so we're gonna unpublish it then it
shows that this is a draft already
now it's not published and then why
don't we delete it so we're gonna go
with deletion
and the moment we do that if i'm gonna
head over back to my project notice this
was previously the first one the moment
we're going to refresh what do you see
here i don't see any more presidential
and if you're going to look at all the
rooms we notice that we have one list so
now we know that everything has been
nicely connected to contentful and what
that means is that now your project
doesn't have to be in your local machine
you don't have to add all the changes in
fact you can work with your project data
exclusively on contentful hopefully you
guys enjoy the project and hopefully
i'll see you on my next project